welcome aspiring ethical hackers and
curious minds to the ultimate journey
into the fascinating world of cyber
security in this comprehensive ethical
hacker full course we will delve into
the realm of ethical hacking where we
will learn the art of securing digital
Landscapes while keeping the digital
world safe from malicious intent whether
you are a beginner or an experienced
Tech Enthusiast this course is designed
to equip you with the skills and
knowledge needed to become a proficient
ethical hacker so let's embark on this
adventure together as we unravel the
secrets of ethical hacking and Empower
ourselves with the tools to protect and
defend and before we begin if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply lar postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of computing the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered now let's take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success by opting
out these courses hi I'm Phillip I'm 61
years old and last year I up skill with
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the it sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that that
I was able to clear and pass my cissp
and ccsp certification exams on the
first attempt after taking the course
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors with many
companies before security analy and
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with infosis as a
cyber security consultant happened on
the first and if these are the types of
videos who would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press on
the Bell icon to never miss on any
future content so stay tuned with us
until end of this video and don't forget
to register your opinion in the comment
section below meet an she often shops
from www. shoppingcart
docomo free shopping
experience the required information is
stor in a server one day Anne received
an email which stated her eligibility
for a special discount voucher from
shopping cart.com in order to receive
the coupon code she was asked to fill in
her shopping cart.com account
credentials this didn't seem fishy to
her at the time as she thought it was
just an account verification step little
did she realize the danger she would be
facing she was knocked off her feet when
a substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account how did do you think
this happened well yes the email she
received was fake ANS shopping cart.com
account witnessed unauthorized access
from a third party this type of attack
is known as a Cyber attack and the
person who carries it out is called a
hacker could Ann have prevented this
attack indeed she could have with the
help of cyber security cyber security
involves techniques that help in
securing various digital components
networks data and computer systems from
unauthorized digital access there are
multiple ways to implement cyber
security depending on the kind of
network you are connected to and the
type of cyber attacks you are prone to
so let's take a look at the various
cyber attacks that an could have been
exposed to one of the most common types
of cyber attacks is a malware attack
like Trojan adwar and spyware to name a
few had Anne downloaded any suspicious
attachments online her system could have
gotten corrupted by certain malicious
viruses embedded within the attachments
next is a fishing attack the type of
Cyber attack which an experienced here
the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
legitimate Source this is done to
install malware or to steal sensitive
data like credit card information and
login
credentials another type of attack is
the man in the middle attack here the
hacker gains access to the information
path between an's device and the website
server the Hacker's computer takes over
an's IP address by doing so the
communication line between an and the
website is secretly intercepted this
commonly happens with unsecured Wi-Fi
networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system here an's password
could have been cracked by using either
common passwords or trying all possible
alphabetical combinations to to prevent
future cyber attacks and sought to
implement a few cyber security practices
first she installed a firewall as the
name suggests it is a virtual wall
between an's computer and the internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware reinforcements secondly and
implemented honeypots just like how
flowers attract bees dummy computer
systems called honeypots are used to
attract attackers these systems are made
to look vulnerable in order to deceive
attackers and this in turn defends the
real system in addition to these she
also decided to use unique alpha numeric
passwords antivirus software and started
avoiding males from unknown senders that
was an's story cyber attacks are not
just confined to individuals but also to
public and private organizations the
cyber attacks carried out in such places
are more deadly and they result in
colossal losses motives of such attacks
are many starting from tampering with
crucial data to monetary gains let's
have a look at a few of the cyber
attacks that companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat a in this form of
attack hackers gain access to networks
for a prolonged period in order to
continuously gain confidential
information
companies also witness the denial of
service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack when a hacker
manipulates a standard SQL query in a
database driven website it is known as a
SQL injection attack by doing so hackers
can view edit and delete tables from
databases amidst a plethora of cyber
attacks it is indeed a challenge for
organizations with several networks and
servers to ensure complete Security this
is not an easy task and to help with
this cyber Security Professionals are
hired to work on identifying cyber
threats and securing a company's Network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored such professionals try to exp a
networks vulnerable abilities just like
how a hacker would do but only to
identify those vulnerabilities and
resolve them for protection against an
actual Cyber attack but if you are
looking to design robust security
structures then the role of a security
architect is more apt a chief
information security officer ciso plays
a crucial role in Enterprise security
and is entrusted with the overall safety
of the information in an organization so
here's a question for you identify the
type of Cyber attack where the Hacker's
system takes over the client's IP
address a DDOS attack B man in the-
Middle attack c fishing attack d
password attack give it a thought and
leave your answers in the comment
section below three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers with the
increase in the production of global
Digital Data it is anticipated that
cyber attacks will quadruple in the near
future organizations are going to need
cyber security professionals who can
prevent these attacks a career in the
field of cyber security is lucrative and
a very smart decision for professionals
now we humans are highly tech-savvy in
today's times with the extensive use of
the internet and modern Technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our Digital Data such as
net banking information account
credentials and medical reports to name
a few have you heard about the deadly
want to cry ransomware attack the attack
happened in May 2017 in Asia and then it
spread across the world within a day
more than 230,000 computers were
infected across 150 countries the oneac
cry crypto worm encrypted the data and
locked the users out of their systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to $600
in Bitcoin the users who used the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one a cry
attack took a toll on every sector top
tier organizations like Itachi Nissan
and FedEx had to put their businesses on
hold as their systems were affected too
now this is what you call a Cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can Define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital attacks these illegal attacks
are often referred to as hacking hacking
refers to exploiting weaknesses in a
computer network to obtain unauthorized
access to information a hacker is a
person who tries to hack into computer
systems this is a misconception that
hacking is always wrong there are
hackers who work with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers black hat hackers are
individuals who illegally hack into a
system for a monetary gain on the
contrary we have white hat hackers who
exploit the vulnerabilities in a system
by hacking into it with permission in
order to defend the organization this
form of hacking is absolutely legal and
ethical hence they are also often
referred to as ethical hackers in
addition to these hackers we also have
the grey hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black these hackers
discover vulnerabilities in a system and
report it to the system's owner which is
a good act but they do this without
seeking the owner's approval sometimes
greyh hat hackers also ask for money in
return for the spotted
vulnerabilities now that you have seen
the different types of hackers let's
understand more about the hacking that
is legal and valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story Dan runs a
Trading Company he does online training
with the money his customers invest
everything was going well and and Dan's
business was booming until a hacker
decided to hack the company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lump some Ransom in exchange for the
stolen credentials Dan took the Hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and Dan
was liable to pay back the customers Dan
lost a lot of money and also the trust
of his customers after this incident Dan
gave a lot of thought as to what could
have gone wrong with the security
infrastructure in his company he wished
there was someone from his company who
could have run a test attack to see how
vulnerable systems were before the
hacker penetrated into the network this
was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does to do
this job he hired an ethical hacker John
John was a skilled professional who
worked precisely ly like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation so now you know hacking is
not always bad Jon in this scenario
exposed the vulnerabilities in the
existing Network and such hacking is
known as ethical hacking ethical hacking
is distributed into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how John our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step Jon takes is to
gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like inmap
and hping for this purpose JN then tries
to spot the vulnerabilities if any in
the Target system using tools like in
map and Expos this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after Jon makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system the metas sploit tool helps him
with this this phase is called
maintaining access John is a brilliant
hacker he hence he tries his best not to
leave any evidence of his attack this is
the fifth phase clearing tracks we now
have the last phase that is reported in
this phase Jon documents a summary of
his entire attack the vulnerabilities he
spotted the tools he used and the
success rate of the attack looking into
the report Dan is now able to take a
call and see how to protect his
organization from any external cyber
attacks don't you all think John is an
asset to any organization if you want to
become an ethical hacker like John then
there are a few skills that you need to
acquire first and foremost you need to
have a good knowledge of operating
environments such as Windows Linux Unix
and Macintosh you must have reasonably
good knowledge of programming languages
such as HTML PHP python SQL and
JavaScript networking is the base of
ethical hacking hence you should be good
at added ethical hackers should be well
aware of security laws so that they
don't misuse their skills finally you
must have a global certification on
ethical hacking to successfully bag a
position of an ethical hacker like John
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification C CompTIA pentest
plus and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few simply learn
provides a cyber security expert master
program that will equip you with all the
skills required by a cyber security
expert you could have a look at it by
clicking the link in the description so
here's a question for you in which phase
of ethical hacking will you install back
doors in the Target system a scanning B
maintaining access C clearing tracks D
reconnaissance give it a thought and
leave your answers in the comment
section below three lucky winners will
will receive Amazon gift vouchers the
endless growth of Technologies in this
area is directly proportional to the
number of cyber crimes cyber crimes are
estimated to cost $6 trillion in 2021
hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber Security Professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is $91,000 in the US and
approximately rupe's 7 lakhs in India so
what are you waiting for get certified
and become an ethical hacker like John
and put an end to the cyber attacks in
the world data is the new goal imagine
how much data is generated by just your
smartphone every single day be the
pictures you click or the messages you
send nearly 41 million messages are sent
worldwide via WhatsApp every single
minute so safeguarding your personal
data against hackers has now become a
top priority did you know that India
leads the world when it comes to ethical
hackers with 23% of the world hacking
population from India the top ethical
hackers earn more than twice of what
software engineers in India do but what
makes ethical hacking such a demanding
industry ethical hacking is the process
of taking security measures to safeguard
data and networks from malicious cyber
attacks the hackers use every tool at
their disposal to try and breach the
security barrier and find any potential
vulnerabilities the ethical in ethical
hacking denotes the lack of malicious
intent since these sessions are often
permitted by the system owner or the
that is being hacked into to fix any
compromised entry points before black
hat hackers discover and exploit them so
what is a black hat hacker you may ask a
hacker who exploits security
vulnerabilities for monetary gains like
stealing or destroying private data
altering disrupting or shutting down
websites and networks is known as a
blackhead hacker on the other end of the
spectrum we have white hat hackers who
help people secure the networks by
stress testing the platform against the
most dangerous of cyber attacks that is
with their consent of course but the
most mutal of the bunch are gray hat
hackers who may not ask for consent
before snooping on a foreign system but
they do inform the owner if they find
any vulnerabilities sometimes in
exchange for a small fee the security
breaches have become less and less
prevalent thanks to rigorous ethical
hacking campaigns and corporate
awareness programs the ability to fix
critical security issues before blackout
hackers leverage them has saved
organizations billions of dollars Google
IBM Microsoft and virtually every major
corporation are looking to protect the
data so it shouldn't come as a surprise
that the ethical hacking and information
security job market is set to rise by
nearly 28% by 2026 but salaries going as
high as
$225,000 perom so that's ethical hacking
wrapped up in 2 minutes to catch more
bite size and detailed videos on
different Technologies subscribe to
Simply learn and stay updated in today's
digital age where cyber threats Loom
large understanding ethical hacking is
crucial by dwelling into the world of
ethical hacking you gain a deep
comprehension of hacker techniques and
vulnerabilities which will enable you to
strengthen your security measures with
the demand for cyber Security
Professionals soaring learning ethical
hacking opens doors to wide range of
exciting career opportunities moreover
it empowers you to protect your personal
data and privacy while staying one step
ahead of evolving cyber threats by
embracing ethical hacking responsibility
you contribute to a safer digital
envirment enhance problem solving skills
and Foster continuous growth get ready
to embark on an exciting journey into
the realm of ethical hacking and
discover its immense value in today's
interconnected world and if you are
someone who's interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elects to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the expert experts then try giving
a shot to Simply learns postgraduate
program in cyber security from Schwan's
College of computing in collaboration
with EC counil the link in the
description box page where you can find
a complete overview of the program being
offered take action up skill and get
ahead but before we begin if these are
the type of videos you would like
subscribe button and click on the Bell
to never miss an update from Simply long
without further Ado let's get started
with understanding why you must learn
ethical hacking there are a wide variety
of reasons of why to learn ethical
hacking let's discuss the important ones
firstly cyber security awareness next
strengthen security measures career
opportunities protection of personal
data awareness of cyber threats ethical
use of skills problem solving and
continuous learning now that we have few
important reasons let's discuss each one
of these important reasons in a bit more
detail firstly cyber security awareness
learning about ethical hacking provides
you with a deep understanding of the
techniques and methods used by hackers
this knowledge helps you identify
vulnerabilities in your computer systems
networks and applications enabling you
to better protect them the next one is
strengthening security measures by
learning ethical hacking you can
actively contribute to impr improving
the security of computer systems ethical
hackers often identify weaknesses in
organizations networks and provide
recommendations for enhancing security
measures followed by that we have career
opportunities the field of cybering and
there is a high demand for skilled
professionals by acquiring knowledge of
ethical hacking you can open up various
career opportunities in Industries such
as it security Consulting penetration
testing and incidence response next next
ahead we have protection of personal
data understanding ethical hacking
techniques empowers you to safeguard
your personal data with privacy you can
Implement security measures to protect
your devices online accounts and
sensitive information from potential
attacks awareness of cyber threats is
the next one on the list the digital
landscape is constantly evolving and new
threats emerge regularly learning
ethical hacking helps you stay up toate
with the latest cyber threats attack
vectors and vulnerabilities enabling you
to proactive your measures to mitigate
the risks followed by that we have
ethical use of skills ethical hacking
emphasizes the responsible and legal use
of hacking techniques by learning
ethical hacking you gain the knowledge
of the ethical guidelines and legal
boundaries associated with cyber
security this ensures that your skills
are utilized for positive purposes
protecting individuals and organizations
from malicious attacks next on the list
is problem solving skills ethical
hacking requires critical thinking
problem solving and analytical skills
through learning ethical hacking you
develop a systematic approach to
identifying and solving complex security
issues which can be valuable in various
aspects of life and other technical
domains next and the list is continuous
learning and growth cyber security is a
dynamic field that demands continuous
learning to keep up with evolving cyber
threats learning ethical hacking ensures
that you remain engaged on ongoing
education and skill development
fostering personal and professional
growth now let's get into the important
aspect of today's tutorial that is
salary details for a certified ethical
hacker in the United States of America
the salary of an ethical hacker can be
based on various factors such as
experience skill level location
industry and the organization they work
for generally ethical hackers in USA
tend to earn higher salaries than other
countries due to the demand for cyber
Security Professionals entry-level
positions may start around $60 to
$80,000 perom while experienced
professionals with Advanced
certifications and specialized skills
can earn salaries exceeding
$150,000 per anom the salary of ethical
hacker in India can vary depending on
factors such as experience skill set
location and organization they work for
on an average a beginner level ethical
hacker in enging from 3 laks to six
lakhs per anom as they gain more
experience and
expertise their salary can increase
significantly experien ethical hackers
with several years of experience and
advanced certifications can earn
salaries ranging from 8 to 20 lakhs or
more annually now proceeding with the
company's hiring ethical hacker hackers
several companies hire ethical hackers
to enhance their cyber security defenses
and protect their systems here are some
prominent companies known for hiring
ethical hackers Google Facebook
Microsoft Apple Amazon IBM Cisco Intel
deoe and evi are the most prominent ones
the topics that we are going to discuss
in this video are what exactly hacking
is the types of hackers the
classifications what is ethical hacking
the skills that are requireed of an
ethical hacker the process that is
utilized by ethical hackers in their
daily activities and then we lastly
we're going to discuss cryptography so
let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is hacking refers to
exploiting weaknesses in a computer
network to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some key words that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you're exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a Security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that you
not allowed to do and when you say a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
it's basically a person with malicious
is intent trying to gain access to a
system or a resource that they are not
authorized to access in the first place
how do they do it they find a
avilability that is a weakness or a flaw
and then they misuse it to gain access
to that particular Network so here in
the diagram you can see that a sender on
the left hand side is trying to send
some data to the receiver on the right
hand side the hacker would try to gain
unauthorized access to the transmission
that is being sent and would try to
capture the data packets and read the
secrets within let's look at a business
case scenario into hacking now there is
an organization uh everybody is going
around their own business when they
realize that their systems may have been
compromised now they're trying to look
at the customer data to ensure that that
has not been compromised and trying to
assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there is an attack that
has happened and based on that attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified by the hacker which means
that the data is no longer trustworthy
and thus cannot be used by the business
for any legal transactions so then the
hacker gives a call to the organization
or gets connected to the organization
demanding a ransom for the data to be
replaced to be taken back into the
original state where it was trusted and
thus the organization can utilize it for
business transactions the organization
has probably no backup so they decide
that they want to pay the lumpsum to the
hacker to restore that data so that they
can continue on with the business does
money exchanges and the hacker is able
to restore that data and the business
continues that as usual however the
activity here of a hacker trying to
Leverage The misconfiguration of the
weaknesses in the organizations security
thus being able to hack them and uh make
these Ransom w demands so the company
then wants to figure out even if having
a security system in place how was the
hacker able to hack their systems thus
one of the employees comes up with a
brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities in the network uh to
proactively search for any flaws that
have been left behind uh so that they
can plug those flaws and nobody can
misuse them thus they figure out that
they want to hire ethical hacker who
would help them identify the security
posture of the organization identify the
weaknesses with V abilities and flaws
and help them remedy those flaws so that
in future scenarios these scenarios will
not happen so before we go into an
ethical hacker let's understand what are
the types of hackers so what are the
types of hackers hacker is a technically
skilled person uh who is very Adept with
computers they have good programming
skills they understand how operating
system works they understand how
networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and viabilities within
all of these aspects and then they
understand and know how to misuse these
flaws to get a outcome which would be
detrimental to the health of the
organization so there are six type of
hackers that have been identified black
hat hackers white hat hackers gray hat
script kitties nation sponsored hackers
and a activist so blackhe hat hackers
are Bas basically uh the malicious
hackers who have malicious intent and
have criminalistic Tendencies they want
to harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying their data
so that uh they can gain from it from a
monetary perspective uh these guys are
also known as crackers the main aspect
of these uh people are that they have
malicious intent they try to do
unauthorized activities and they try it
for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity uh they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their IP addresses Mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network why that hacker on the other
hand is also an ethical hacker or a
security analyst who's an individual who
will do exactly the same thing that a
blackhead hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security posture so
these uh these kind of Security Experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks gray hat hackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity scrip
kites are people uh who are technically
not much aware about what hacking is uh
they rely on existing tools that have
been created by other hackers they have
no technical knowledge of what they're
doing it's just a hit or miss for them
so they just get their hands on a tool
they try to execute those tools uh if
the hack works it works otherwise it
doesn't so these people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or uh just uh people
who with malice's intent who just want
to have some fun or trying to impress
people around then we have the nation or
the state sponsored hackers as the name
suggest these hackers are sponsored by
their government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers uh enrolled
in their pay on um on their uh
organizations to spy on their enemies to
spy on various countries and try to
figure out uh the aspirations of those
count so this is basically a spying
activity where you technically trying to
get access to other Count's resources
and then try to spy on them to figure
out what their activities have been or
what their future plans have been and
then we have the activists who is an
individual who has a political agenda to
promote and they promote it by doing
hacking so uh these guys what is the
difference between a blackhe hat hacker
and a activist the blackhe Hat hacker
may try to hide their identity a
activist will claim responsibility of
what they have done so for them it's a
political agenda political cause and
they will try to hack various
organizations to promote their cause
they would probably do this by defacing
the website and posting the messages
that they want to promote on these
websites so what exactly is ethical
hacking n we have discussed the types of
hackers we have identified a malicious
hacker as a black hat hacker with the
intent uh of doing harm to an
organization's Network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in an
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization it would
give them a definite scope of what
they're allowed to do and what they are
not allowed to do and the ethical
hackers would function within those
Scopes would try to execute those test
scenarios where they would be able to
identify those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that blackhe hat hackers do
however the main difference here is that
these guys are authorized tries to do
that particular activity they're doing
it in a controlled manner with the
intent of helping the organization and
not with the intent of personal games so
who's an ethical hacker again ethical
hacker is a highly intelligent Highly
Educated person who knows how computers
function how programming languages work
how operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
Adept at Computing they understand the
architecture they understand uh how
various components in a computer work
they can troubleshoot those components
and they can basically be uh very good
with programming as well now when I say
programming we don't want the ethical
hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
Trojans or exploits which would help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they are individuals
who perform a security assessment of
their companies with the permission of
cons concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they have been configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire a ethical hacker
they they would give the ethical hacker
the information about what information
is or what security controls what
firewalls what idss ipss inent detection
or intrusion prevention systems
antiviruses are already in place and
then they will ask the ethical hacker to
figure out a way to bypass these
mechanisms and see if they can still
hack the organization what is the need
of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those flaws to help
secure the organization from blackhe hat
hackers so ethical hackers would prevent
Hackers from cracking into an
organization's Network by securing the
organization by improving on their
security on a periodic basis and they
would also try to identify system
vulnerabilities Network vulnerabilities
or application Level vulnerabilities
that would have been missed or have
already been missed and then tried to
figure out a way of plugging them or uh
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze and enhance an organization
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are uh they contain the alphabet A
through Zed uppercase and lowercase 0
through 9 as numerics and special
characters and they're randomized so
that the password becomes more more
stronger to prevent from Brute Force
attacks so what would an ethical hacker
do at this point in time they would try
to test the strength of the passwords to
see if Brute Force attacks or dictionary
attacks are possible and if any of these
passwords can be cracked they would
ensure that all the employees are
following the policies and all the
passwords are are as secured as the
policies want them to be if there are
any gaps in the policies or the
implementation of the policy it is the
ethical hacker responsibility to
identify those gaps and War the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by by
the organization that is critical for
the functioning of the organization and
they'll try to protect it by from
falling into the Hacker's hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as Windows Linux Unix and
Mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security Center of Windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with Linux and uh
Mac softwares operating systems so we
need to know we can secure these
operating systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as a
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time they should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
PHP python Ruby HTML for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for an ethical
hacker should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're in application security
you're in network security or you're in
host base security since a computer will
always be connected to a network either
a local area network like a lan or the
internet we should know how networking
works we should know the seven layers of
the OSI model we should know which
protocols work on those seven layers we
should identify the tcpip model and how
OSI model can be mapped to the tcpip
model we should understand how TCP and
UDP work how how each and every protocol
is crafted how they are supposed to
behave for us to analyze and understand
any network based attacks we should be
very good in security measures so we
should know where those vulnerabilities
would lie what are the latest exploits
available in the market and we should be
able to identify them we should be able
to know the techniques and the tools of
how to deal with security how to analyze
security and then how to implement
security to enhance it as well along
with that it is important that a
security analyst or ethical hacker is
aware of the local security laws and
standards why is that because an
organization cannot do any illegal
activity whatever responses that they
have whatever security mechanic Ms
whatever security controls they will
Implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause
undue harm to any of the employees or
any of the third party clients that they
are dealing with so the ethical hackers
should be aware of what uh security laws
are before they Implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming uh it's good to
have a certification in PHP Pearl python
Ruby and so on so forth why because most
of the organizations when they hire
ethical hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize uh in their testing scenarios to
be honest there are hundreds of tools
out there what you see on the screen are
just a few examples of them uh nessus is
a vulnerability scanner what is a
vulnerability scanner it is an automated
tool that is designed to identify
vulnerabilities within hosts within uh
operating systems within networks so
they come with their rade databases of
all the vulnerabilities that have
already been identified and they scan
the network against that database to
find out any possible flaws or any
possible vulnerabilities that currently
exist on the host or the operating
system or on the network similarly there
would be application scanners like actic
or Arachne that would help you scan
applications and identify flaws within
those applications as well now all of
these are automated tools the essence of
ethical hacker is when these tools churn
out their reports the ethical haer
hacker can understand these reports
analyze them identify the flaws and then
craft their own exploits or use existing
exploits in a particular manner so that
they can get access or they can bypass
the access security controls mechanisms
that are already in place how can they
do that with the tool called metas
sploid you see that Big M there on the
right hand side that M logo is for a
tool called Metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool NS identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using metas sploid to validate those
flaws and to verify that those flaws
actually exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metas flid helps us do that wire
Shar would be used in the background
while we are doing both the activities
using nessus or metas sploit to keep a
track of what packets are being sent and
by received on the network which will
help us analyze those packets so
whenever I run a a scanner I would run a
yre Shar in the background it will
capture the data packets and I can go
through those data packets and analyze
that data packets to identify what
nesses is actually trying to do
similarly when I try to attack a machine
using exploit on metas exploit I will
keep on wire shock running in the
background to capture the data packets
that have been sent and the responses
that I've received from the victim so
that I can also go through those packets
and analyze the responses and analyze
the attack whether it was successful to
what extent was was it successful and
basically will also give me a validation
a proof of the activity that has
happened nmap is another automated tool
that allows me to scan for open ports
and protocols so why would I use nmap
because Pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect
through a web browser but we
automatically connect to Port 80 using
HTTP and Port 443 using https so if I'm
connecting to a web server using https
it is safe to assume that Port 443 on
the web server is open to accept those
connections similarly there would be
other services that may be left open on
the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted Services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then I can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that I'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
I want to do a SQL injection attack or
if I if nessus tells me that there's a
SQL injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
I can use an automated tool called SQL
map or SQL map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a SQL injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here I do not have to manually
create my own queries uh the SQL app
tool would automatically create them for
me what I would do is I would use nessus
to identify that particular flaw if
nessus reports that flaw I would then go
use the tool SQL map configure it to
attack that particular web server and
when I fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
SQL injection queries to the database to
see if those uh databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me have
hack networks applications operating
systems and host devices and this is
what ethical hacker does they use these
kind of tool sets they identify what
attacks they need to do they identify
the right tool for that particular
attack and they write their exploits
they create those attacks and then they
start attacking analyze the response and
then give a report to the management uh
providing them feedback about how the
attack was created or crafted what was
the response to that attack and whether
the attack was successful or not if
successful there would also give
recommendations of what to do to prevent
these attacks from happening in the
future so when we are doing these
attacks or when we want to launch these
attacks what is the process that that we
would follow so there are six steps that
we would do as an ethical hacker if you
are just a hacker you probably wouldn't
do the sixth step which is a reporting
step so the first step that would be
done is the recognizance phase which is
the information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hacker
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a Windows
based server and I use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a Linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so I need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase I want to
identify all of that information once I
have that information done I'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we're
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap I would run
a vulnerability scanner the NS
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
actic for applications and then I would
try to identify vulnerabilities in those
applications operating systems or
networks once I've have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access uh by either tracking passwords
or escalating privileges or exploiting a
avability that I may have found during
the scanning phase once I have gained my
access I want to maintain my access why
because the vulnerability may not be
there for long maybe somebody updated
the operating system and hence the flaw
was no longer exist existing or somebody
changed the password that may I may have
cracked does I no longer have access so
what do I do to maintain my access I
install Trojans or backd door entries to
those systems using which I can secretly
in a covert manner get access to those
devices at my own will at my own time as
long as those devices are available over
the network so that's where I maintain
my access I have hacked them now I want
to maintain my access so I install a
software which would give me a backd
door entry to that device no matter what
once I've done this I want to clear my
track so whatever activity that I've
been doing for example installing a
Trojan a Trojan is also a software that
would create directory directories and
files once installed on the victim's
machine so I want to hide that if I have
access data stores if I have modified
data I want to hide that activity
because because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline thus my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason I'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so I would be
deleting references of any of the IP
addresses or Mac addresses that I may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is is where I will be
able to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once I
take off those traces the victim would
not be any visor of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I'm successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we ID IFI 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or or the expected output
of that attack I'll create a report
which would give a detailed analysis of
all the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that the ethical hacking process would
take uh just going through this the uh
recognizance is where you're going to
use hacking tools like n map HP to
obtain information about targets there
are hundreds of tools out there
depending on what information you want
then in scanning again n map next p
these kind of tools to be utilized to
identify open ports protocols and
services in gaining access you're going
to exploit the vulnerability by using
the metas sploit tool that we talked
about in the previous slides in the
maintaining access you're going to
install back doors you can use metas at
the same time uh you can craft your own
scripts to create a Trojan and install
it on the victim's machine once you have
achieved that clearing tracks is where
you're going to clear all evidences of
your activity so that you do not get
caught or the victim doesn't even
realize that they have been hacked and
once you done all of this we going to
create reports that are going to be
submitted to the management to help them
understand the current security
evaluation of their or organization so
now let's see how we can hack using
social engineering now what is social
engineering social engineering is the
art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you're able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's look
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is fishing
we receive a lot of fake mails on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those Nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some South
African country and you out of 7 billion
people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million do through your
account and they want to give you 50% of
that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go on
to websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the 1 millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your prize
all of these are social engineering
attacks fishing attacks fake websites
fake Communications being sent out to
users to pray on their Gully bleeding
most of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge Lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those mails it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those Communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotion
machines do not try pleading with a
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social inuring attack where
you can plead with them saying if I do
not get access to this account
immediately I might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but person
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your LinkedIn
profile where person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you were in right similarly it
might also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's uh I mean if a person
can interact with you let's say say
they're trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it fishing as
discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing uh comes into
mind fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is a
open a generic attack whoever Falls
victim will fall victim so if I just
throw around a few USBS in the parking
lot obviously with Trojans implemented
on them some people who are curious or
who are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at at the same time
once they plug in their those pen drives
on their computers the virus or the
Trojan would get infected and cause harm
to their machine then exploiting human
greed uh we just talked about the
Nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money-making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
pray upon the persons greed kicking in
and they clicking on those links in
order to uh get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we just
making it unreadable or non-readable by
using a particular key or a particular
algorithm and then we're going to send
the the key to the end user the end user
using the uh same key would then decrypt
that data if anybody compromises that
data while it is being sent over the
network since it is encrypted they would
not be able to read it so the encryption
algorithm would be something like this
now if you see uh the computer word once
made into unreadable format would look
like EQ o r XV GT for a end user it
wouldn't make any sense but the person
who has a key to unscramble that would
be able to convert it back to computer
and then understand the meaning of that
word so this is just a substitution
Cipher that is being shown on the screen
so what is the alphabet the key is
alphabet plus 3 so C plus three
alphabets that becomes e o becomes q m
becomes o so the key that is utilized to
scramble the data is the character that
you are at the third character from
there would be the corresponding key so
the encrypted message is also known as a
cipher the decryption is just the other
way around where you know the key now
and and you can now figure out what that
e corresponded to by going back three
characters in the alphabet most of the
times a certified ethical hacker must
decrypt a message without knowing the
secret key so let's say a ransomware has
affected your organization or has
affected a device and you want to figure
out uh or you want to decrypt that data
now as a ethical hacker you wouldn't be
for paying a ransom uh to the hacker
would you so it is now your prerogative
of how you're going to work around and
how you're going to try to crack the
encryption mechanism how to crack the
cipher to decrypt that message and see
what's within it right decryption
without the use of a secret key that is
known as a crypt analysis Crypt analysis
is the reversing of an algorithm to
figure out what the decryption was uh
without using a key so Crypt analysis
can be done using various formats the
first one is a Brute Force attack second
is a dictionary attack third one is a
rainbow table attack a Brute Force
attack is trying every combination
permutation and combination of the the
key to figure out what the key was it is
100% successful but may take a lot of
time a dictionary attack is where you
have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you Tred to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out uh the similarities between the text
that you have and the encrypted data
that you wanted to decrypt in the first
place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tantamount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the cipher
text is compared with another Cipher
text you find out similarities and then
you try to work a reverse engineer your
way accordingly so let's have a quick
demo on cryptography before we be end
this session so to begin with the demo
of cryptography we are on a website
called spam mic.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
I say I want to encode a message turn a
short message into spam so what this
does is you want to send across a secret
message you type in The Secret Message a
short one it will convert that into a
spam mail you send it across so whoever
is reading that spam mail would never
get an idea of the embedded message
within it so if I want to type in a
message here hi this is a secret message
the password is ASD at12 34 and I want
to send this out to people or to one of
my colleagues but I want to send it out
in a secret manner so that others are
not aware of this so when I press on
encode what the algorithm would do is it
will convert this message into a spam
mail so my message hi this is a secret
message the password is at theate 1 234
or ASD at theate 1 234 4 gets converted
into this now if you read it dear
e-commerce professional this letter was
specially selected to be sent to you
this doesn't make sense there is nowhere
or no reference to the actual message
that I've already said so if I copy this
entire message and I send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
I've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is Spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
open up a new browser and I'm going to
go to the same website and at this point
in time I'm going to click on decode
when I click on decode I'm going to
paste the message that I have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if I decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we we paste the message in the decode
Factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the Google Chrome
browser and in the Firefox browser we
decoded similarly if I want to protect
these kind of messages there is an aspen
encrypt.me ASD at 1 2 3 4 and then I
give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
I use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say AES which is the
strongest Cipher right now and I say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically uh if I
don't have the password over here if I
decrypt it you would see that the error
has occurred now if I type in the
password over here and then decrypt it
it will be able to convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original message was
this is a secret message the password is
ASD at1 234 so if I want to keep my data
secure from hackers I want to scramble
it in such a way that they would not be
able to crack it or it would be very
difficult for for them to crack it and
this is one of the first mechanisms that
would be recommended by any ethical
hacker and before we begin if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or iCal hacker by learning from
the experts and try giving a short to
Simply Larn postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of computing the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered hello everyone and welcome
to this video on the hackers road map at
the simply land YouTube channel as vast
as the field of cyber security is
there's often an overflow of information
about it at the same time for people who
wish to know more about how to venture
into the cyber security or ethical
hacking space it is very important for
them to know what's the career
progression what are the skills needed
and how a person with no or bare minimum
knowledge can take the first step in
this amazing career well this video is
for all those individuals who wish to
pursue a career in the field of cyber
security and ethical hacking whether you
are an entry-level professional a
college graduate or an experienced
professional looking to understand how a
career in the field of cyber security
progresses and what additional skills
and responsibilities would you need as
you grow in the field then you are at
the right place so let's get started
with our topic the hackers road map and
before we begin if you are someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
at sits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply lar
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of Engineering the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will now get you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered and if
these are the types of videos you would
like to watch then hit the Subscribe
button like and press on the Bell icon
to never miss on further content so stay
tuned with us until the end of this
video and don't forget to register your
opinion in the comment section below and
now we will start with what is ethical
hacking and how is it different from
hacking so in the world of cyber
security hacking can be broadly
categorized into two types ethical
hacking and unethical hacking ethical
hacking involves using the same tools
and techniques as malicious hackers to
identify and fix security
vulnerabilities before they can be
exploited and these expert known as
Whitehead hackers work with a focus on
security rather on theft and on the
other hand we have unethical hacking
that refers to unauthorized access to
digital devices or networks with
malicious intent performed by black hat
hackers and additionally there are gray
attackers who possess knowledge in
offensive and defensive computer use
sometimes work working as Security
Consultants during the day and engaging
in black hat activities at night it is
important to understand these
distinctions to protect against cyber
threats effectively now we'll see the
objective or roles of an ethical hacker
ethical hackers also known as white head
hackers use their skills and expertise
to identify vulnerabilities in system
and network before malicious hackers can
exploit them their primary objective is
to simulate real world attacks and help
organizations strengthen their security
measures
the role of an ethical hacker involves
several key phases and we'll see those
roles and key phases so they are
responsible for reconnaissance scanning
can and maintain access clear their
tracks document their findings and
compile detailed reports so firstly they
conduct thoro Recon gathering
information about the target system or
organization this includes understanding
the organization structure Network
infrastructure and potential weak points
and through scanning they identify the
easiest and quickest methods to gain
access to the network and gather further
information and once access is gained
ethical hackers maintain it allowing
them to exercise their Privileges and
control the connected systems this step
helps them identify any potential
security flows and weaknesses within the
network they also work to clear their
tracks covering their footsteps to evade
detection and ensuring the SEC security
personel cannot Trace their activities
and throughout the entire process
ethical hackers document their findings
compile detailed reports on the
vulnerabilities discovered and provide
recommendations to address and mitigate
the identified security issues their
vulnerability goal is to help
organization strengthen their defenses
prevent data breaches and protect
sensitive information from falling into
the wrong hands ethical hacking is a
crucial aspect of cyber security as it
allows organizations to stay one step
ahead of cyber threats by leveraging the
skills of ethical hackers businesses can
proactively identify and address
vulnerabilities ensuring the overall
security and integrity of their digital
infrastructure so now we'll see the
skills that needed to be an ethical
hacker so now we'll see the skills so
the first skill is knowledge of computer
networks then it's the programming
languages then the knowledge of web
applications databases ethical hacking
tools and knowledge of common attack
vectors and techniques then what
certificates that are required for an
ethical hacker now we'll start with
knowledge of computer networks
understanding computer networks is
fundamental for ethical hackers this
includes Concepts such as IP addressing
Network protocols example TCP IP routing
switching and firewalls a strong grasp
of how networks function will enable you
to identify vulnerabilities and
potential entry points the next is
programming languages Proficiency in
programming languages is is essential
for Effective ethical hacking languages
like python Java C++ and scripting
languages such as Pearl or ruik are
widely used in this field programming
skills enable you to write custom
scripts and tools automate task and
explore vulnerabilities and the next we
have is web applications in today's
digital landscape web applications are
often the target of attacks therefore a
solid understanding of web application
architecture protocols example HTTP and
security mechanisms example SSL TLS is
crucial knowledge of web programming
languages like HTML CSS JavaScript and
Frameworks like PHP or asp.net is also
beneficial then we have databases so
databases store and manage sensitive
data making them attractive targets for
hackers familiarize yourself with
database Management systems dbms such as
MySQL orle or Microsoft SQL Server learn
about database security including access
control encryption and vulnerability
assessment then we should focus on the
skill to have a knowledge on ethical
hacking tools so to perform ethical
hacking task efficiently you should be
familiar with various hacking tools
these include Network scanners example n
map vulnerability scanners example
nessas password crackers joone the riper
packet snipers W shck and exploitation
Frameworks metas sploit mastering these
tools will enhance your Effectiveness as
an ethical hacker then you should have
knowledge of common attack vectors and
techniques that is understanding common
attack vectors and techniques is vital
for an ethical hacker this includes
knowledge of different types of malware
social engineering Network attacks that
is DDOS and web application
vulnerabilities example crite scripting
staying up to date with the latest
threats and attack methodologies is
crucial for Effective defense the next
is certificates so obtaining relevant
certifications demonstrates your
expertise and commit ment to the field
certificates like certified ethical
hacker CH offensive security certificate
professional OSP or coma Security Plus
are highly regarded within the industry
they validate your skills and can boost
your credibility when seeking ethical
hacking opportunities the CH
certification is a multiple choice exam
that evaluates your understanding of the
penetration testing structure and the
tools that are utilized inside it it
gives job Seekers the information
security field a Head Start by ensuring
that the certificate holder understands
the fundamentals such as information
gathering attacking computers or servers
Wireless attacks and social engineering
so the objective of CHS inform the
public that credentialed individuals
meet or exceed the minimum standards
second establish and govern minimum
standards of credit
enity third professional information
security specialist in ethical hacking
so now we'll have an exam overview so
the exam name is EC Council certified
ethical hacker and the exam duration is
240 minutes and you will get questions
that is 125 questions you will get in
the exam and it is a multiple choice
question exam and the passing score you
need is
70% and to register for the exam you
should go to peon view or ECC Exam
Center and eligibility criteria for CHS
there are two ways to satisfy the
eligibility criteria
that is attend official CH training and
this can be in any format example
instructor Le training computer Based
training or live online training as long
as the program is approved by EC Council
and attempt without official training in
order to be considered for the EC
council certification exam without
attending official training you must
have two or more years of documented
information security experience remit a
non-refundable eligibility application
fee of $100 submit completed CH exam
elig ibility form including verification
from an employer upon approval EC
Council will email your voucher number
to register for the CH exam so this was
all about the CH exam and now we'll move
to the steps to become ethical hacker so
ethical hacking is an exciting and
rapidly growing field that requires a
combination of technical skills
knowledge and a strong sense of Ethics
by following these steps you can begin
your journey towards becoming an ethical
hacker and contribute to enhancing cyber
security so step one that is knowledge
of computer systems and networks step
two you should have Proficiency in
programming languages step three
networking and security Concepts you
should have a knowledge of it third
knowledge of web application and
database fifth understanding of
operating systems step six familiarity
with ethical hacking tools step seven
problem solving and analytical thinking
step eight knowledge of common attack
vectors and techniques step nine
certifications so now we'll elaborate
all the steps one by one so we'll start
with knowledge of computer systems and
networks so to become an ethical hacker
it is crucial to have a deep
understanding of computer systems and
networks this involves familiarizing
yourself with the inner workings of
computer system Network protocols
operating systems and how different
components interact within a network
environment by gaining this knowledge
you will be better equipped to identify
vulnerabilities and assess potential
security risk and the next is
proficiency programming languages so
programming languages are an essential
tool for ethical hackers by gaining
Proficiency in programming languages
such as python C++ Java JavaScript SQL
per and Ruby you will be able to develop
your own scripts automate task and
create exploit codes these programming
languages provide the foundation for
writing secure and efficient code as
well as manipulating and analyzing data
the next step is networking and security
Concepts to effectively assess and
secure network it is important to have a
solid understanding of networking and
security concept this includes
familiarizing yourself with topics such
as Network protocols network security
principles encryption techniques and
firewall configurations understanding
how data is transmitted secured and
protected in a network environment will
enable you to identify potential
vulnerabilities and Implement
appropriate security measures step four
knowledge of web application and
database knowledge so in today's
interconnected world web applications
and databases are common targets for
hackers therefore it is crucial to
develop a strong understanding of web
application architectures web protocols
and database systems pay special
attention to Common vulnerabilities
specific to web applications such as SQL
injection crite scripting xss and crite
request forgery csrf by gaining
expertise in these areas you will be
able to effectively assess the security
of web applications and databases and
provide appropriate recommendations for
securing them and the next step is
understanding of operating systems so
operating systems form the backbone of
computer systems and are often targeted
by hackers it is important to gain a
comprehensive understanding of different
operating systems such as Windows Linux
or Mac OS this includes understanding
system configurations file permissions
user management and security mechanism
specific to each operating system this
knowledge will enable you to identify
vulnerabilities apply patches and secure
operating systems effectively step six
familiarity with ethical hacking tools
ethical hackers rely on a variety of
tools to assess and secure systems and
networks familiarize yourself with
popular ethical hacking tools such as
met spotli wi shock and map BB suit Ki
Linux canvas SQL ninja and B these tools
provide functionalities for
vulnerability scanning Network sniffing
exploit development and penetration
testing understanding how to use these
tools effectively will enhance your
capabilities as an ethical head now
we'll see the step seven that is problem
solving and analytical thinking so being
an ethical hacker requires strong
problem solving skills and the ability
to think analytically you will often
encounter complex systems and face
intricate security challenges developing
your problem solving abilities and
analytical thinking will help you
approach these challenges systematically
identify vulnerabilities and device
effective strategies to mitigate risk
it is essential to stay updated with the
latest security Trends and Technologies
to enhance your problem solving skills
and the step it is knowledge of common
attack vectors and techniques so to
defend against potential threats you
must familiarize yourself with common
hacking techniques and attack vectors
used by malicious hackers this include
social engineering fishing attacks
password cracking network based attacks
and more understanding how these attacks
work and the methodologies used will
enable you to Pro actively identify and
prevent potential security breaches and
now the step nine that is certifications
while certifications are not mandatory
to start a career in ethical hacking
they can provide a structured learning
path and validate your skills and
knowledge consider pursuing
certification such as certified ethical
hacker CH offensive security certified
professional OSP certified information
system security professional cissp
certified penetration Testing Engineer
cpte and certified secur analyst ecsa
these certifications demonstrate your
expertise and dedication to the field
enhancing your credibility as an ethical
hacker now we'll see the job roles in
ethical hacking field so starting with
like there are several job roles in
ethical hacking such as here's an
elaboration on each job role in ethical
hacking and we'll see some of the major
ethical hacker job roles so starting
with ethical hacker so an ethical hacker
is a skilled professional who legally
attempts to p P trade computer system
and networks to identify vulnerabilities
and weaknesses they use their knowledge
to strengthen the security
infrastructure and protect against cyber
threats and the next is network security
engineer network security Engineers
specialize in securing and maintaining
computer networks within an organization
they Implement and manage security
measures such as firewalls intrusion
detection systems and virtual private
networks that is VPN to protect
sensitive data then we have cyber
security analyst so cyber security
analyst Monitor and analyze systems for
potential security breaches or incidents
they investigate threats develop
security protocols and Implement
measures to protect against attacks the
next is penetration tester penetration
testers also known as ethical hackers
simulate real world attacks to identify
vulnerabilities in computer systems
networks and applications they conduct
thoro assessments and provide
recommendations for improving security
the next is information security manager
information security managers are
responsible for overseeing an
organization's overall security strategy
and ensuring the protection of sensitive
data they develop and Implement security
policies manage security teams and
handle incident response and the next is
cyber security engineer so cyber
security Engineers design and Implement
security systems including firewalls
encryption protocols and intrusion
detection systems they also conduct risk
assessments and perform security audits
to maintain a security environment and
the next is security consultant Security
Consultants provide expert advice and
guidance on security strategies and
solutions they assess vulnerabilities
develop security plans and assist
organizations in improving their overall
security posture in the United States
these requirements are very high and
this was all for this tutorial did you
know that in August this year Google
openly admitted that some of its Gmail
accounts were hacked by an Iranian group
fortunately the event was isol olated
and was taken care of but rarely are
security breaches this easy to stop with
more and more data moving to the cloud
the prospects of hacks like these have
grown in the past decade exponentially
consequently organizations have now
discovered the need to secure the
digital infrastructure against various
attack vectors fueling the need for
ethical hackers in the IT industry so
today's video is all about how you can
learn the ins and outs of hacking and
cyber security irrespective of your
learning background so welcome to our
video on how to become an ethical hacker
by simply loar before we get started
head Ure you subscribed to the channel
so you always stay updated with the
latest Technologies and Trends let's
first clear the air on an ethical
Hacker's role the term hacking has
inherently negative connotations however
this will only be applicable until the
duty of an ethical hacker is properly
understood ethical hackers are the good
people in the hacking field wearing the
white hat so what exactly is the
responsibility of an ethical hacker
instead of utilizing the extensive
computer expertise for criminal purposes
ethical hackers find gaps in data and
computer security for businesses and
organizations worldwide to defend
themselves against hackers with less
than noble intentions ethical hacking is
a subcategory of cyber security that
involves lawfully breaking a system
security mechanisms in order to discover
possible threats and data leaks on the
network ethical hackers can work for
cooperation as independent Freelancers
in house security staff for its website
or its applications or as simulated
offensive cyber Security Professionals
as well all of these careers need
knowledge of current attack
methodologies and tools albe the
in-house expert may need to be
knowledgeable about a single kind of
software or digital asset but how can
you hone your ethical hacking skills
let's take a look at few steps one can
take while starting a career in this
field the first step is getting
comfortable with Linux there are
operating systems catered specifically
to ethical hackers like Ki Linux and
parro security both are based on Linux
derivatives and have a plethora of tools
to make your hacking workflow easy and
relatively stressfree the better versed
you are with Linux and its terminal the
quicker you can achieve things when
hacking the next would be to master the
mother of all programming languages
which is the C programming language
since Linux and a lot of backend code
are written in C having a strong hand
over this programming language is very
important it's always helpful to learn a
couple more relevant languages like
python or Java Script which will help
you dissect giant pieces of server code
like
butter remaining Anonymous is vital in
the hacking sphere since giving a
malicious actor news of your existence
on a Target Network can cause him then
to flee or attack your device instead
the usage of Mac address randomizers and
proxy chains is highly beneficial and
recommended when monitoring networks for
criminal activity and speaking of
proxies ethical hackers must understand
networking fundamentals and exactly how
they are established learning about
various networks and protocols might
help you exploit flaws an ethical hacker
with an extensive understanding of
networking tools such as wire shock nmap
and others can overcome field incidents
relatively unscathed the fifth skill in
our list is traversing the darkware
using the famous store browser most of
the internet is hidden behind the Tor
networks and getting a closer look at
the people who often are at the
Forefront of the hacking industry in the
dark web directly can help you
familiarize yourself with a certain
domain Secrets while keeping you updated
with the latest happenings in the cyber
crime World A major advantage that can
tip the skills in the famor of an
ethical hacker is the knowledge of
cryptography or encryption encryption is
used in various elements of information
security including authentication data
Integrity anonymity and others passwords
and sensitive information are always
encrypted on a network a hacker must
understand how to recognize and break
these encryption standards exploring
vulnerabilities make you a better
ethical hacker simply keeps you aware of
the security measures that are kept in
place as industry standards while
handing you the most advanced
penetration testing tools on the market
learning how to scan networks and
systems for vulnerabilities that might
result in a security Beach ethical
hackers may also attempt to write
vulnerabilities to exploit the system in
question as a final tip join forums for
convers iations with other hackers
worldwide to trade share expertise and
collaborate Discord Reddit Telegram and
other platforms all have communities
where you can join and collaborate with
fellow Learners to broaden your learning
Spectrum now that we understand some
basic skills ethical hackers need to
excel in this domain let us look at the
road map one can follow to get started
many ethical hackers begin their careers
by studying computer science you can
also acquire an A+ certification from
comp Gia by appearing for and passing
two additional tests these test assess
an individual understanding of PC
components and their ability to
disassemble and reassemble a PC however
before advancing in your profession you
must gather experience and obtain a
network Plus or a ccns certification the
network plus certification certifies
fundamental Network expertise such as
Network Administration maintenance
deployment and troubleshooting the CCNA
certification guarantees the same skills
and Stripes of foundation level
proficiency once qualified you can
advance to the next level of your career
in network support you'll be responsible
for monitoring and upgrading installing
security software and testing for
vulnerabilities you'll obtain expertise
in network security and your goal should
be offered as a position as a network
engineer as a network engineer you will
build and plan networks rather than
simply maintain them your focus should
now be on the security part of your
journey to becoming an ethical hacker
this is the time to focus on earning a
security certifications such as Security
Plus or cissp the US Department of
Defense has approved the Security Plus
accredition which covers testing on
critical areas such as Access Control
identity authentication and cryptography
the cisp certification is a worldwide
recognized security accredition that
validates the expertise of risk
management Cloud technology and
application development The Next Step
would be to start working in the
information security division an
information security analyst studies
systems and network security engages
with security breaches and strives to
implement Security Solutions for this
profession you should focus on
penetration testing to gain handsome
experiences some of the most essential
tools of the trade getting the certified
ethical hacker or the C certification
should be your top priority the training
will teach you all you must understand
to become a productive and ethical
hacker you will be engaged in a Hands-On
environment where you will be guided
through breaking into a network and
finding any security flaws after
obtaining this certification you can
begin marketing yourself as a
professional ethical hacker we have
already covered some skills one needs to
learn when starting their Journey
however an ethical hacker has certain
roles and responsibilities that must be
carried out ulous the first of which is
threat modeling threat modeling is
optimizing network security by
identifying vulnerabilities and
determining counter measures for
avoiding or reducing an attack's impact
on the system a threat is a real or
projected negative incident jeopardizing
the organization's assets the role of an
ethical hacker is to give a thorough
assessment of potentially harmful
assaults and their potential
consequences they can also conduct
information security audits or a
risk-based evaluation of a company's
security
these regular exercises assess security
Readiness identify it system weaknesses
and offer strategies for reducing future
attack threats they also assess how
successfully security related policies
are implemented resulting in a report
that includes discovered flaws and
appropriate Solutions ethical writers
must be able to collect data detect
vulnerabilities and correlate risks to
create clear and unambiguous
professional reports these evaluations
are frequently used to justify
finalizing security asset expenditures
the market for trained ethical hackers
has never been this expensive according
to various surveys the job outlet for
ethical hackers and information security
analyst is supposed to grow by 33%
between 2020 and 2030 companies like IBM
Google and Microsoft are always on the
lookout for train cyber security
Personnel in this climate of data
breaches and security vulnerabilities we
hope this video has cleared some doubts
regarding where to start and what to
learn during this
journey when it comes to web app hacking
it generally refers to the exploitation
of applications by HTTP which can be
done by manipulating the applications
via its graphical user interface this is
done by tampering with the uniform
resource identifier also known as a URI
or tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be
compromised anyone who uses a computer
connected to the internet is susceptible
to the threats that computer hackers and
online Predators post these online vain
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your conversation or produse the back
end of your personal website usually
disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertex transfer protocol or
HTTP so hack attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like GS
attacks syn flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wiress networks offer great
flexibility they have their own security
problems a hacker can sniff the network
packets without having to be in the same
building where the network is located as
wireless networks communicate through
radio waves a hacker can easily sniff
the network from a nearby location most
attackers use Network sniffing to find
the SSID and hack a wireless network an
attacker can attack a network from a
distance and therefore it is sometimes
difficult to collect evidence against
the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
it revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer
systems coming to our main focus for
today let us have a look at the top five
most essential ethical hacking tools to
be used in
2021 at the top of the chain lies
nmap nmap which stands for network
mapper is a free and open-source utility
for network discovery and security
auditing many systems and network
administrators also find it useful for
tasks such as Network inventory managing
service upgrade schedules and monitoring
host or service sub time it is most
beneficial in the early stages of
ethical hacking where a hacker must
figure the possible entry point to a
system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
breach the
device nmap users raw IP packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what service
they are running what operating systems
are installed what type of packet
filters and firewalls are in used and
dozens other character istics it was
designed to rapidly scan large networks
but works F against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked
device next on our list we have
Metasploit the Metasploit framework is a
very powerful tool that can be used by
cyber criminals as well as ethical
hackers to probe systematic
vulnerabilities on both networks and
servers because it's an open source
framework it can be easily customized
and used with most operating
systems with Metasploit the ethical
hacking team can use readymade or custom
code and introduce it into a network to
probe for weak spots as another flavor
of threat hunting once the flaws are
identified and documented the
information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
Solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the necessary exploit is
fed into the system there are a host of
options for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the
device a big advantage of Metasploit is
the ability to run full-fledged scans on
the target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
softwares having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the
list moving on we have the actic
framework acuns is an endtoend web
security scanner which offers a 360°
view of an organization security it is
an application security testing tool
tool that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web
assets the need to be able to test
application in depth and further than
traditional vulnerability management
tools has created a market with several
players in the application security
space actic can detect over 7,000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other out of band
vulnerabilities it can scan all pages
web apps and complex web applications
running HTML 5 and JavaScript as well it
also lets you scan complex multi-level
forms and even password protected areas
of the
site actic is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as s scanners s tools only
work during development and only for
specific languages and have a history of
reporting lot of false positives whereas
Dynamic testing tools also known as D
have the ability to streamline testing
from development to deployment with
minimal
issues next on our list we have air
gedon this is a multi-use bash script
used for Linux systems to hack and audit
wireless networks like our everyday
Wi-Fi router and its counterparts along
with being able to launch denial of
service attacks on compromised networks
this multi-purpose wi-fi hacking tool
has very rich features which support
multiple methods for wi-fi hacking
including WPS hacking modes WP attacks
handshake captures evil twin and so much
more it usually needs an external
network adapter that supports monitor
mode which is necessary to be able to
capture Wireless traffic that Traverse
the air
channels thanks to its open-source
nature air Garden can be used with
multiple Community plugins and add-ons
thereby increasing its Effectiveness
against a wide variety of routers both
in the 2.4 GHz and the 5 GHz
band finally at number five we have John
the Ripper John the Ripper is an open-
Source password security auditing and
the password recovery tool which is
available for many operating
systems John the Ripper jumbo supports
hundred of hash and Cipher types
including for user passwords of
operating systems web apps database
servers encrypted keys and document
files some of the key features of the
tool include offering multiple modes to
speed up the password cracking
automatically deselecting the hashing
algorithm used by the passwords and the
ease of running and configurating the
tool to make it password cracking
easier it can use dictionary attacks
along with regular brute forcing to
speed up the process of cracking the
correct password without wasting
additional resources the word list being
used in these dictionary attacks can be
used by the users end allowing for a
completely customizable
process we also have a few honorary
mentions in our list that just missed
the cut netsparker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported vulnerabilities
the burp suit professional is one of the
most popular penetration testing and
vulnerability finder tools and it's used
for checking web application security
the term burp as it is commonly known as
a proxy based tool which is used to
evaluate the security of web-based
application and to do Hands-On testing
moving away from websites and
applications yashar is a free and open
source packet analyzer which was
launched in 2006 it is used for Network
troubleshooting analysis software and
Communications protocol development and
education it captures Network traffic on
the local network and stores data for
offline analysis yha captures Network
traffic from ethernet Bluetooth wireless
networks and frame relay
connections now that we learn about the
different types of tools that can be
used when conducting an ethical hacking
audit let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits being able to identify defects
from an attacker's perspective is
game-changing since it displays all the
potential Avenues of a possible hack one
can only prepare for the known
vulnerabilities as a defensive
specialist but proactively trying to
breach a network or device can make
hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
Network infrastructure as seen on many
occasions a real breach will cause loss
of data and irreparable damage to the
foundation of an
organization being able to gauge such
shortcomings before they become public
and can be used exploited is a benefit
most organizations make use
of this is not to imply that such
security audits are only beneficial to
the organization paying for it when
coming across companies that provide
certain Services a reliable third party
security audit goes a long way in
instilling trust and confidence over
their craft if the ethical hackers
cannot find any major vulnerabilities
that can be leveraged by hackers it just
accentuates the technical bance of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount in this we are going
to discuss ethical hacking and
penetration testing so we're going to
talk about about the concepts about what
constitutes an ethical hack and what is
a penetration test we're going to talk
about the different types of penetration
test and how they can be done we're
going to talk about an operating system
called Khali Linux and we're going to
talk about its usage and its importance
in cyber security we'll also be
discussing the different phases of
penetration test and how people or
hackers would utilize these phases uh to
gain their objectives we will also be
discussing in what areas can we do a
penetration test how to do those
penetration tests we'll be discussing
quite a few bit of penetration testing
tools that are available in the K Linux
space and then we'll be looking at a
couple of demos at the end of the
session to understand how these tools in
the operating system can be utilized for
various hacks so let's started with what
is ethical hacking now plainly defined
ethical hacking is locating weaknesses
or vulnerabilities of computers and
information systems using the intent and
actions of a malicious hacker the major
difference is here that we are hired to
discover those weaknesses in a legal and
ethical manner that means first and
foremost our intent should not be
malicious we do not wish any harm to the
organization and whatever we discover is
reported back and not misused once we
report back we would also be trying to
help them out to mitigate or remove
those weaknesses or vulnerabilities to
enhance the company security poer so
essentially we would have the same
training or the same knowledge as that
of a malicious hacker except that the
intent is going to be different the
intent is going to help the organization
achieve security to protect themselves
against malicious hackers and the second
most important thing about ethical
hacking is that we authorized to do that
activity I cannot in good faith hack
somebody and then tell them you know
what I just I just wanted to help you
out and uh here are your vulnerabilities
and uh this is the way you can prevent
them I first need the authorization from
the other party and only then can I
perform an ethical hack so in this
example hacker attacks an individual
with malicious intent and makes misuse
of whatever information they have gotten
they steal the data they maybe fry the
operating system Hardware destroy it and
thus uh they leave the victim without uh
a device with authorization an ethical
hacker can also attack the same
individual minus the destruction of
course and the intent is good so they're
willingly finding out the
vulnerabilities and helping the victim
plug them out so that they wouldn't be a
victim of a malicious attack now here
the first thing is authorization from
the victim and the second thing is the
good intent where we do not misuse those
vulnerabilities and we report them back
to the victim or to the client and help
them uh patch those vulnerabilities
that's the main difference between a
white hat and a black hat so Security
Experts are normally termed as white hat
hackers malicious hackers are termed as
black hats now the responsibilities of
ethical hacker are multifold first and
foremost you have to create scripts test
for vulnerabilities first have to
identify those in the first place so
there's vulnerability assessment
identifying those vulnerabilities and
then you're going to test them to see
the validity and the complexity of those
vulnerabilities so your one of your
responsibilities would be to develop
tools to increase security as well or to
configure Security in such a way that it
would be difficult to breach performing
risk assessment now what is a risk risk
is a threat that is posed to an
organization by a Poss possibility of
getting hacked so let's say I as a
ethical hacker run a vulnerability
scanner on a particular client I
identify 10 different vulnerabilities
within those 10 vulnerabilities I do a
risk assessment to identify which
vulnerability is critical would have the
most impact on the client and what would
be the
once they get hacked and the loss could
not only be loss of data it could be
Financial losses it could be loss of
reputation penalties they have to pay to
the client for breaches or penalties
that they may have to pay for pay the
governments in case of breaches that
happened that uh couldn't be controlled
another responsibility of the ethical
hacker is to set up policies in such a
way that it becomes difficult for
hackers to get access to devices or to
protected data and finally train the
staff for network security so uh we've
got a lot of employees in an
organization we need to train the staff
of what is allowed and what is not
allowed how to keep themselves secure so
that they don't get compromised thus
becoming a vulnerability themselves to
the organization the policies that we
have talked about are administrative
policies to govern the employees of the
organization for example password
policies most of the organizations will
have a tough password policy where they
say you have to create a password that
meets a certain level of complexity
before that can be accepted and till you
create that password you're not allowed
to log in or you're not allowed to
register so let's move on to understand
what is penetration testing now for
penetration testing there's a phase
called vulnerability assessment that
happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing but running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration test this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only
of the information systems so you have
identified that flaw maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be uh a buffer over overrun flaw
or it could be a simple password
cracking attempt your idea is to create
those tools create those attacks and try
to penetrate into those areas where
security is weak uh the essense of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks could be anything
like a fishing attack a password
cracking attack a denal of service
attack or any other vulnerabilities that
you have identified during the
vulnerability scan so what is K Linux
and why is it used K Linex is an
operating system oftenly used by hackers
and ethical hackers both because of the
tool sets that the operating system
contains it is a Operating System
created by professionals with a lot of
embedded tools it is a dbn based
operating system with Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing features there are more than
600 plus or tools on that operating
system that can help you leverage any of
the attacks man in the mdle attacks
sniffing password cracking any of these
attacks would be possible with all the
tools available you just need to know
how to utilize the operating system and
its tools contains like I said 100 of
hundreds of tools that are used for
various information security tasks like
uh computer forensics rever reverse
engineering information finding even uh
getting access to different machines and
then uh creating viruses worms Trojans
anything that you will 600 plus tools in
the Kali Linux operating system there
are periodic updates that are given out
to the operating system as well it is
open source that means it is free to
utilize you can even have the source
code you can modify it if you want to
there's customizations available for all
the tools you can download third party
tools and install them if you want
there's a white support for wireless uh
network cards multiple languages are
being supported at the time at the same
time as well and you can create create a
lot of attacking uh scripts you can
create attacking tools and you can write
your own exploits as well on K Linux so
this all all in all helps you create a
very robust system where you can create
your own attacks and then launch them
against unsuspecting victims now that is
illegal so as far ethical hacking is
concerned once you have authorization
you're going to identify which tools to
be utilized you're going to get the
appropriate permissions and only then
are you going to attempt those attacks
let's talk about the phases of
penetration testing now there are five
different phases the first one is the
recognizance phase also known as the
information gathering phase this is the
most important phase for any hacker this
is where the hacker or the ethical
hacker if you will will gather as much
information about the target's victim or
V vers the V the victim right so once
you have that information you would then
be able to identify what tool sets to
include and how to attack the victim for
example you want to find find out the IP
addresses the domains subdomains the
network architecture that is being
utilized you want to identify operating
systems that are being utilized the
network IP ranges that are being
utilized and so on so forth you might
want to identify employees within an
organization for social engineering
attacks in the future email addresses
telephone numbers anything and
everything that will help you validate
and give you information about the
target is something that you want to do
in the recognizance phase at this point
in time we are not going to question
whether whatever information we are
getting is useful or not only time will
tell depending on the various attacks
that we will be building up later on
this becomes your Baseline this becomes
your database with all the information
about the victim so that you can come
back from later stages back to the
recognizance phase to look at the
information that you have gathered and
then you can find tune your attacks once
you have done that you're going to uh
then start the scanning phase based on
the information that you have gathered
you're going to identify live machines
within the network once you you
identified the life machines you'll scan
them for open ports protocols and
procedures any processes that are
running and then we going to identify
vulnerabilities Within These processors
and Within These open ports so in the
scanning phase uh why do we need to find
live machines because we want to find
out the machines that have booted up
have an operating system and are running
on the network if an machine is not
available on the network or is in a
shutdown mode that machine cannot be
hacked through a technical attack then
it will be a physical attack where you
physically go to the machine and then do
whatever you want to do with it for a
technical attack you will have to
identify the machines that have booted
up then you're going to scan the open
ports because that's going to be our
entry point and on the port would be a
service that is running so you scan the
service as well identify the version of
the service and then do a vulnerability
scan to identify if there are any
vulnerabilities on those services that
are running and then based on all of
this information we are going to develop
our attacks as we go on so once we have
this we go onto the gaining access phase
where we are going to attack and try to
get access to our victims machines could
be a social engineering attack based on
the information gathering we have done
in the technical assessment in scanning
phase if you have identified a
vulnerability you're going to identify a
relevant exploit and then use that
exploit to try to gain access or we
might just craft a Trojan and try to uh
execute that trojen on the victim's
machine to uh check if we can get access
through that particular manner once we
have the access could be even a simple
password cracking attack which we have
been able to accomplish and we have
cracked the password of the person and
now we have gained access to that
person's computer right but these
attacks would be temporary for example
we have cracked a password somebody
changes the password every 30 days after
that period our attack would be useless
if a Trojan is executed we get a
connection to that machine for once but
then how do we get get a repeated
connection over and over again if we
want to reconnect to that machine so
that's where we come into the mainten
access phase where we install uh root
kits key loggers sniffers and things
like that where we could get a back door
entry to the victim's machine if we have
already been successfully installed a
Trojan we would want to add the Trojan
to the startup menu so that every time
the operating system starts the Trojan
gets automatically executed and thus we
maintain the back door entry to that
victim's machine once we have done all
of this all these activities are going
to leave a trace in the victim's machine
so if you install a Trojan a Trojan
being an application would create
directories and files a virus would be
destructive in nature if you're
executing a script it will leave some
logs behind if we even log in through
the cracked password that we have it
will create a login entry at for that
particular Tim stamp along with the IP
address that we utilized in the covering
tracks we are essentially trying to
avoid detection by deleting traces of
our activity that means that we need to
identify where logs are been stored we
need to to address those logs and we
need to delete them or modify them in
such a way that our activity is not
traceable so these are the five main
phases of a penetration test gather as
much information as you can scan for
machines ports protocols and services
running on the victim's device try to
gain access by password cracking prions
exploits for the V lities if any
maintain that access by installing
further software which will allow you to
get back door access to that particular
system and then try to cover your tracks
by deleting all Trac bis of your
activity once successful the victim will
have no idea and you have a backd door
entry and you can monitor the victim to
the extent that you want now in an
ethical Hacker's perspective this
penetration test can be done in multiple
aspects so again understand the fact
that we are doing an authorized activity
we have identified the tools that we
have to use identified the attacks we
have got the appropriate authorization
and based on that authorization we are
conducting a penetration test the
penetration test may be asked to be done
in one of these manner first is the
blackbox test the blackbox test is where
no information is given to the ethical
hacker about the it infrastructure so
they have no idea what it is they start
right from the first phase of the
information gathering gather as much
information they can and based on the
gathered information they try to create
and launch attacks to see if they are
going to be successful now not only does
it test the knowledge of the penetration
tester it would also test the security
implementations that the organization
has done to see whether they can
identify the attack and prevent it in
the first place so this is the
simulation of a malicious hacker
scenario where a malicious hacker having
no idea about the organization first
tries to gather information and then
tries to attack that organization so no
source code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the it infrastructure is
given think of it from a employees
perspective a regular employee in an
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges uh like an administrator but
is just a uh regular employee does that
means that they got limited access
within the organization based on which
they get some knowledge of the it
infrastructure so this is an attempt of
an Insider uh simulation attack where a
regular user may want to try to misuse
the access that they've been given and
then try to gather information or try to
gain access to other devices which they
are not authorized to the third test is
white box where there's full knowledge
of the it infrastructure that has been
given so this is again a simulation of
an Insider attack a malicious Insider if
you will but at this point in time the
person has complete knowledge of the
infrastructure could be in an
administrative position and then they
are trying to leverage their access to
see if they can get information or they
can compromise any stuff any of the data
so the three attacks would be the first
one blackbox where we are simulating uh
external threat a hacker sitting outside
the organization trying to gain access
the gray box is an Insider threat where
there's a regular employee who is trying
to get access to infrastructure that
they are not authorized for and then the
third audit is a white box audit where
there's an administrator who has all the
leverage all the access and the
visibility within the uh infrastructure
and then they're trying to misuse their
access to see what else they can get
from whatever access has been authorized
to them now let's look at the areas of
penetration testing where all could we
do a penetration test thus compromising
the security of the application or of
the server or of the the user so first
and foremost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in the network all of these
are devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been correctly
secured they would leave some V lities
behind if we as ethical hackers are able
to identify these flaws these
misconfigurations these vulnerabilities
we could then try to exploit them and
try to gain access to the network and
devices within that Network by uh
getting access to the network in the
first place then we have the web
applications web applications are
nothing but softwares that are developed
over or deployed over a web server and
are made available over the intranet or
the internet for example uh websites
that we visit or web applications like
Facebook if you will right so if these
applications have vulnerabilities within
them we then try to attack the web-
based applications and thus try to
bypass authentication or get access
access to database or try to leak
information through those applications
if not then we try to attack the client
side now web application is at the
server level and is hosted by the
deployer so that's at the server side
the client side is where we as users are
using a computer with a browser and
trying to interact with the web
application now the browser and the
operating system that we are utilizing
would have its own vulnerabilities thus
identifying a client side avilability
and then exploiting it to either either
hack the client or then piggy back on
the client's connection and try to get
access to the server so either you could
attack the network the web application
or the client side itself or you could
attack wireless networks this test would
examine all the wireless devices which
are used in a corporation most of the
wireless would have laptops smartphones
tablets faets all of those connected to
them if you're able to access any of
these devices through the wireless it
would help you gain access to other
devices on the wireless as well and then
social engineering so this is where
you're trying to attack humans you're
tracking an employee of a corporation to
reveal some confidential information
knowingly or unknowingly by tricking
them with fake mails or fake websites or
malicious emails that you have sent to
them uh which they have failed to
recognize as malicious and they click on
it thus getting victimized social
engineering attacks are always uh
successful because of the gullibility of
humans empathy sympathy humans basically
have emotions emotions can be toyed with
and then taken advantage of if the
person is not careful enough for example
the most common social engineering
attack that we see is the Nigerian fraud
where we receive an email that someone
somewhere has died and has left a huge
estate behind a few hundred million doar
and we have been identified as the
person through whom they want to
transfer the money to a foreign land to
save on taxes what are the chances of
that happening on a daily basis right
how many princes are there so that's
something that we do not verify it's
just the I guess the greed if you will
of striking it rich quickly that makes
us believe these kind of emails uh we
have also received emails of lottery
tickets that we have won over a period
of time without even having bought a
lottery ticket so if you haven't bought
one what did you win but we don't ask
these questions we just get excited
about the amount of money that we have
won and then we try to bet on our luck
and try to see if that uh email is going
to fructify or is it just another scam
so social inuring attacks are dime a
dozen these days and we need to be very
careful on what we trust on the internet
let's look at the penetration testing
tools there are hundreds and thousands
of tools out there most of these have
been cons sized and collected together
and hosted on a operating system known
as Kali Linux that we have talked about
earlier now the predecessor to K Linux
was backtrack backtrack is no longer
continued it has been discontinued and K
Linux has taken uh the place of backpack
within which are all the tools that you
see on your screen Metasploit is one of
the most favorite penetration
interesting tools of hackers and ethical
hackers uh there are a lot of inbuilt
exploits over there and we'll be doing a
demo at the end of the session on this
nmap is the information gathering tool
which will scan for live devices scan
for open ports protocols and services
beef would be an application testing
tool that would help us uh find exploits
within applications nessus vulnerability
scanner is a network and a host based
scanner that would help you identify V
abilities within such hosts wi shock is
a network fer which allows you to
capture Network packets and and analyze
them to see if there are there is any
information worth capturing within those
packets SQL map is a automated tool used
for SQL injection attacks so you don't
even have to craft your queries for SQL
injection it will be done by the SQL map
tool you just need to identify whatever
is possible through the queries that
this SQL is going to create and then
based on the activity that you've
identified you just need to redefine
your your search parameters to get
access to the database we'll be doing a
demo on SQL map or SQL map as well and
then there is John the Ripper John the
Ripper is a tool that is used for
password cracking so dictionary attacks
Brute Force attacks are done using John
the Ripper what is a dictionary attack a
dictionary attack is an attack where we
create list of all probable passwords
store them in a txt file and run that
list against the password tool to see if
any of those passwords are going to
match a Brute Force attack is trying the
same attack but with every permutation
and combination of the alphabet that we
have and we're going to try to figure
out uh if we are able to crack the
password at all so these are just some
of the tools for every tool there are
another supporting 100 tools or more
than that uh like for NS vulnerability
scanner you'll have Callis vulnerability
scanner you have uh GFI lanard and there
are other lots of other softwares out
there but these are some of the most
commonly utilized tools let's look at
the Metasploit attack Metasploit is a
framework of penetration testing that
makes hacking very simple you just need
to know how to utilize the tool you need
to identify the vulnerability associated
with a particular exploit and then run
the exploit on metas sploit we'll be
demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits in active exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit these exploits wait for incoming
requests and exploit them as soon as
they connect they can also be used in
conjunction with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
payload we uh like a reverse connection
payload we send it to the victim once
the victim installs that software the
machine will then initiate a connection
to us our machine will be in a listen
mode and then we will once the software
is executed at there and we would then
try to connect and exploit that
particular vulnerability this is the uh
practical that we'll be doing on
Metasploit so let's move on with the
demos and then we'll see uh what we can
discuss amongst them all right let's
have a look at at some of the demos that
we had uh talked about in the ethical
hacking and penetration testing module
we are going to look at three different
demos the first one is going to be a SQL
injection attack that we're going to
perform on this tool that we have the
second one is a password cracking attack
on Windows 7 and a third one is a meter
based or a metas sploid based shell
shock attack on a Linux based web server
so let's get cracking I've powered on
this virtual machine uh which is the
ovas broken web application it is a tool
that is provided for a people who want
to enhance their skills and they can
practice uh how to do these attacks in a
legal manner so we are going to go to
this site I'm just going to open up my
browser the IP address is 7113 to and
that's the OAS broken web application
that we want to utilize we're going to
head off to mutil Day 2 and we are going
to look at a SQL injection attack where
we want to bypass authentication now
this takes us to the login screen so we
can just try our luck here and see that
that the authentication mechanism works
the account does not exist so the
username and password that we have
supplied is not the correct one so we
want to ensure that there's a SQL
database and uh we can uh try to attack
it and see uh if we can bypass the
authentication now uh what we want to do
is we want to create a SQL based
malformed query that can give us a
different output so I'm just going to
type in a single quote over here and
type login and you can see that this is
now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's a error that is given out
compared to the login that we tried uh
earlier when we used a proper text based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the single code
give us a error and it shows us how SQL
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what this queries are
all about how this syntax works here we
just going to see if we can create a
malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is uh
create the query over here and we're
going to give it a comparison so we're
going to give it R 1 equals one space
hyphen hyen space and if you now click
login you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user as
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database and Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
at a demo this is how a SQL injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query worked wonders where it
allowed us to bypass authentication so
it also depends on what kind of a page I
am and what query would be accepted at
this point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we
calling up on when we connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user on password and if you type in the
same query over here single quote or and
give it a condition single quote r 1
equals 1 space hyphen hyphen space now
here it is not going to log Us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it will
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the the usernames and passwords coming
in that are stored in the user lookup
field so this is where the understanding
comes in of which query to create at
what page we are depending upon the
function that is being called right so
that's the SQL uh injection attack that
we wanted to look at let's move on to
password cracking now this is a Windows
7 machine that we have I'm just going to
do a very basic password cracking
example we're just going to log in now
here the assumption is that we are able
to log in we have access to a computer
and we want to check out other users who
are using this computer and see if we
can find out their passwords so that uh
we can log in as a different user steal
data if required and we wouldn't be to
blame if there are any locks that are
created so here we've got a tool called
can enable that is installed right here
now I'm already an administrator on this
machine I'm checking out other
administrators who share the same
privileges or any other user who may be
on this system whose password I can
crack and thus I would be able to get
access through their account and then do
any malicious activity right so this
allows me to go into a cracker tool and
it allows me to enumerate this machine
and identify all the users and passwords
that are there in this particular
machine right so I'm just going to click
on the plus sign and I'm going to import
uh hashes from a local system so where
are these files stored where does
Windows store its passwords in what
format are they stored and what this
tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users are hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
there's a user called virus as well and
you can see that this is the hash value
of the password that is being utilized
now there's a particular format uh for a
hash value for Windows and how it stores
but once we have these hash values let's
say if I want to crack this password
there are VAR attacks that we can do for
example a dictionary based attack or a
Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so
we're going to try to create an llm hash
attack and here we're going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and uh lower case a through Zed upper
case a through Zed numeric 0 through 9
and and all the special characters let's
say the password is between 7 and 16
characters and this is the character set
that we want to try the brot force
attack on what is a root Force attack it
is an attack where the computer is going
to try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100% successful given the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to become a little bit
redundant there are other attacks that
we can do which can easily identify this
data for us as well but that is
something that we will look on in future
videos so that's how we can get access
to users and passwords uh there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we going to try
to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
Linux web server that I have that I'm
going to power on I'm going to use a k
Linux machine to hack that device and
I'm going to just power off my Windows 7
machine give it a minute till it boots
up now this is also a demo machine that
we have which has its own preconfigured
vulnerabilities so here we've got
something from the pentesters lab uh and
has a shell shock vulnerability imple
implemented inside shell shock
vulnerability affects Linux Mac and Unix
based operating systems for a particular
version of The Bash shell bash is the
bone again shell which is the command
line interface in these operating
systems so what we are trying to do here
is we're going to use the Ki Linux
machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we are going to use metas sploit to
attack this machine now the first and
foremost thing is we want to identify
the IP address we have no idea what the
IP addresses we are in the same subnet
so we are assuming that we able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called Zen map I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my IP address is
this with a subnet mask of 255 255
255.0.0.0 the same subnet and we are
doing a ping Swip over here to identify
which machines are live in a minute
we'll get all the IP addresses 71.1 2
133 254 and 128 we know that we are 128
at this point in time uh 254 is the dhp
server so we assuming that 133 is the
machine that we want to look at and
let's then try to see if we can scan
that machine 133 and we're going to do
an intent scan to find out which ports
are open what services are running over
there and if it is whether the pintest
machine that we were looking for you can
see of the start Port 22 and Port 80 and
somewhere here it's going to give us the
ports that are open and the details
about those ports and somewhere here it
will tell us that this is the pentester
lab machine that we wanted which is
correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what
we're going to do is I'm going to use
another GUI based tool called Sparta
which I can just find out from here
Sparta uses two tools in the background
uh nmap tool and a tool called ncto so
we just going to start scanning 192
16871 133 was the IP address add to
scope and over a period of time you can
see all of these will start populating
with information there we are that's the
ncto tool coming in scanning on Port 80
which is uh which means that it's a web
server using HTTP it tells us it's an
Apache HT httpd
2.2.2 and that gives us the 22 port
number as well if we have head over to
the tab of ncto or let's look at the
screenshot first this is what the
website would be looking like and ncto
gives us the options over here it tells
us that there is a vulnerability over
here for shell shock and this is the
path where the vulnerability is going to
exist so what we going to do we go back
to the command line sorry we open up a
new one minimize all these other windows
and we're going to open up metas sploit
metas is a penetration testing tool that
is used by most hackers and ethical
hackers to test applications and test
existing exploits and vulnerabilities so
just give it a minute till it starts you
can see there are already around 1,700
exploits right here uh we're going to
see all those exploits with these
commands there we are sorry for the typo
and it will just give us a list of all
the exploits that are stored in metas in
this version so all of these are windows
based if we scroll up we will be looking
at other vulnerabilities as well or
exploits the unique space exploits LX
OSX multi exploits and we're looking for
uh exploit for um multi- based Apache or
HTTP let's go up uh let's look at so
this is the one that we're looking for
Apache mod CGI bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we're just going to copy it go back to
the bottom say use exploit and paste the
one that we wanted press enter say show
options so it will ask us to configure
this I'm just going to configure it
based on the knowledge that we have set
our host which is the remote host the
victim's machine so we put in the IP
address it asks us for the Target URI so
that's the path that we saw set Target
URI to CGI hyphen bin SL status enter
now with the exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want so we say show
payloads and it will give us a list of
all the compatible payloads with this
exploit and we want to create a reverse
TCP connection
which is this so we know it's a Linux
operating system we want this uh payload
to be set so set payload press enter
that's the payload coming in show
options now that we have set the payload
this is the options for the exploit and
now we want to set our options for the
payloads as well so we are creating a
reverse TCP connection which means we
are remotely executing code at the
victim side and making the victim
connect back to our machine which means
we need to set up a listener so I need
to put my IP address over here set local
host or lhost 192
16871 128 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack I can see that it
has created a MPR session at the victim
site and it has opened up a session so
if I do a PWD now PWD is a Linux command
for present working directory and it
will show us that we'll connect it to
where dub dub dub CGI hyphen bin do an
LS it will list all the files that's the
status file over there do a CD back
slash it will take us to the root of
this machine and if you're someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security that is by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional where sits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply Lars postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from the MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered Jude is waiting at the airport
to hop on her flight back home when she
realizes that she missed making an
important Bank payment she connects her
laptop to the public Wi-Fi at the
airport and goes ahead to carry out the
bank transaction everything goes well
and Jude completes her
transaction after a couple of days she
was wiped off her feet when she learned
that her bank account was subjected to a
Cyber attack back and a hefty amount was
wiped from her account after getting in
touch with the bank Authority she
learned that her account was hacked at
the airport she then realized that the
public Wi-Fi she used might have caused
her this trouble Jude wishes that had
her bank transfer escaped the Hacker's
eyes she would not have been a victim of
a Cyber
attack Bank officials advise her to use
a bpn for future transactions especially
when connecting to an open or public
network like most of us Jude had come AC
cross the term VPN several times but
didn't know much about it and little did
she think that the repercussions of not
using a VPN would be this bad let's
understand how the hacker would have
exploited judee's transaction in the
absence of a VPN in this process judee's
computer first connects to the internet
service provider ISP which provides
access to the internet she sends her
details to the bank server using her IP
address Internet Protocol address or IP
address is a unique address that
recognizes a particular device be it a
laptop or a smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects judee's Bank details
without being detected more often or not
in such an attack payment information is
likely to be stolen the targeted data
here are the victim's username passwords
and other personal information
such an unsecured connection exposed
Jude's IP address and Bank details to
the hacker when it passed through the
public network so would Jude have been
able to secure her transaction with the
help of a VPN well yes picture judee's
Bank transaction to be happening in a
tunnel that is invisible to the hacker
in such a case the hacker will not be
able to spot a transaction and that is
precisely what a VPN does a virtual
private Network more often known as VPN
creates a secure tunnel between your
device and the internet for using a VPN
judee's First Step would be to install
software-based technology known as the
VPN client on her laptop or smartphone
that would let her establish a secure
connection the VPN client connects to
the Wi-Fi and then to the
ISP here the VPN client encrypts Jude's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure next
the VPN client establishes a VPN tunnel
within the public network that connects
to the VPN server the VPN tunnel
protects jud's information from being
intercepted by the hacker judee's IP
address and actual location are changed
at the VPN server to enable a private
and secure connection finally the VPN
server connects to Jude's Bank server in
the last step where the encrypted
message is decrypted this way judee's
original IP address is hidden by the VPN
and the VPN n tunnel protects her data
from being hacked this explains how VPN
makes your data Anonymous and secure
when it passes through the public
network and the difference between a
normal connection and a VPN connection
after learning about this Jude was
certain that she should start using a
VPN to carry out her online transactions
in the future this is also applicable to
each one of us even if you work remotely
or connect to public Wi-Fi using a VPN
is the safest option in addition to
providing a secure encrypted data
transfer vpns are also used to disguise
your whereabouts and give you access to
Regional web content VPN servers act as
proxies on the internet this way your
actual location cannot be established
VPN enables you to spoof your location
and switch to a server to another
country and thereby change your location
for example by doing so you can watch
any content on Netflix that might be
unavailable for your region
meet Jonathan he is an investigative
journalist who occasionally researches
and publishes news articles contrary to
the government's ideologies on one such
occasion he could not access a Global
News website dealing with uncensored
information it seemed his IP was blocked
from visiting the news website with his
IP blocked Jonathan turned to a popular
proxy service that was able to unblock
the news website thereby allowing an
open internet to all users just like how
your friend gives a proxy attendance for
you a proxy server serves as a standin
user to keep the real client private but
what is a proxy let's understand its
working by taking a look at how Jonathan
was able to access geoblock content
without much hassle a proxy server acts
as a Gateway or intermediary server
between a user and its destination
website when Jonathan wasn't able to
access the news website he connected his
system to a global Pro proxy server once
connected the proxy server assigns a new
IP address to Jonathan's system an IP
address of a different country where the
website is not censored following this
process whenever Jonathan visits that
website the website administrators see
the new IP address assigned via proxy
server and sees no reason to deny access
to their account once the proxy server
is able to access the website it's
passed on to Jonathan's system via the
same channel regarding accessibility to
proxy servers you must first set it up
on your computer device or network next
check the steps required for your
computer or network as each operating
system has its setup procedures in most
cases however setup intels using an
automated configuration script there are
plenty of free proxy services available
on the internet however the safety of
such proxies is rarely verified most
free proxies will provide an IP address
and a relevant port support for
connection purposes reputed proxy
providers like smart proxy and WR data
that run on subscription models will
most likely provide credentials to log
into when establishing the connection
this extra step access authentication
that verifies an existing subscription
on the proxy provider server unlike free
providers that are open to all when it
comes to hiding IP addresses many people
consider a VPN to be the primary
solution while that's true up to some
extent stand there are a few things
proxies do differently in the case of
vpns extra encryption is also carried
out to create a secure tunnel between
the user's device and a VPN server a VPN
is usually much faster more secure
thanks to multiple layers of encryption
and has little to no downtime proxies
tend to be comparatively unsafe with the
service owners having the exact IP
address of the enduser and having no
guarantees regarding downtimes and
reliability
if you want to know more about how vpns
work do watch how Jude could have
protected her banking credentials using
vpns in our detailed video linked above
now let's take a small quiz to check how
much we have learned what can a VPN
connection provide that a proxy service
cannot a new IP address B multiple
layers of encryption C access to
geoblock content D authentication
credentials think about it and leave
your answers Below in the comment
section and three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers what about
the benefits of a proxy service though
besides allowing access to blocked
content proxies can serve as an
efficient firewall system they can also
filter content from third-party websites
allowing control over internet usage in
many cases browsing speeds are
stabilized compared to vanilla Internet
thanks to proper optimization on the
base proxy server the element of privacy
proxy provide provides is highly
lucrative to people looking to hide
their actual IP address from as many
crying eyes as possible one can easily
argue the benefits of using vpns over
proxies for added security measures
however a few basic tasks don't warrant
maximum privacy for the user's side as
in other cases for example many
consumers worldwide find proxy Services
more convenient since all major
operating systems starting from Windows
to Android allow proxy configuration
without the hassle of installing new
applications as is in the case of a VPN
in addition there are services online
that function as web proxies allowing
users to access block content without
any setup from there end they can enter
the target URL and the web proxy will
route data from its physical server this
level of freedom is hard to come by in
the case of vpns making proxies an ideal
solution for casual browsing with the
next generation of Internet exchanges
focused on maximum privacy and security
a variety of ways have been enforced to
maintain them as such censorship has
been shifted from the streets to the
digital domain it forces the standard
citizen to derive alternative ways to
maintain anonymity major weapon in this
battle for privacy and security is the T
browser an independent browser meant to
browse the internet while reing
information through the tour Network it
serves as a meaningful alternative to
the standard internet browsing habits to
better understand the purpose of this
brows and such we must learn about the
work of the to network featuring its own
routing protocol the to browser is an
easy way to maintain anonymity while
browsing without emptying one's wallet
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the T Network and its
significance in the working of the to
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
Tor directories in order to circumvent
government sensation ship moving on we
learn a few features of the to browser
and the distinct advantages the to
network provides next we learn the
difference between using a VPN and a
tour to anonymize internet usage and
finally we have a live demonstration of
the T browser anonymization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open Source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the tour was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid rise in development
and innovation of digital products has
given way to frequent data breaches and
cyber thefts in response consumers are
increasingly opting for products that
offer data privacy and cyber secur
security T is one such underground
Network that was implemented for the
purpose of protecting users identities
the T network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the to network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user requester Final
Destination these random user are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the T Network disguises
your identity by encrypting the traffic
and moving it across different to relays
within the network the T Network uses an
onion routing technique for transmitting
data hence the original name of onion
router to operate within the T Network a
user has to install the T browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the T
Network it has its own feature set which
we will be be going over later in this
video as we discussed already the data
passing through the to network must
follow a unique protocol known as The
Onion routing protocol let us learn more
about its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is transmitted directly
the sender has data packets to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind however
since the data can easily be captured
while being transmitted the security of
this exchange is not very reliable
moreover it becomes very easy to trace
the origin of such requests on many
occasions websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a sender with the to browser
installed on the client system the
network sends the information to node
one's IP address which encrypts the
information and passes it on to node 2's
address which performs another
encryption and passes it on to node 3
address this is the last address which
is also known as the exit node this last
not decrypts the encrypted data and
finally relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user the to network
obfuscates user IP addresses from
unwanted surveillance by keeping the
user's request untraceable with multiple
servers touching the data it makes the
tracking very difficult for both I isps
and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
T Works let us learn more about the T
browser the to browser was developed by
a nonprofit organization as a part of
the T project in 2008 and its first
public release was announced the to
browser is a browser for from the
popular Firefox that anonymizes your web
traffic using the T network if you're
investigating a competitor researching
an opposing litigant in a legal dispute
or just think it's creepy for your ISP
or the government to know what websites
you visit the to browser might be the
right
solution before the to browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for everyday
consumers starting from the setup to the
usage the entire process demanded a lot
of knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers centor and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major feature of the tour
browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the T network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these
onion websites which are only available
within the to network onion is a special
use top level domain which designates an
anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service similar to The
Links of the Deep Web these onion links
provide services like online shopping
cryptocurrency and many other products
not available in the consumer Internet
space often being considered as a Haven
for illegal activity and sales on links
provide both information and Assets in a
private manner without the risk of
spying by
authorities browsing the web over to is
slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users door browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously journalist
and dissidents around the world have
embraced tore as a Cornerstone of
democracy and Searchers are hard at work
at improving TOS anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the T browser
over standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonymity over
the Internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network doubting the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by Third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via T usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the T browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference T is completely free and open
source all of the code for the browser
and the network can be audited and has
been cleared for security concerns when
it comes to VPN there are many different
brands which have open- Source clients
but the same cannot be set for their
counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stolen
further moving on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the sender it goes through all of
those relay points while in the case of
a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one to
one between the client and a
VPN as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes
through similarly the multi-layer
encryption of to is consistent if you
use T browser every single request
passes through the same layer of
encryption and follows the same routing
protocol in the case of a VPN different
companies offer different levels of
encryption some have multihop some
prefer a single onetoone connection and
these kind of differences make the
choice much more
variable finally the nodes and relays
being used in the T Network are
volunteer there is no company holding
over them so jurisdiction becomes
relatively straightforward for in in the
case of vpns many such vpns are hosted
by adware companies or are being
monitored by Central governments to note
the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding of the the T browser and
its routing let us take a look at how
the to browser can anonymize and protect
our internet
usage on opening of the T browser for
the first time this is the page that
you're going to be welcomed with you
have the option of connecting to the T
Network before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome
currently is showing as Navi Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check the same link
on the T browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the tour browser will be little delayed
and the speed will be hampered because
of the multiple layers of encryption
like we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is is no VPN configured
there is no proxy attached it's straight
up the out of the box settings that come
inbuilt with the tour browser similarly
we have an option of cleaning up the
data let's say if you want to refresh
your location and you want to use a
different ID for the next browsing
session if you just restart it once and
we can have to check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this time as you can see we have
Netherlands right now so this is how you
can keep refreshing your address you can
keep refreshing your host location so
that you cannot be tracked when in
browsing the internet like we discussed
we have some onion links that can only
be used on the tour
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the Tor
Browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the T
Network this is kind of an alternative
Wikipedia website where we can find
articles to read and more information to
learn similarly we have another onion
link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser now these kind of delays are
expected but they are a valid compromise
because they maintain the anonymity that
many people desire similarly we have
found a hidden wallet which is a
cryptocurrency wallet which is
specifically for dark web
members this operates over the T Network
and this is used by mostly journalists
and people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the T Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available imagine our houses without a
fence or boundary wall this would make
our properly easy accessible to
trespassers and robbers and place our
homes at Great risk right hence fencing
our property helps safeguarded and keeps
trespassers at Bay similarly imagine our
computers and networks with without
protection this would increase the
probability of hackers infiltrating our
networks to overcome this challenge just
like how boundary walls protect our
houses a virtual wall helps Safeguard
and secure our devices from Intruders
and such a wall is known as a firewall
firewalls are security devices that
filter the incoming and outgoing traffic
within a private Network for example if
you were to visit your friend who lives
in a gated community you would First
Take permission from the security guard
the security guard would check with your
friend if you should be allowed entry or
not if all is well your access is
granted on the other hand the security
guard would not Grant permission to a
trespasser looking to enter the same
premises here the entry access depends
solely on your friend the resident's
discretion the role of the security
guard in this case is similar to that of
a firewall the firewall works like a
gatekeeper at your computer's entry
point which only welcomes incoming
traffic that it has been configured to
accept firewalls filter the network
traffic within your network and analyzes
which traffic should be allowed or
restricted based on a set of rules in
order to spot and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address destination address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports the firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
their source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network when
you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network this
is when a firewall comes to your Rescue
by acting as a barrier between your
computer and the internet the firewall
rejects the malicious data pack and thus
protects your network from hackers on
the other hand traffic from trusted
websites is allowed access to your
network this way the firewall carries
out quick assessments to detect malware
and other suspicious activities thereby
protecting your network from being
susceptible to a Cyber attack firewalls
can either be Hardware or software
software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called a host firewall meanwhile
Hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the Gateway and
your network linky routers are a good
example of a hardware firewall besides
this there are other types of firewalls
designed based on their traffic
filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a packet
filtering firewall if the incoming
Network traffic is not for the
predefined rules that traffic is blocked
a variant of the packet filtering
firewall is the state inspection
firewall these types of firewalls not
only examine each Network packet but
also checks whether or not that Network
packet is part of an established network
connection such firewalls are also
referred to as Dynamic packet filtering
firewalls our next type of firewall is
called a proxy firewall this draws close
comparison to how you give proxy
attendance for a friend like how you
take the authority to represent your
friend the proxy firewall pretends to be
you and interacts with the internet they
come between you and the internet and
thereby prevents direct connections this
protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they're
also known as application Level Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content it's the year
2015 and Richard has just finished
playing games on his computer after a
long gaming session Richard tries to
shut it down but finds some random text
file on the desktop that says Ransom
note the text file mentioned how a
hacking group had encrypted Richard's
game files and private documents and he
had to pay a ransom of 500 $100 worth of
bitcoin in a specified Bitcoin address
Richard quickly checked his files only
to see them being encrypted and
unreadable this is the story of how the
Tesla Crypt ransomware spread in 2015
which affected thousands of Gamers
before releasing the master key used for
encrypting the files so what is
ransomware for Richard to be targeted by
such an attack he must have installed
applications from untrusted sources or
clicked an unverified link both both of
them can function as gateways for a
ransomware breach ransomware is a type
of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
a password ATT Tex files available to
the victim explaining how to make the
ransom payment and unlock the files for
it just like Richard found the ransom
note text file on his desktop even after
the money has been paid there's no
guarantee that the hackers will send the
decryption key or unlock the files but
in certain sensitive situations victims
make the payment hoping for the best
having never been introduced to
ransomware attacks before this gave
Richard an opportunity to learn more
about this and he began his research on
the topic the spread of ransomware
mostly starts with fishing attacks to
know more about fishing attacks click
the link in the button above
users tend to click on unknown links
received via emails and chat
applications promising rewards of some
nature once clicked the ransomware fil
is installed on the system that encrypts
all the files or blocks access to
computer functions they can also be
spread via malware transmitted via
untrusted application installation or
even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access a
computer can be accessed remotely using
this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is a type of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a log
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers once the files are
encrypted finding the decryption key is
impossible unless the ransomware variant
is old and the keys are already
available on the Internet scareware is
fake software that claims to have
detected a virus or other issue on your
computer and directs you to pay to
resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with popup
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting a affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security one must always have backups of
their data cloud storage for backup is
easy but a physical backup in a hard
drive is always recommended keeping the
system updated with the latest security
patches is always a good idea apart from
system updates one must always have
reputed anti-virus software install many
antivirus software like kasperski and
Bit Defender have anti-ransomware
features that periodically check for
encryption of private documents when
browsing the internet a user must always
check for the lock symbol on the address
bar which signifies the presence of
https protocol for additional security
if a system is infected with ransomware
already there's a website Noor ransom.
org it has a collection of decryption
tools for most well-known ransomware
packages it can also help decrypt
specific encrypted files if the list of
anti-ransomware tools didn't help the
victim malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
prion viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus and
troan firstly let's take a look what
exactly is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan hor Trojan H
horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms the system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create back doors into our
system to allow the cyper criminal to
steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting installed into
our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the copy routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the troan hor
functioning for troan horses entry way
into our system is through emails that
may look legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the troan
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
and rions are let's understand different
types of virus and
rions let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is known
as the boot sector virus this type of
virus damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the masterbot record
which is also known as MBR this damages
the boot sector section by targeting the
hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus
macro virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system or on a
larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
troan the first type of troan is the
back door troan
they are designed to create a back door
in the system on execution of an
infected program they provide remote
access of a system to the hacker this
way the Cyber criminal can steal our
system data and may use it for illegal
activities next we have cricos Rion they
enter the system by clicking the random
popups which we come across on the
internet they ATT the user to give their
personal details for different
transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the Cyber
criminal and the last troan type is
ransome troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system
functioning the Cyber criminal Demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the troan program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding viruses and rosion
let's solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in a
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind his system's
problem option a macrovirus option b
Ransom troan option C back door troan
give your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and
Trojan in our
system to detect virus or Tron activity
in our system we can refer to the
following points for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data
and lastly we have frequent system
crashes due to virus infection which
damages the operating system for Trojan
we have frequent system crashes and
system also faces slow reaction time
then we have there are more random
popups from the system which may
indicate troan activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the dextop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a troan
program next let's take a look at a
famous Cyber attack for virus and a
trojan
horse for virus we have the maom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back door
access into our
systems next for the troan horse we have
the emot troan program which is a
specifically designed for financial
theft and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or troan
attack for a
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses can this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
budge better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into our
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for troan we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any troan activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and Fireballs
for protection against troan
is a good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video Let's Take a look what we
learned for the first part we saw the
main objective of the virus is to harm
the data and information in a system
whereas for the troan we have stealing
of the data files and information effect
of viruses is more drastic in comparison
to the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non- remote progr programs whereas
trojen horses are remote accessed and
lastly viruses have the ability to
replicate itself to harm multiple files
whereas Trojan does not have the
replication ability so let's begin with
what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to inter
with the database now normally this
attack is targeted towards a database to
extract uh the data that is stored
within however the vulnerability does
not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just configuring
the database itself so the attacker at
this point in time when they send a
query to the application will form a
malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database uh basically gets cracked or
does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick demo so what we have done
here is I have this virtual machine
called oasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this
on till this power is on I'm going to
show you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can just look for
OAS broken web application project
download you'll find it on
sourceforge.net click on the
link you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or Oracle
virtual box now this is an application
that has been developed by oasp which
stands for open web application security
project which is a not for-profit
organization and uh periodically uh
releases the most top 10 risks that an
application uh will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice practice upon to develop
our our skills upon because doing this
in the real world is illegal I cannot go
onto a website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so to to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine hosted in a
VM workstation or Oracle virtual box and
you can uh then try your skills on it
right so uh just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 7113 to
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in 192 168 71.
132 and you'll see the oasp broken web
application project and there are lot of
training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutil day over here
uh this gives you the uh o top 10 risks
for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest one so
far uh but the difference between 2013
and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them uh the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh attacks blind
SQL injection and then there is a tool
called SQL map which is available freely
on your Linux machines Ki Linux or parro
Linux whichever you want to use uh for
your practice targets and so on so forth
so if I just take you here for bypass
Authentication
and this is a regular login page that an
application may have right you look at a
username you look at password you type
that in and you log in so let's say I
don't know a password here I'm just
going to type in the username test
password is
pswd I try to log in and it shows me
that the account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work the I
did tyy type in a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote or 1 equal 1 space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on log in
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it give me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and uh we're going to look at
the basics of SQL injection so looking
at that small demo looking now let's
look at what types of SQL injections are
available so the first is inband SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within inband error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a Time based attack and the
third one is outof bound SQL injection
attack now what is inband SQL injection
attack inband is where you're either
attempting the error based or the union
based what is error based uh we send a
query to the data datase we craft a
query to the database and uh it
generates an error M message and it
dumps the error message right in front
of us on the screen that makes us
realize that there is a flaw and there
there is some information that is dumped
on the screen which we can then further
utilize to craft our further queries as
we go ahead whereas Union base is the it
is where we combine multiple statements
at the same time so if you look at the
URL earlier in the URL you would see a
large structure in that URL uh we can
try to add more two or more statements
within the URL itself to combine them
and then confuse the database into
executing both the statements together
and giving a data dump at the same time
right so what would a error based uh SQL
injection look like if I go back to the
same database uh which is here right and
if you remember in the username we gave
it uh single quote or 1 equals 1 space
hyphen hyphen space we gave it the
condition right so basically what it did
was this a single code is an operator
that goes to the database selects the
default uh table uh in the user tables
in this database column and then
Compares it to the condition that is
given so the condition that we gave was
1 equals one which is always true so
what it did was it selected the default
uh user table that was available in the
database and instead of comparing it to
a password it compared it to the
condition so if I give it one equals 2
where the condition is false and if I
log in you will see that the account
doesn't exist comes back again because
the condition was false and instead of
comparing the user account to the
password it basically uh compared the
user account to the condition so if I
give it a single quote or 1 equals 1
hyphen hyphen space and uh and log in
you can see that this is a correct
condition and thus we are able to log in
now before we even go to that extent if
I just forget the condition over here
and I just give it a single code the
operator and I send this operator to the
database and I click on login you will
see that it generates an error which is
right on top and it tells us the line
the uh file where the error happened and
you can see it happened in the MySQL
handler. PHP file right and then it give
us the message you have an error in your
SQL syntax check the manual that
corresponds to your MySQL server version
for the right syntax to use now why
would a hacker want to do this in the
first place because there are different
types of databases so there is a MySQL
mssql or Microsoft SQL Oracle SQL IBM
db2 all of these are variations of the
SQL database uh they use the SQL
language however every database has its
own Command right they they have their
their own syntax they have their own uh
specific commands that are utilized for
the database so in this scenario the
hacker wants to identify what database
is being currently utilized so they can
craft those particular queries so now
with this injection with just me sending
the quote and the error getting
generated I now come to know that we are
using a MySQL server and the version of
that server is 5.1.7 3 and uh the rest
of the information about uh where the
handlers are located and so on so forth
right this gives the information to the
hacker of how they want to proceed next
what kind of queries they want to create
what kind of syntax they want to utilize
so error based attack is where you
generate these kind of Errors uh and you
get this information the union base is
where you craft your queries within the
URL or you can try to combine multiple
statements within the input fields and
try to generate a response from that
then we come to Boolean based SQL
injection uh sends a SQL query to the
database which forces the application to
return a different result depending on
whether the query returns a true or a
false result so basically if the input
is false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input B the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs the attack will come to know
which input is true with this he can
then access the database of the website
so you're trying to figure out by
sending out multiple inputs uh and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
uh which command exactly worked what was
the resultant output of that command
thus from this kind of an information
the hacker can infer their next step
forward then you have time based sequel
injections uh now there are times when a
database administrator an application
administrator has done some security
configuration and does have disabled
verbos error messages now what is a
verbos error message the error message
that we saw right here is a verbos error
message that means that the message
gives out details the message gives out
details about what the database is the
version and whatnot so if they have
sanitize these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot f
figure out what database is then what do
you do right for example if I just take
you to Simply
learn
and take you to a URL that that is
supposedly not accessible you can see
that it gives a generic error oops like
it looks like you have crash landed on
Mars it doesn't give you a verbose error
that we saw here so this gives us a
detail error of what went wrong where it
gives us the database the version of the
database and uh where the query went
wrong and etc etc etc whereas on this
side where there's some there's a lot of
security that goes in here so you can
see that it doesn't generate a error it
just get a generic page in front of you
so in that case what does a hacker do so
the hacker then injects a Time
based uh query in the URL which allows
us to verify whether the command is
being executed or not so uh we put in a
time
wait let's say 10 seconds of time weit
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is possible possible
however if we inject the query and uh it
just gets executed without the delay
that means that the time uh injection
attack would not be uh possible on that
particular site outof bound is not a
very common attack it depends on the
features being enabled on the database
management system that is being used by
the web application so this can be a
somewhat of a misconfiguration error uh
by the database administrator where you
have enabled functions and not sanitized
them so you have not done in access
controls properly you have not given
account control so queries should never
be executed at an administrative level
they should always be uh executed at a
user level with minimum privileges that
are required for that query to be
executed now if you're allowing these
kind of functions to be uh to be enabled
at the dbms and there's an
administrative account that can have
access to them at that point in time an
outof bound injection attack is possible
so let's look at how a website works
right uh how SQL works on a website now
the website is constructed of HTML
hypertext markup language uh which would
include javascripting for functionality
cascading stylesheet for the mapping of
the website right and then reactjs and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the SQL query
uh at the client side you'll have uh all
these scripting languages coming in uh
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server side you'll have uh
databases like Oracle MySQL Ms SQL and
so on so forth that will then execute
those queries right so just to give you
an example if I use a tool called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've uh used it on quite a bit
uh here we have a example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to Gmail the
moment I sent it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error right
uh you can see that the application
converted this into a SQL query so the
query was select username from accounts
where the username in quote single
quotes and we use the quote right the
single quote right there so uh that's
where we use that operator and that's
where the exception error occurred so
these are the kind of queries that are
structured by the application and then
taken on to the database for execution
when we type in uh it is a HTTP get
request with the username and password
within that query uh that is sent to the
application the application converts it
into a SQL query sends it to the
database and the database responds with
the appropriate response so how do we
prevent SQL injection in the first place
use use prepared statements and
parameterized queries uh these
statements make sure that the parameters
passed into SQL statements are treated
in a safe manner so for example we saw
that the single code was an operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place right so here what we
are doing here is a secure way of
running a SQL query in the jdbc using a
parameterized statement Define which
user we want to find so there's a string
the email comes in connection to the
database we are going to figure out how
the connection is going to be passed how
it is going to be created construct the
SQL statement we want to run specifying
the parameter right so we Define how is
it going to be uh created what is going
to be created what can be passed to the
database and what should not be passed
to the database so that is one way of
utilizing prepared statements and
parameterized queries then we have
object relational mapping most
development uh teams prefer to use OB
object relational mapping Frameworks to
make the transl ation of SQL results set
into code objects more seamless so this
is an example of object relational
mapping uh where we map certain objects
and allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs it a simple way to
protect against most SQL injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of quote
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized uh in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created the
code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are they
feed out by the application and they
never reach the database other methods
of uh preventing SQL injection are uh
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use o
or uh some other service for a single
sign on mechanism does uh you rely on a
third party to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
on to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you're start
playing a game you're allowed to log
into the game using your Facebook
credentials or your Google credentials
now that is not just for ease of use but
the game user the developer has
outsourced the authentication mechanisms
to third party such as Facebook or
Google because they understand that that
authentication mechanism is as safe as
can be Facebook and Google Google are
wealthy organizations uh hire a lot of
Security Experts and the development for
their authentication mechanisms is
topnotch small organization cannot spend
that kind of money on security itself
right so you use a third party
authentication mechanism to ensure that
these kind of attacks may not happen
then web application firewalls uh having
a web application firewall and
configuring it properly uh for SQL
injection attacks is one of the shot
method of uh mitigating or minimizing
the uh threat in the first place so at
this point in time you have realized
that the application has some
vulnerabilities for SQL injection and
instead of recoding or restructuring the
application uh you want to take the
easier way out or the cheaper way out so
what you do is you uh you install a web
application firewall and you configure
the web application firewall to identify
malicious queries and stop them uh at
the firewall level itself so they never
reach the application and thus the
vulner ities on the application don't
get
executed buy better software and keep on
updating the software so it's not
necessary that once you have a software
you install it it's going to be safe for
Life new V abilities are discovered
every day every hour and it may so
happen what is secure today may be
completely insecure tomorrow or the day
after right so you need to keep on
upgrading the software if there are no
upgrades available and the VAB still
exist you you might want to migrate to a
better software and does uh ensure that
you don't get hacked right always update
and use patches organizations keep on
sending out updates and patches as and
when they are released you need to
install them to uh enhance your security
postures and then continuously monitor
SQL statements and databases use
protocol monitors uh use different
softwares use the firewalls to keep on
monitoring what kind of queries you uh
getting and based on those queries you
want to ensure the inputs and the
queries that are creating uh are not
detrimental to the health of the
software that you have Jane is relaxing
at home when she receives an email from
a bank that asks her to update her
credit card pin in the next 24 hours as
a security measure judging the severity
of the message Jane follows the link
provided in the email on delivering her
current credit card pin and the
supposedly updated one the website
became unresponsive which prompted her
to try some time later however after a
couple of hours she noticed a
significant purchase from a random
website on that same credit card which
she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with the malicious link
that entailed credit card fraud this is
a classic example of a fishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word fishing which works on
the concept of baits if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our case makes Jane
the fish and the fishing emails the bait
if Jane never opened the malicious link
or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials a fishing attack
starts with a fraudulent message which
can be transmitted via email or chat
applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as sming which is a
specific category of fishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns where an identical
fishing mail is sent to thousands of
users the rate of success is relatively
low but never zero between 2013 and 2015
corporate giants like Facebook and
Google were tricked off of $100 million
due to an extensive fishing campaign
where a known common associate was
impersonated by the hackers apart from
credit access some of these campaigns
Target the victim device and install
malware when clicked on the malicious
links which can later function as a botn
net or Target for ransomware attacks
there is no single formula for there are
multiple categories of fishing attacks
the issue with Jane where the hacker
stole her bank credentials falls under
the umbrella of deceptive fishing a
general email is sent out to thousands
of users in this category hoping some of
them fall prey to this scam spear
fishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive fishing techniques
on the other hand a simple screenshot of
a Spotify playlist being shared on
social media indicates a probable point
of entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
private information since the hacker
already knows the target uses Spotify
the chances of victims taking the bait
increase substantially for more
important targets like CEOs and people
with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10f which can be called
a case of wailing the hackers prepare
and wait for the right moment to launch
their fishing attack often to steal
industry secrets for rival companies or
sell them off at a higher price apart
from just emails farming focuses on fake
websites that resemble their original
counterparts as much as possible a
prevalent method is to use domain names
like Facebook with a single o or YouTube
with no e these are mistakes that people
make when typing the the full URL in the
browser leading them straight to a
counterfeit web page which can fool them
into submitting private data a few more
complex methods exist to drive people
onto fake websites like ARP spoofing and
DNS cach poisoning but they are rarely
carried out due to time and resource
constraints now that we know how fishing
attacks work let's look at ways to
prevent ourselves from becoming victims
while the implications of a fishing
attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relatively
strong straightforward Jane could have
saved herself from credit card fraud had
she checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that it redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or popup
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti-fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prevent fishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all times
start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a Layman's
perspective cross-site scripting also
known as xss is a type of code injection
attack that occurs on the client's side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the real
Attack takes place when the victim hits
the malicious code infected web page or
online application the web page or
application serves as a vehicle for the
malicious script to be sent to the
users's browser forums message boards
and online pages that enable comments
are vulnerable vehicles that are
frequently utilized for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then pass this
user input in VB script ActiveX Flash
and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript going to the fact that
JavaScript is most important to most
browser experiences
nowadays the main purpose of this attack
is to steal the other users identity be
it via cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different client side programming
languages as
well cross-side scripting is often
compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of its ability to damage even less
vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed with JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client side code adds
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike servers side languages such as
PHP JavaScript code runs inside your
browser and cannot impact the website
for other visitors it is sandbox to your
own Navigator and can only perform
actions within your own browser window
while JavaScript is client site and does
not run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously the manner of attack can
range in a variety of face it can be a
single link which the user must click on
to initiate a JavaScript piece of code
it can be used to show any piece of
images that can be later used as a front
end for malicious code being installed
as malware but the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the
client's side using a fake page or even
a form that is displayed to the the user
on websites with displayed
advertisements malicious emails can also
be sent to the victim these attacks
occur when the malicious user finds the
vulnerable parts of the website and send
it as appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-side scripting let us learn
more about how this kind of attack
works the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website asks the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately Rees the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here it passes on certain arguments to
the web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting a tag Vector means sending and
injecting malicious code or script this
attack can be performed in different
ways depending on the type of attack the
malicious script may be reflected on the
victim's browser or stored in the
database and executed every time when
the user calls the appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output a malicious user can enter a
script which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is Mal
ious or not therefore this malicious
script is being executed on the victim's
browser or any faked form if that is
being displayed for the users there are
many ways to trigger an xss attack for
example the execution could be triggered
automatically when the page loads or
when a user hovers over specific
elements of the page like hyperlinks
potential consequences of cross-site
scripting attacks include capturing
keystrokes of a user redirecting a user
to malicious websites running web
browser based exploits obtaining cookie
information of a user who is logged into
a website and many more in some cases
cross-side scripting attack leads to
complete compromise of the victim's
account attackers can trick users into
entering credentials on a fake form
which can then provide all information
to the attacker with the basic working
of a cross-side scripting attack out of
the way let us go over the different
ways hackers can leverage vulnerable web
applications to gather information and
eventually breach those systems
the prime purpose of Performing xss
attack is to steal the other person's
identity as mentioned it may be cookies
session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display
faked Pages or forms for the victim
however this can be performed in several
ways we have a reflected attack this
attack occurs when a malicious script is
not being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected accesses code is not being
saved permanently in this case the
malicious code is being reflected in any
website result the attack code can be
included in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
different ways by displaying faked
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflected cross-side
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious code
and then spread the same URL via email
or social media a user who clicks on
this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser the script
is not stored in the web application and
malicious code is shown only to one user
the user that opens the link executes
the script and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server side
or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting attacks this occurs
when when a malicious script is being
saved on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored xss attack
can affect many users also as the script
is being stored on the web server it
will affect the website for a longer
time
in order to perform stored xss attack
the malicious scripts should be sent
through the vulnerable input form for
example can be a commment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored xss example the
script might have been submitted via an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a sufficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
database
the consequence of this might be that
the script is now being delivered to all
users visiting the web application and
for example able to gain access to the
user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently St in the web app the users
visiting the app after the information
retrieve the script the malicious code
then exploits the flaws in the web
application and the script and the
attack is visible on the server side or
to the app owner as
well the third variant is is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how xss
Dom attack is being performed Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order to perform xss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based xss attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be
executed the malicious quote the
exploits flaws in the browser on the
user side and the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-side
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of feels one
can Safeguard against such attacks let's
go through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier exis
attacks are sometimes difficult to
detect however this can be changed if
you get some external help a way to
prevent accss attacks is using automated
testing tools like crash test security
suit or actic security
suit still manual testing is highly
timec consuming and costly and therefore
not possible to be done for every
iteration of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected xss
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server side as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against accesss
vulnerabilities typically requires
properly escaping user provided data
that is placed on the page rather than
trying to determine if the data is user
provided and could be compromised we
should always play it safe and Escape
data whether it is user provided or not
unfortunately because there are many
different rules for escaping you still
must choose the proper type of escaping
before settling on a final
code encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First uni
code escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard
introduced to prevent cross-side
scripting click checking and other code
injection attacks resulting from the
execution of malicious content in The
Trusted web page context it is a
candidate recommendations of the w3c
working group on web application
security it's widely supported by modern
web browsers and provides a standard
method for website owners to declare
approved origins of content that browser
should be allowed to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports this flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flop the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third part party if a browser does not
support HTTP only and a website attempts
to set an HTTP only cookie the HTTP only
flag will be ignored byow the browser
thus creating a traditional script
accessible cookie as a result the cookie
becomes vulnerable to theft of
modification by any malicious script
next on our docket is a live
demonstration where we solve a set of
cross-site scripting problems starting
from the basic level to the topmost
level six we're going to start at level
one in this verb application it
demonstrates the common cause of cross
side scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if you interact with the
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar this task needs only
basic knowledge let's see why the most
primitive injections work here right
away let's do a simple query and inspect
the resulting HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single code as a special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the P
load should be included in the URL to
perform successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily we're just going to write the
script over
here I'm going to press
search
as you can see we have successfully
launched our first cross-side scripting
attack we can see an alert box pop up
with the necessary message and a similar
process can be used to steal browser
cookies and passwords albeit with
different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily xss bugs can be
introduced in complex chat applications
chat app conversations are stored in a
database and retrieved when a user wants
to see the conversation therefore if a
malicious user injects some JavaScript
code all visitors will be infected this
kind of cross-site scripting attack is
more powerful and it is more riskier
than reflected crossed scripting attacks
and that's why is known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I get
whatever I typed in simply appeared on
the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source you can see here the text I
posted seems directly put inside a block
code tag so even a simple script tag we
used in level one should work here but
it will not let us examine the code to
understand why
we're going to toggle the code of here
and check the index.html
file important
part is line
32 the generated HTML fragment which is
the HTML variable in the code is added
to the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will will not execute
any script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parer will not execute a
script tag when it passes htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
javascripts we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we are
loading an image that doesn't exist
which causes to trigger an on error
event in on error event the it will
execute our alert
method with that we are able to beat
level two and we can now move up to the
next level in our
challenge as you can see clicking on any
tab causes the tab number to be
displayed in the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the
URL is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in
97 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the events
are ases here once again I will choose
to use the existing IMG tag and change
the source to something that doesn't
exist hence forcing it to fall in to
execute an on error even which I will
pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of attack
in this web application there is a timer
on the page that means whatever numbers
we put in the Box a countdown starts and
then when it finishes the application
alerts that the countdown is
finished and we can see the time is a
popup appearing over here and this
resets the timer again now it is obvious
that the value entered in the text box
is transferred to the server over the
timer parameter in the URL
let us examine the code to see how the
timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over
here in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload event however the
timer parameter is being directly passed
to the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
of the function start timer without
making the JavaScript code the parameter
value is directly added to the start
timer method without any filtering what
we can try to do here is to inject an
alert function to be executed inside the
on loone event along with the start
timer
method we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here
now I me press on create
timer and we have a popup with the xss
level four
complete we can now move on to level
five in this web application this
application xss is different cuz this
challenge description says cross-side
scripting isn't just about correctly
escaping
data sometimes s attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cuz the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected
the href attribute value of next link is
confirm which is exactly the value of
the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means using the next query parameter can
be used to inject a JavaScript code to
the href attribute of the next
link the following is the best way to do
it as soon as the user clicks on the
link the script will be
triggered we're going to press anything
random and now that we click next we can
see the xss level five that we had
provided in the URL as a parameter to
the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level
six in this sub application it shows
some of the external Javascript is
received if you analyze the URL you can
see that the script is loaded already
the vulnerability lies within how the
code handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget
name and then in line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method and the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line 8
a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being
created that is with this vulnerability
we can inject our own Javascript file
into the code we can inject a URL of our
own hosted JavaScript into the web
applications URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not be using https but
anything like that to bypass the regular
expression for security
checking going to remove the pre-stored
URL and we're going to load our own
Javascript
file
finally we have reached the end of our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting attacks and
used different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without out specific
measures to ensure a secure session
apart from individuals organizations
worldwide that host data and conduct
business over the internet are always at
the risk of a Dos attack these DS
attacks are getting more extreme with
hackers getting easy access to botet
farms and compromised devices as can be
seen in the graph three of the six
strongest DDOS attacks were launched in
2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020 lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botet allow further penetration into the
consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DS attack
in 2018 widely suspected to be conduct
conducted by Chinese authorities this
attack went on for about 20 minutes
after which the systems were brought
into a stable condition it was the
strongest DS attack to date at the time
and made a lot of companies reconsider
the security practices to combat such
attacks even after years of
experimentation Ros attacks are still at
large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space hey
everyone this is B from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on what is a DS
attack let's learn more about what is a
Dos
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a a DS attack comes
from multiple systems generally these
attacks work by Drowning a system with
requests for data this could be sending
a web server so many requests to serve a
page that it crashes under the demand or
it could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
app ations or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control
center the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DS campaign
but how do these devices come under aotn
net and what are the requests being made
to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how dos attack
work a Dos attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
any time to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the bot net the
devices in this networks are called Bots
or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these requests the
target thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth these can be simple
ping requests or complex attacks like SN
flooding and UDP flooding the aim is to
overwhelm them with more traffic than
the server or the network can
accommodate the goal is to rent the
website or service
inoperable there's a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of DS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of Dos
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured in bits per
second these attacks focus on clogging
all the available bandwidth for the
server thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balances and firewalls which are meant
to protect the system against the DOR
attacks these protocol attacks include
SN floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but since the IP is poofed
and leads nowhere the server gets stuck
in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application layer attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application layer attacks is
measured in request per second these are
relatively sophisticated attacks that
Target the application and operating
system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network bandid up to the point of a
system crash examples of such an attack
are HTTP flooding and bgp hijacking
a single device can request data from a
server using HTTP post or get without
any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a Dos attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them
the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many ds attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against rival groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals resources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a dets attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launched
these d do attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a while toos
attacks have also found use in the
political segment certain activists tend
to use DS attacks to voice their opinion
spreading the word online is much faster
than any local Rally or Forum primarily
political these attacks also focus on
online communities ethical dilemas or
even protest against corporations let's
take a look at a few ways that companies
and individuals can protect themselves
against redos
attacks the company can employ load
balances and firewalls to help protect
the data from such attacks load
balancers reroute the traffic from one
server to another in a DS attack this
reduces the single point of failure and
adds resiliency to the server data a
firewall blocks unwanted traffic into a
system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a Dos attack in
action early detection of a Dos attack
goes long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious DS traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here's where
you will filter the traffic so that only
legitimate traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources the most most important stage
in DOS mitigation is where you will look
for patterns of Dos attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandw than most private networks
so it is likely to fail if under the
pressure of increased stos
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth available to a host
server being targeted since d do attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with our demo regarding
the effects of DS attacks on a system
for our demo we have a single device
that will attack a Target making it a
Dos attack of sorts once a botet is
ready multiple devices can do the same
and eventually emulate a DS attack to do
so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parro security operating system
running for a Target machine we will be
running another VMware instance of a
standard Linux distribution known as
Linux light in a Target device we can
use wire shockk to determine when the
attack begins and see the effects of the
attack
accordingly this is Linux light
which is a target machine and this is
parad security which is used by the
hacker when trying to launch a DS attack
this is just one of the dros that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal we use the command if config
and here we can find the IP address now
remember we're launching this attack in
VMware now the both the instances of
parro security and Linux light are being
run on my local network so the address
that you can see here is
192.168
72129 which is a private address this IP
cannot be accessed from outside the
network basically anyone who is not
connected to my Wi-Fi when launching
attacks with public servers or public
addresses it will have a public IP
address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool
called hping
3 hping 3 is an open-source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
Yar is a network traffic analyzer we can
see whatever traffic that is passing
through the Linux light drro is being
displayed over here with the IP address
the source IP and the destination IP as
to where the request is being
transferred to once we have the Dos
attack launched you can see the results
coming over here from The Source IP
which will be par security Now to launch
the hping 3 command we need to give PSE
sudo access to the console which is the
root
AIS now we have the root axis for the
console the hping 3 command will have a
few arguments to go with it which are as
you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is 192 168 72.1
1229 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the
parent security OS is the client and
Linux slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shock it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the requests coming in
from this IP which is 192 168
72128 till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the requests keep on coming and we
can see the http flooding has started in
flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a
backend now remember Linux light is a
drro and such Linux dros are served as
backend to many servers across the world
for example a few seconds have passed
from the attack now the system system
has become completely irresponsive this
has happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security you can see whatever I press
nothing is responded even the wi shark
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux Destro is being used as
a backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a Dos attack multiple systems such
as multiple par security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one boot Force attacks
are simple and reliable there is no
prior knowledge needed about the victim
to start an attack most of the systems
falling prey to Brute Force attacks are
actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find the one that works due
to this repeated trial and error format
the strength of password matters a great
dral although with enough time and
resources brute force will break Aker
System since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts encrypted
documents or even Network peripheral
devices the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be timec
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data off fisc are used
and at times downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks
but the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the Target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like K Linux and
parrot
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific 8-digit word containing only
letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to guess the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and arduous process but the work is
left to the computer other than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely due to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
ous
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
we can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force
among the ones listed on the screens
which one do you believe will take the
longest to be broken when using Brute
Force tools leave your answers in the
comment section and we will get back to
you with the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system compromised
due to Brute Force
attacks a hacked laptop or mobile can
have social media accounts logged in
giving the hackers free access to the
victim's connections it has been
reported on multiple occasions where
compromised Facebook accounts are
sending malicious links and attachments
to people on their friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forc A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via ft TP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the hack machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of its standing Brute
Force attack tax thanks to the sheer
number of combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to bruteforce them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or password is
compromised due to a breach or a hack
the rest of the accounts are isolated
from the
incident two-factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific TFA
applications like Ai and Aegis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for 2 course
are much more reliable and
secure captur are used to stop BS from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of BR Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good good way to prevent Brute Force
attempts many websites lock account for
30 minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
world situation the world has gone
Wireless with Wi-Fi taking the re in
every household it's natural that the
security will always be up for debate to
further test the security index and
understand Brute Force attacks you will
attempt to break into the password of a
Wi-Fi router for that to happen you
first need to capture a handshake file
which is a connection file from the
Wi-Fi router to a connecting device like
a mobile or a laptop the operating
system used for this process is parot
security a Linux distribution that is
catered to penetration testers all the
tools being used in this demo can easily
be found pre installed in this operating
system if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scaleup by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called air gedon which is
made to hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
are are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the WL X1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you can see see
above it's written it is in manage mode
right now so we're going to select
option two which is to put the interface
in monitor
mode and its name is now W land zero
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is which is the
handshake tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter we have to let this run for about
60 seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example the station that you can see
56 26 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BS ID is supposed to be
which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C it will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they configured that way
that when a client is disconnected it
tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's let's go
with the second option that is the do
air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go we have
the WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a DOT cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the
path and the Hand Shi file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option one
now to run the Brute Force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with airack plus crunch
which is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option
two it can already detect the capture
file that we have generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the ge24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10 and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we're going to
use used for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if you already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
you go with only uppercase characters
and numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this pass phrase over here
the first five or six digits are a it
starts working its way from the end from
the last character it keeps trying every
single combination you can see the last
the fourth character from the right side
the D it will eventually turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever pass phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world cyber
attacks are frequently making headlines
in today's digital environment at any
time everyone who uses a computer could
become a victim of a Cyber attack there
are various sorts of cyber attacks
ranging from fishing to password attacks
in this video we'll look into one such
attack that is known as botet but before
we begin if you love watching Tech
videos subscribe to our Channel and hit
the Bell icon never to miss an update to
begin with let's take a look at some of
the famous bot attacks the first one is
Mirai bot which is a malicious program
designed to attack one vulnerable iot
devices and infect them to form a
network of bots that on command perform
basic and medium level denial of service
attacks then we have the zoos bot is
specifically designed for attacking the
system for Bank related information and
data now let's see what exactly a botnet
is botnet refers to a network of
hijacked interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
are known as Bots and the hijack
criminal known as bot Herer remotely
controls them the Bots are used to
automate Blas skill attacks including
Data Theft server failure malare
propagation and denial of service
attacks now that we know what exactly a
bot net is let's dive deeper into
learning how bot net works during the
preparation of a botnet network the
first step involves preparing the bot
net Army
after that the connection between the
bot net Army and the control server is
established in the end the launching of
the attack is turn by the B Herer let's
understand through our
illustration firstly we have a b Herer
that initiates the attack according to
the control server commands the devices
that are infected with the malw programs
and begins to attack the infected system
let's see some details regarding the
preparation of the bot net
Army the first step is known as the
prepping the bot net Army the first step
is creating a botnet is to infect as
many as connected devices as possible
this ensures that there are enough Bots
to carry out the attack this way it
creates Bots either by exploiting the
security gaps in the software or
websites or using fishing attacks they
are often deployed through Trojan
horses for the next step we have step
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with the specific malware
that connects the device back to the
control bot server a bot Herer uses
command programming to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to admin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the B
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like
IRC when the B Herer issues a command to
the server it is then related to the
clients to perform malicious
actions then then we have peer-to-peer
model here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the BS are tropological
interconnected and act as both C and C
servers that is the server and the
client to the hackers adopt this
approach to avoid detection and single
point
failure in the end we will see some
points on some countermeasure against
bot net
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates after that we
should avoid clicking random popups or
links that we often see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti-spyware softwares and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack the internet is
an endless source of information and
data still in some cases we come across
some occurrences like cyber attacks
hacking force entry which may affect a
Time on the web hi everyone and welcome
to the simply La Channel today we will
discuss a topic that secretly records
our input data that is known as key
loggers but before we begin if you like
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data regularly this is Jacob
from the information Department who is
here to inform her about some of the
security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow reaction speed and unusual
internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came AC
cross was the key logging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system to begin with we learn what
exactly the key logging program
is as the name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that are
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a lock file then the same program
secretly sends these lock files to its
origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key loging program into
our
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases is when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present
on the net which can harm our system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arounds is API based the most
common key logging case which uses apis
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggests they are based key
loggers that store the form data that is
if we often use web forms or different
kinds of forms to enter different data
they can be recorded into the system by
the program and send it to its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type type on the
keyboard and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
loging issue or
not in the case of hand devices
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use onscreen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different kinds of or malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key loging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system
now to prevent our system from getting
infected by the key loging program let's
take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering of
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it
the system says the library is already
installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we type
on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
key log text file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where
the format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given as
along with the time
stamp as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed is
pred
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line
and
logging the Pressed
key
info a string file to be
recorded into the lock file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release that will come into play
when
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle
that will be going for while press
and
on release will contain while
release
function as
listen
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the log file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it now
now to verify the program let's open
notepad and on the notepad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the botton
over here we see the key log text that
is the text file that we created let's
open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is the hello world part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the the summary firstly
we learn what exactly key loggers are
then we understood what different modes
are present how the system get infected
with the key logging problem then we
learned how to detect the problem into
our system then we learned what
different types of key loggers are
present on the net we also understood
how hackers use the recorded data from
the program and we also learn whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging problem or not and lastly we
understood what different points can be
taken to prevent the entering of the key
logging problem into the system and
before we begin if you are someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security or to become an ethical
hacker by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts and try giving a short
to Simply Lars postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schi College of computing the course
link is mentioned in the description
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered before we learn about the
Pegasus platform let us understand what
spyware is and it's working spyware is a
category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information with some spy
systems even clicking on the link isn't
necessary to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such spy system that is
making the rounds in the tech industry
today is Pegasus the Pegasus is a
spyware system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android version
this is not a newly developed platform
since Pegasus has existed since as early
as 2016 a highly intricate spy program
that can track user location read text
messages scan through mobile files
access device camera and microphone to
record voice and video Pegasus has all
the tools necessary to enforce
surveillance for any client that wishes
to buy its services initially the NSO
group had designed the software to be
used against terrorist factions of the
world with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
Forefront Pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
National Security unfortunately the
people who bought the software had
complete control over who how and up to
what level they can put surveillance
limits on eventually the primary clients
became Sovereign Nations spying on
Public Information that is supposed to
stay private became really easy with
this service multiple devices can be
affect With the same spy system to
create a network information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages by
pass this filter and make their way into
a person's inbox they look like generic
emails which are supposed to be safe the
Pegasus pyware targets such occurrences
by passing malicious messages and links
which install the necessary Spy software
on the user's mobile device be it
Android or an iPhone this isn't unique
to the email ecosystem since it's
equally likely to be targeted by SMS Tex
WhatsApp Instagram or even the most
secure messaging apps like signal and
threa once the malicious links are
clicked a spyware package is downloaded
and installed on the device after the
spyware is successfully installed the
perpetrator who sent the payload to the
victim can monitor everything the user
does Pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes to the
device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex py software like Pegasus
can access the root files on our mobiles
these root files hold information that
is crucial to the working of the Android
and iOS operating systems leaking such
private information is a massive blow to
the security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible ible due to the
zero day vulnerabilities known as bugs
in the software development process the
zero day bugs are the ones that have
just been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these explo IDs are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection unlike Crypt Miners and
Trojans spying Services usually do not
demand many system resources which makes
them tough to detect after they have
been activated since many devices slow
down after a couple of years any kind of
Performance Set due to such spyware is
often attributed to poor software
longivity by the users they do not check
meticulously for any other causes that
is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if you are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall prey to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
we will rev the correct answer next week
but what about the unaffected devices
the vulnerable ones while we cannot be
certain of our security there are a few
things we can do to boost our device be
it against Pegasus or the next big spy
on the market let's say we are safe now
and we have the time to take the
necessary steps to prevent a spyware
attack what are the things we can go for
our primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits Target
are often discovered by developers from
Google and apple which send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen pre
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spyware platform altogether
another big factor is the spread of
malware is the trend of sideloading
Android applications using do APK files
downloading such apps from a third party
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware invasion on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into our
device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains spiv is a controversial segment
in governance while the ramifications
are pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veale of democracy
altogether even if our daily life is
rather simplistic we must understand
that privacy is not about what we have
to hide instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both rhetorically and
literally hey everyone do we look at the
hack which took the World by storm and
affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar wind attack
the global statistics indicate that
upward of 18,000 customers have been
affected potentially needing billions to
recover the losses in C before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the notification
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
learn the date is December 8th 2020
firei a global leader in company
specializing in cyber security released
a blog post that caught the attention of
the entire it Community a software known
as Orion which was developed by solar wi
incorporat had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running since the
spring of 2020 and went virtually
unnoticed for months the reveal sent the
developers of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fixes for the platform in order
to mitigate this threat and prevent
further damage but how did this come
into existence we first need to
understand the platform which was
responsible for this breach soloin a
software company based in Texas United
States had developed a management
platform known as Orion Hing to
corporations and governments worldwide
Orion was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
bought the platform solar winds claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferbly services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was software
updates the update server for solar
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a Trojan to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled these software
updates was breached once the update
server repository was compromised the
source code of the applications became
open to modification and malicious code
found its way onto the software the
remote access troen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers backd
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believe the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposedly hit the hardest as the
list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issued
quick updates to fix these
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believ that
this was an act of crossborder corporate
Espionage conducted by state sponsored
hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar wind hack was it one a virus a
remote access Trojan a spyware or a worm
let us know your answers in the comment
section right away and we will reveal
the correct answer in a week coming to
possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encouraged since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a RCT no
as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar winds hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly $18 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers access some us
attorneys Microsoft 365 email accounts
as part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FBI and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more complicated
job than it looks on paper the day is
26th February
2022 the world is hit with breaking news
that Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a activist
collective in movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade this was in response
to the Russian aggression on Ukrainian
territory and the hopes of annexation
Anonymous hacked the Russian State TV
networks to combat propaganda in Russia
and highight the damage to life Meed out
by the Kremlin in Ukraine they also
hacked 120,000 Russian troops personal
information and the Russian Central Bank
stealing 35,000 files this served as a
clear indicator of how cyber War can
change the momentum in battle something
which people had never seen so closely
so what is cyber War a digital assault
or series of strikes or hacks against a
country is sometimes referred to as a
cyber War it has the ability to to cause
havoc on government and civilian
infrastructure as well as disrupted
essential systems causing State harm and
even death in this day and age the
internet plays a bigger role than just
watching videos and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry Financial transactions so
rather than resorting to physical
violence cyber War has become the new
means to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet in most
circumstances cyber warfare involves the
nation state attacking another in
certain cases the assaults are carried
out by terrorist organizations or
non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in June 2021 Chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
Verizon to secure remote access to their
networks stuck net was a computer worm
designed to attack Iran's nuclear
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in
2010 since the definition of cyber war
is so vague the applying rules and
sanctions based on digital assault is
even tougher making the field of cyber
warfare a lawless land not bound by any
rules or policies there are multiple
ways in which these attacks can be
carried out a major category of Cyber
attack is espionage Espionage intels
monitoring other countries to steal
critical Secrets this might include
compromising vulnerable computer systems
with botn Nets or spear fishing attempts
before extracting sensitive data in
cyber warfare the next weapon in cyber
war is sabotage government agencies must
identify sensitive data and its dangers
if it is exploited Insider threats such
as disgruntled or irresponsible
Personnel or government staff with ties
to the attacking country can be used by
hostile countries or terrorists to steal
or destroy information by overwhelming a
website with bogus requests and forcing
it to handle them denial of service
attacks prohibit real users from
accessing it attacking parties may use
this this form of assault to disrupt key
operations and systems and prevent
citizens military and security officials
and research organizations from
accessing sensitive websites but what
benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
globally without having to travel
thousands of miles as long as the
attacker and Target are connected to the
internet organizing and launching Cyber
Wars is relatively less tedious Than
Physical Warfare people living in or
battling for a country are subjected to
propaganda attacks in an attempt to
manipulate their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today's modern world starting from
communication channels to Secure Storage
servers crippling a country's footprint
and control on the Internet is very
damaging but what are some of the ways
we as Citizens protect ourselves in the
case of a cyber war in the unfortunate
event that your country is involved D in
Warfare be sure to fact check every
piece of information and follow only
trusted sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of War
drastically it is highly crucial to
follow basic security guidelines to
secure our devices like regularly
updating our operating systems
occasionally running full system
antivirus scans Etc if your country or
organization is being attacked
having devices segregated in a network
goes a long way in bolstering
security try to avoid sharing a lot of
personal data online in this era of
Instagram and Facebook divulging private
information can be detrimental to
keeping a secure firewall for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defenses and if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security that is by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who Al sits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts and try giving a short
to Simply lears postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from the MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered during data transmission there
are various external factors which can
affect the transmission of data over a
network channel to prevent such cases
from happening we use Internet Protocol
security which we'll be discussing in
the session on IP SEC explain hi guys
and welcome to year testing video by
simply learn but before we begin if you
are watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
miss an update from us now without
further Ado let's take a look at the
agenda for this
session to begin with we will look into
what is IP SEC continuing with why do we
use IPC in a
network followed by components of
IPC modes of Ip security as for the last
topic we will look into working steps
involved in IP security let's begin with
the first heading that is what is
IPC IPC Internet Protocol security is
defined as a set of framework and
protocol to ensure data transmission
over a network
channel this protocol was initially
defined of two main protocols for data
security over a network channel which
were authentication header which is
responsible for data integrity and
anti-replay
services and the second protocol is
encapsulating security payload in short
ESP which includes data encryption and
data
authentication now let's move on to the
next setting that is why do we use IPC
in a network
IP SEC is used to secure sensitive data
and information such as company data
clinical data Bank data and various
sensitive information regarding an
institution which are used during data
transmission over an Network
channel the use of vpns that are virtual
private networks and apply IP protocols
to encrypt the data for inin
transmission
let's continue with why do we use IPC
Services IPC is also used to encrypt
data for application layer in the OSI
model and provide security for sharing
data over Network routers and data
authentication let's take a look at the
working of ipx
services to begin with we have two
different system system one and system
two which will establish a network
channel and then the encryption of data
which will takes place when one host
will share the data to the second host
during this ipx services will secure the
data that is to be transferred over the
network channel by applying router
encryption and
authentication now let's move on to the
next topic that is components of
IPC the ipx services comprises of
multiple protocols that ensure the data
transmission over the network channel
the first one is encapsulating security
payload protocol in short
ESP this protocol of Ip security
provides data encryption and
authentication
services and it also authenticates and
encrypt the data packet in the
transmission
Channel moving on we have authentication
header in short
ah similar to ESP the authentication
header also provides all the security
services but it does not encrypt the
data it also protects the IP packet and
adds additional headers to the packet
header the modified IP datagram looks
this way where the IP components are
included at the second position the
seventh position and the sixth position
along with the authentication of data
services over the network
channel moving on we have Internet key
exchange ik
ke this protocol provides protection for
Content data and also changes the
attribute of the original data to be
shared by implementing sha and md5
algorithms they also check the message
for authentication and then only is
forwarded to the receiver side for
example this is the original data packet
we are used to with IP head upar PCP UDP
and data whereas this is the modified IP
site data packet where ESP header is
added between between IP header and the
TCP
protocol now let's move on to the next
heading that is modes of Ip
SEC there are basically two types of Ip
modes available for data transmission
over the network channel where the first
one is tunnel mode this mode of
transmission is used to secure gateway
to Gateway
data it is applied when the final
destination of the data is to be
connected to a sender site through a
connection Gateway over the Internet for
example we have two host host a and host
B through the host a we are sending a
message to host B which will pass
through a Gateway at host a point and it
passes through a gateway to host B
then this is a basic format for Gateway
to Gateway data
transmission and the given IP datagram
format is used for tunnel mode now let's
move on to the second mode of Ip s that
is transport mode this mode of IPC is
used to protect protocols like TCP or
UDP and is used to ensure end to end
communication unlike tunnel mode the
transport mode data at authentication
header and encapsulating security
payload for security purpose in the IP
header this is the modified IP datagram
for transport mode the point to be noted
is the IP SE header is always added
between IP header and TCP
header now let's move on to the last
heading for the session on IP SEC that
is the working steps involved in IP
Security in general there are five steps
involved in the working of Ip sec to
ensure data transmission over a network
channel the first step is host
recognition in the first step the host
system will check if the packet is to be
transmitted or Not by automatically
triggering the security policy for the
data which is implemented by the sender
side for proper
encryption then the second step is known
as ik Phase 1 in this step the two host
devices the center and the receiver site
will authenticate each other to
establish a secure network channel
it is comprised of two modes the main
mode this provides much better security
with a proper time
limit and the second mode known as
aggressive mode as the name suggests it
establishes the IPC protocol much faster
in comparison to main mode let's move on
to the third step which is ik Phase 2
after the second step the host decide
the type of cryptography algorithm to
apply over the session in the network
channel and the secret key for the
algorithm to be used to encrypt the data
for
transmission then we have IP SEC
transmission this step involves the
actual transfer of data over the network
channel using various protocols used in
ipx security which are implemented under
the tunnel
condition and the last step is IPC
termination after the completion of data
exchange or session timeout the IP
tunnel is terminated and the security
key established is discarded by both the
host system network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network it
architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it effective
network security strategies employ
multiple lines of defense that are
scalable and automated each defensive
layer here enforces a set of security
policies which are determined by the
administrator beforehand this aims at
securing the confidentiality and
accessibility of the data and the
network see every company or
organization that handles a large amount
of data has a degree of solutions
against many cyber threats the most
basic example of network security is
password protection it has the network
the user chooses recently network
security has become the central topic of
cber security with many organizations
involving applications from people with
skills in this area it is crucial for
both personal and professional networks
most houses with highspeed internet have
one or more wireless routers which can
be vulnerable to attacks if they're not
adequately
secured data loss theft and sabotage
risk may be decreased with the usage of
a strong network security system your
workstations are protected from
hazardous FW thanks to network security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network by dividing information into
various sections encrypting these
portions and transferring them over
separate Pathways network security
infrastructure offers multiple levels of
protection to th man in the middle
attacks preventing situations like
eavesdropping among other harmful
attacks it is becoming increasingly
difficult in today's hyperconnected
environment as more corporate
applications migrate to both public and
private clocks additionally modern
applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team Network traffic
and infrastructure must be protected in
these cases since assaults on businesses
are increasing every single day we now
understood the basics of network
security but we need to understand how
network security works in the next
section in slightly more detail network
security revolves around two processes
authentication and authorization the
first process which is authentication is
similar to access cards which ensure
that only those have the right to enter
a building in other words authentication
checks and verifies that it is indeed
the user belonging to the network who is
trying to access or enter it thereby
preventing unauthorized
intrusions next comes
authorization this process decides the
level of access provided to the recently
authenticated
user for example Network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network based on the network users rule
the process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization today's Network
architecture is complex and faces a
threat environment that is always
changing and attackers that are always
trying to find and exploit
vulnerabilities these vulnerabilities
can exist in many areas including
devices data applications users and
locations for this reason many Network
Security Management tools and
applications are in use today that
address individual
threats when it's just a few minutes of
downtime can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place
beforehand now that you know a little
about network security and its working
let's cover to the different types of
network
security the fundamental tenant of
network security is the layering of
protection for massive networks and
store data that ensure the acceptance of
rules and regulations as a whole there
are three types the first of which is
physical security the next being
Technical and the third being
administrative let's look into physical
security first this is the most basic
level that includes protecting data and
network to unauthorized personal from
acquiring control over the
confidentiality of the network this
include external peripherals and rout RS
that might be used for cable connections
the same can be achieved by using
devices like biometric systems physical
security is critical especially for
small businesses that do not have many
resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large
firms when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions this kind fulfills two
functions one is defense against
unauthorized us users the other is a
defense against malevolent
actions the last category is
Administrative this level of network
security protects user Behavior like how
the permission has been granted and how
the authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks this
level also suggests necessary amendments
that have to be done to the
infrastructure I think that's all the
basics that we need to cover on network
security and in which our next topic
we're going to go through two mediums of
network security which are the transport
layer and the application
layer so transport layer is a way to
secure information as it is carried over
the Internet with users browsing
websites emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with a
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications the connection
employes lighter symetric cryptography
to save bandwidth and processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app player security can
lead to Performance and stability issues
data theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
lay attacks include distributed denal of
service attacks or DDOS attacks HTTP
floods hql injections cross-site
scripting Etc most organizations have an
arsenal of application layer security
protections to combat these and more
such as web application firewalls secure
web Gateway Services Etc now that we
have the theory behind network security
has been covered in detail let us go
through some of the tools that can be
used to enforce these network security
policies the first two to be covered in
the section is a firewall a firewall is
a type of network security device that
keeps track of incoming and outgoing
Network traffic and it decides which
traffic to allow or deny in accordance
to a set of security rules for more than
25 years firewalls have served as
Network Security's first line of defense
they provide a barrier between
trustworthy internal protected and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some
points the next which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for short it's an
encrypted connection between a device
and a network via the Internet the ened
connection AIDS the secure transmission
of sensitive data it makes it impossible
for unauthorized parties to e drop on
the traffic and enables remote work for
the user the usage of VPN technology is
common in both corporate and personal
networks next we cover the importance of
intrusion prision systems in network
security
or IPS Frameworks an intrusion
prevention system is a network security
tool that continually scans the network
for harmful activity and response to it
when it does occur by reporting blocking
or discarding it it can be either
Hardware or software it's more
sophisticated than an intution detection
system or an IDs framework which can
just warn an administrator and merely
identify harmful activities while in the
case of an IPS it actually takes against
that activity the next tool in this
section and the final one are going to
be behavioral analytics behavioral
analytics focus more on the statistics
that are being carried over and stored
through months and years of usage once
some kind of similar pattern is noted
but the it administrator can detect some
kind of attack the similar attacks can
be stopped and the security can be
further
enhanced now that we have covered all
that we need to know about network
security the necessary tools it's
different types Etc let's go to the
benefits of network security as
four the first which is protection
against external threats the objective
for cyber assaults can be as varied as
the Defenders themselves although
they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert the attacks are
getting a strong cyber security posture
that considers routine software updates
May assist firms in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry
points the next benefit is protection
against internal threats the human
aspect continues to be the cyber
security systems weakest link Insider
risk can originate from current or
former workers third party vendors or
even trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright EV
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote location s can
make it easier for these kind of threats
to go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
dangers may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive
disasters the third benefit is increased
productivity it is nearly impossible for
employees to function when Network and
personal devices are slowed to a crawl
by viruses and other cyber attacks
during the operation of website and for
the company to run you may significantly
minimize violations and the amount of
downtime required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls
virus scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email fishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training another benefit is brand trust
and
reputation customer retention is one of
the most crucial elements in business
development customers today place a
premium on maintaining brand loyalty
through a strong cyber security stance
since this is the fastest way to get
other businesses back get referrals and
sell more tickets overall additionally
it helps manufacturers get on the vendor
list with bigger companies as a part of
the supply chain which is only as strong
as its weakest link this opens
possibilities for potential future
endeavors and development with the rise
in censorship and general fear over
privacy loss consumer security is at a
an all-time high risk technology has
made our life so much easier while
putting up a decent Target on our
personal information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
Safeguard our data and be up to date
with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet Anne Anne wanted to
look for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and found her rather Shady
website that offered a 50% discount on
the first purchase once Anne submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after devastated and
quickly realized she she had failed to
notice that the website was a HTTP web
page instead of an https one the payment
information submitted was not encrypted
and it was visible to anyone keeping an
eye including the website owner and
hackers had she used a reputed website
which has encrypted transactions and
employees cryptography our iPhone
Enthusiast could have avoided this
particular incident this is why it's
never recommended to visit unknown
websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today we take a
look into what cryptography is and how
it works we learn where cryptography is
being used in our daily lives and how we
are benefiting from it then we will
understand the different types of
cryptography and their respective uses
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action let's Now
understand what cryptography
is cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties encryption is a primary route
for employing cryptography by adding
certain algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography for example when simply
learn is jumbled up or changed in any
format not many people can guess the
original word by looking at the
encrypted text the only ones who can are
the people who know how to decrypt the
coded word thereby by reversing the
process of
encryption any data pre- encryption is
called plain text or clear text to
encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers they
are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
cipher text and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content wonder what else we would lose
if not for
cryptography any website where you have
an account can read your passwords
important emails can be intercepted and
their contents can be read without
encryption during the transit more than
65 billion messages are sent on WhatsApp
every day all of which are secured
thanks to endtoend
encryption there is a huge Market
opening up for cryptocurrency which is
possible due to blockchain technology
that uses encryption algorithms and
hashing functions to ensure that the
data is secure if this is of particular
interest to you you can watch our video
on blockchain the link of which will be
in the description of course there is no
single solution to a problem as diverse
as explained there are three variants of
how cryptography works and is in
practice they are symmetric encryption
asymmetric
encryption and hashing let's find out
how much we have understood until now do
you remember the difference between a
cipher and Cipher text leave your
answers in the comments and before we
proceed if you find this video
interesting make sure to give it a
thumbs up before moving ahead let's look
at symmetric encryption
first symmetric encryption uses a single
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data it is comparatively
less secure than asymmetric encryption
but much faster it is a compromise that
has to be embraced in order to deliver
data as fast as possible without living
information completely vulnerable this
type of encryption is used when data
rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times Caesar Cipher and
igma machine are both symmetric
encryption examples that we will look
into further for example if Alice wants
to send a message to Bob she can apply a
substitution Cipher or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message symmetric
encryption uses one of the two types of
ciphers stream ciphers and block ciphers
block ciphers break the plane text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into Cipher text stream
ciphers convert the plane text into
ciper Tex one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks in today's world the most
widely used symmetric encryption
algorithm is AES 256 that stands for
advanced encryption standard which has a
key size of 256bit with 128bit and 196
bit key sizes also being available other
primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the dees the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
Blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of AES AES chops UPS the
data into blocks and performs 10 plus
rounds of obscuring and substituting the
message to make it
unreadable asymmetric encryption on the
other hand has a double whammy at its
disposal there are two different keys at
play here a public key and a private key
the public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message Bob uses his own private key
to decrypt the data this way nobody can
intercept the message in between
transmissions and there is no need for
any secure key exchange for this to work
since the encryption is done done with a
public key and the decryption is done
with a private key that no one except
Bob has access to both the keys are
necessary to read the full
message there is also a reverse scenario
where we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message this
mechanism also proves that the sender is
authenticated and there is no problem
with the or of the
information RSA encryption is the most
widely used asymmetric encryption
standard it is named after its Founders
reest Shamir and Edelman and it uses
block ciphers that separate the data
into blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than EES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time since asymmetric
encryption takes longer to decrypt large
amounts of data the full information is
encrypted using a single key that is
symmetric encryption that single key is
then transmitted to the receiver using
Asm Network encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the defy helpman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into the third
variant of cryptography is termed as
hashing hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of data beyond
recognition it gives an output of fixed
size which is known as the hash value of
the original data or just hash in
general the calculations that do the job
of of messing up the data collection
form the hash function they are
generally not reversible without
resilient Brute Force mechanisms and are
very helpful when storing data on
website servers that need not be stored
in plain text for example many websites
store your account passwords in a hashed
format so that not even the
administrator can read your credentials
when a user tries to log in they can
compare the entered password's hash
value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
Authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same
input cryptography has been in practice
for
centuries Julius Caesar used a
substitution shift to move alphabets a
certain number of spaces beyond their
place in the alphabet table a spy can't
decipher the original message at first
glance for example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use a substitution shift
of plus two a becomes C c b becomes D
and so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus
three becomes D ww dfn this Cipher has
been appropriately named the Caesar
Cipher which is one of the most widely
used
algorithms the Enigma is probably the
most famous cryptographic Cipher device
used in ancient history it was used by
the na German armies in the world wars
they were used to protect confidential
political military and administrative
information and it consisted of three or
more rotors that scrambled the original
message depending on the machine State
at that time the decryption is similar
but it needs both machines to stay in
the same state before passing the cipher
text so that we receive the same plane
text message let's take a look at how
our data is protected while we browse
the internet thanks to cryptography here
we have a webbased tool that will help
us understand the process of RSA
encryption we see the entire workflow
from selecting the key size to be used
until the decryption of the cipher text
in order to get the plain text back as
we already know RSA encryption algorithm
falls under the umbrella of asymmetry
key
cryptography that basically implies that
we have two keys at play here a public
key and a private
key typically the public key is used by
the sender to enip the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
deip the message there are some some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well in RSA we have the choice of key
size we can select any key from a
512-bit to 1024-bit all the way up to a
496 bit key the longer the key length
the more complex the encryption process
becomes and thereby strengthening the
cipher text although with added security
more complex functions take longer to
perform the same operations on similar
size of data we have to keep a balance
between both speed and strength because
the strongest encryption algorithms are
of no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024-bit key over here now
we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on past freezes the tool we are
using right now generates the sudo
random keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case
these two keys are mathematically linked
with each other they cannot be
substituted with any other key and in
order to encrypt the original message or
decrypt the cipher text this pair must
be kept together the public key is then
sent to the sender and the receiver
keeps the private key with himself in
this scenario let's try and encrypt a
word simply
learn we have to select if the key being
used for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over
here the cipher we are using right now
is plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well once we click on
encrypt we can see the cipher text being
generated over
here
the pseudo random generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different Cipher
text this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods now that we are done with the
encryption process let's take a look at
the decryption
part the receiver gets this Cipher text
from the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to deip the message since they
are mathematically linked we paste the
private key here and select the same the
cipher must always so be the same used
during the encryption
process once we click decrypt you can
see the original plane text we had
decided to encrypt this sums up the
entire process of RSA encryption and
decryption now some people use it the
other way around we also have the option
of using the private key to encrypt
information and the public key to
decrypt it this is done mostly to
validate the origin of the message since
the keys only work in pairs if a
different private key is used to encrypt
the message the public key cannot
decrypt it conversely if the public key
is able to decrypt the message it must
have been encrypted with the right
private key and hence the rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key and use that to encrypt the plain
text and select the same in this
checkbox as well you can see we have
generated a completely new Cipher text
this Cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for
decryption let's select the correct
checkbox and decrypt and we still get
the same
output now let's take a look at
practical example of encryption in the
real
world we all use the internet on a daily
basis and many are aware of the
implications of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at Wikipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
H stands for secured let's take a look
at how it secures the
data wi shck is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use the software to see the traffic that
is living a machine and to understand
how vulnerable it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to
[Music]
Wikipedia let's search for something
that we can navigate the website
with okay once we get into it a little
you can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice
versa as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way to put this in
perspective let's take a look at another
website which is a HTTP web
page this has no encryption enabled from
the server end which makes it vulnerable
to attacks there is a login form here
which needs legitimate user credentials
in order to Grant access let's enter a
random pair of
credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data
transfer unsurprisingly we weren't able
to get into the platform instead we can
see the data
packets let's apply a similar filter
that will help us understand what
request this website is
sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here see whatever username and
password that we are entering we can
easily see it with the wire shockk now
we used a dummy pair of credentials if
you select the right data packet we can
find our correct credentials if any
website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it would have been really easy to get a
hold of these to reiterate what we have
already learned we must always avoid
HTTP websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online there are two types of
encryption in
cryptography symmetric key
cryptography and asymmetric key
cryptography both of these categories
have their pros and cons and differ only
by their implementation today we are
going to focus exclusively on symmetry
key
cryptography let us have a look at its
applications in order to understand its
importance
better this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving onto
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial symmetric cryptography
helps in detecting bank fraud and boost
the security index of these payment
gateways in
general they are also helpful in
protecting data that is not in transit
and rests on servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
Assurance of minor to no
delay while browsing the internet we
need symmetric encryption to browse
secure https websites so that we get an
all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption Keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security this helps us in
preventing the rather insecure HTTP
website
format so let us understand how
symmetric key cryptography works first
before moving on to the specific
algorithms symmetric key cryptography
relies on a single key for the
encryption and decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into Cipher text and vice
versa as you can see in the image the
key used for encryption is the same key
needed for decrypting the message at the
other end the secret key shouldn't be
sent along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography
graphy key exchange can be done
beforehand using other algorithms like
the defy Helman key exchange protocol
for
example for example if Paul wants to
send a simple message to Jane they need
to have a single encryption key that
both of them must get secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious
actors it can be generated by either one
of them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message I am ready is
converted into Cipher text using a
specific substitution Cipher by Paul in
that case Jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to decp this Cipher
text once it reaches her irrespective of
the scenario where someone manages to
grab the cipher text mid transit to try
and read the message not having the
secret key renders everyone helpless
looking to snop in the symmetric key
algorithms like the data encryption
standard have been in use since the
1970s while the popular ones like the
EES have become the industry standard
today with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of Paramount importance to keep
it secret on All
Occasions the side effect of having a
single key for the encryption and
decryption is it becomes a single point
of failure anyone who gets their hand on
it can read all the encrypted messages
and do so mainly without the knowledge
of the sender and the receiver so it is
the priority to keep the encryption and
decryption key private at all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin if the sender somehow
transmits the secret key along with the
cipher text anyone can intercept the
package and access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's Integrity is
writing on the promise that the users
can keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public provided we manage to keep the
key secret we still have to choose what
kind of ciphers we want to use to
encrypt this information in symmetric
key cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a
look stream ciphers are the algorithms
that encrypt basic information one bit
at a time it can change depending on the
algorithm being used but usually it
relies on a single bit or bite to do the
encryption this is the relatively
quicker alternative considering the
algorithm doesn't have to deal with
blocks of data at a single time every
piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format in stream ciphers
each binary digit is encrypted one after
the other the most popular ones are the
rc4 salsa and Panama the binary data is
passed through an encryption key which
is a randomly generated bitstream upon
passing it through we receive the cipher
text that can be transferred to the
receiver without fear of man in the
middle attacks the binary data can be
passed through an algorithmic function
it can have either X or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or heximal format to give our final
Cipher
text on the other hand block ciphers
disect the raw information into chunks
of data of fixed size the size of these
blocks depend on the exact Cipher being
used a 128bit block Cipher will break
the Plaine text into blocks of 128bit
each and encrypt those blocks instead of
of a single digit once these blocks are
encrypted individually they are chained
together to form a final Cipher
text block ciphers are much slower but
they are more tamper proof and are used
in some of the most widely used
algorithms employed
today just like stream ciphers the
original Cipher text is converted into
binary format before beginning the
process once the conversion is complete
the blocks are passed to the encryption
algorithm along with the encryption key
this would provide us with the encrypted
blocks of binary
data once these blocks are combined we
get a final binary
string this string is then converted
into hexadecimal format to get our
Cipher text today the most popular
symmetric key algorithms like AES Dees
and 3des are all block Cipher
methodology
subsets with so many factors coming into
play there are quite a few things
symmetrically cryptography excels at
while falling short in some
other symmetrically cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric cryptography there is only
one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption similarly the performance of
symmetric encryption is much more
efficient under similar computational
limitations fewer calculations help in
better memory management for the host
system bulk amounts of data that need to
be encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetry key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication Channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the SE Keys transmitted to
both the sender and receiver without any
prior mishandling the rest of the system
aligns easily and everyday
Communications becomes easy and secure
if the algorithm is applied as per the
documentation symmetric algorithms are
very robust and can enip vast amounts of
data with very less
overhead Dees algorithm stands for data
encryption
standard it is a symmetric key Cipher
that is used to encrypt and recpt
information in a block by block manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they're later chained together to form
our final Cipher text which is then sent
to a
receiver DS takes the original unaltered
piece of data called the plain text in a
64-bit block and it is converted into an
encrypted text that is called the cipher
text it uses 48 bit Keys during the
encryption process and follows a
specific structure called the fistal
Cipher structure during the entire
process it is a symmetric key algorithm
which means DS can reuse the keys used
used in the encryption format to decrypt
the cipher text back to the original
plain text once the 64bit blocks are
encrypted they can be combined together
before being
transmitted let's take a look at the
origin and the reason thees was
founded DS is based on a fistal block
Cipher called Lucifer developed in 1971
by IBM cryptography researcher host
fistal DS uses 16 rounds of this fist
structure using a different key for each
it also utilizes a random function with
two inputs and provides a single output
variable DS becames the organization's
approved encryption standard in November
1976 and was later reaffirmed as a
standard in 1983 1988 and finally in
1999 but eventually DS was cracked and
it was no longer considered a secure
solution for all official roots of
communication consequently triple Ds was
developed triple Ds is a symmetry key
block Cipher that uses a double Ds
Cipher encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple Ds was
ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using DS for encrypting messages in
order to search for a better alternative
a public wide competition was organized
and helped cryptographers develop their
own algorithm as a proposal for the next
global standard this is where the rile
algorithm came into play and was later
credited to be the next Advanced
encryption standard for a long time DS
was the standard for data encryption for
data security its rule ended in 2002
when finally the advanced encryption
standard replaced Dees as an acceptable
standard following a public competition
for a
place to understand the structure of a
fistal Cipher we can use the following
image as a reference the block being
encrypted is divided into two parts one
of which is being passed onto the
function while the other part is exor
with the function's output the function
also uses the encryption key that
differs for each individual round this
keeps going on until the last step until
where the right hand side and the left
hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final Cipher text for the
decryption process the entire procedure
is reversed starting from the order of
the keys to the block sorting if the
entire process is repeated in a reverse
order we will eventually get back our
plane text and this Simplicity helps the
speed overall This was later detrimental
to the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was
compromised a fistal block Cipher is a
structure used to derive many symmetri
block ciphers such as DS which as we
have discussed in our previous comment
pistol Cipher proposed a structure that
implements substitution and permutation
alternately so that we can obtain Cipher
text from the plane text and vice versa
this helps in reducing the redundancy of
the program and increases the complexity
to combat Brute Force
attacks the fistel cipher is actually
based on the Shannon structure that was
proposed in
1945 the fistel cipher is the structure
suggested by horse feistel which was
considered to be a backbone while
developing many symmetric block ciphers
the Shannon structure highlights the
implementation of alternate confusion
and diffusion and like we already
discussed the fistal Cipher structure
can be completely reversed depending on
the data however we must consider the
fact that to decrypt the information by
reversing the Fel structure we will need
the exact polinomial functions and the
key
orders to understand how the blocks are
being calculated we take a plane test
which is of 64bit and that is later
divided into two equal halves of 32 bit
each in this the right half is
immediately transferred to the next
round to become the new Left half of the
second r the right hand is again passed
off to a function which uses an
encryption key that is unique to each
round in the fistal Cipher whatever the
function gives off as an output it is
passed on as an xor input with the left
half of the initial plane text the next
output will become the right half of the
second round for the plain text this
entire process constitutes of a single
round in the fistal
Cipher taking into account what happens
in a polinomial
function we take one half of the block
and pass it through an expansion box the
work of the expansion box is to increase
the size of the half from 32bit to
48-bit text this is done to make the
text compatible to a 48 bit Keys we have
generated
beforehand once we pass pass it through
the EXO function we get a 48-bit text as
an output now remember a half should be
of 32bit so this 48 bit output is then
later passed on to a substitution box
this substitution box reduces its size
from 48 bit to 32bit Output which is
then later exort with the first half of
the plane
text a block Cipher is considered the
safest if the size of the block is large
but large block sizes can also slow down
encryption speed and the decryption
speed generally the size is
64-bit sometimes modern block ciphers
like AES have a 128bit block size as
well the security of the block cyer
increases with increasing key size but
larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process earlier 64-bit
keys were considered sufficient modern
ciphers need to use 128bit Keys due to
the increasing complexity of today's
computational standard
the increasing number of rounds also
increase the security of the block
Cipher similarly they're inversely
proportional to the speed of
encryption a highly complex round
function enhances the security of the
block Cipher Al we must maintain a
balance between the speed and
security the symmetric block Cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed there is
no use of an algorithm it cannot be
implemented in a real life framework
that can help organizations to encrypt
or decrypt the data in a timely manner
now that we understand the basics of FAL
ciphers we can take a look at how Dees
manages to run through 16 rounds of the
structure and provide the cipher text at
the end now that we understand the
basics of FAL ciphers we can take a look
at how DS manages to run through 16
rounds of this structure and provide a
cipher text in simple terms DS takes the
64-bit plain text and converts it into a
64-bit Cipher text and since we are
talking about asymmetric algorithms the
same key is being used when it is
decrypting the data as
well we first take a 64-bit ke plane
text and we pass it through an initial
permutation function the initial
permutation function has the job of
dividing the block into two different
parts so that we can perform fisal
Cypher structures on
it there are multiple rounds being
procured in the algorithm namely 16
rounds of his Cipher structure each of
these rounds will need keys initially we
take a 56-bit cipher key but it is a
single key we pass it onto a round key
generators which generates 16 different
keys for each single round that the
fistal Cipher is being run these keys
are passed on to the rounds as 48 bits
the size of these 48 bit Keys is the
reason we use the substitution and
permutation Bongs in the polinomial
functions of the special
ciphers when passing through all these
rounds we reach round 16 where the final
key is passed on from the round key
generator and we get a final permutation
in the final permutation the RS are
swapped and we get a final Cipher text
this is the entire process of Dees with
16 rounds of FAL ciphers encompassed in
it to decrypt a cipher text back to the
plane text we just have to reverse the
process we did in the DS algorithm and
reverse the key order along with the
function
this kind of Simplicity is what gave
Dees the bonus when it comes to speed
but eventually it was detrimental to the
overall efficiency of the program when
it comes to security factors DS have
five different modes of operation to
choose from this one of those is
electronic codebook each 64-bit block is
encrypted and decrypted independently in
the electronic codebook format we also
have Cipher block chaining or the CBC
method here each 64-bit block depends on
the previous one and all of them use an
initialization
Vector we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding Cipher
text becomes the input for the
encryption algorithm it produces a su
random output which in turn is exor with
the plane
text there is an output feedback method
as well which is the same as Cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding
DS counter method has a different way of
approach where each PL text block is
exor with an encrypted counter the
counter is an incremented for each
subsequent block there are a few other
alternatives to these modes of operation
but the five mentioned above are the
most widely used in the industry and
recommended by cryptographers
worldwide let's take a look at the
future of
DS the dominance of DS ended in 2002
when the advanced encryption standard
replaced the DS encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done
following a public competition to find a
replacement nist officially withdrew the
global acceptance standard in May 2005
although triple Ds has approved for some
sensitive government information through
2030 n also had to change the DS
algorithm because its Kei length was too
short given the increased processing
power of the new computers encryption
power is related to the size of the key
and DS found itself a victim of ongoing
technological advance ances in Computing
we have received a point where 56-bit
was no longer a challenge to the
computers of cracking note that because
DS is no longer the nist federal
standard does not mean that it is no
longer in use triple Ds is still used
today and is still considered a legacy
encryption
algorithm to get a better understanding
of how these keys and Cipher Tex look
like we can use an online tool for our
benefit as we already know to encrypt
any kind of data a key is mandat
this key can be generated using
mathematical functions or computerized
key generation program such as this
website offers it can be based on any
piece of text let's say the word is
simply
[Music]
learn in our
example once the key is settled we
provide the plain text or the clear text
that needs to be encrypted using the
aforementioned key suppose a sentence
for this example is this is my first
message
we have satisfied two prerequisites the
message and the key another variable
that goes into play is the mode of
operation we have already learned about
five different modes of operation while
we can see some other options here as
well let us go with the CBC variant
which basically means the cipher block
chaining method one of cbc's key
characteristics is that it uses a
chaining process it causes the
decryption of a block of Cipher text to
depend all on the preceding Cipher text
blocks as a result the entire validity
of all the blocks is contained in the
previous adjacent blocks as well a
single bit error in a cipher text block
affects the decryption of all the
subsequent blocks rearrangement of the
order of these for example can cause the
decryption process to get
corrupted regarding the manner of
displaying binary information we have
two options here we can either go with
base 64 or the hexadecimal format let's
go with the Bas 64 right
now as you can see the cipher text is
readily available b64 is a little more
efficient than hex so we will be getting
a smaller Cipher text when it comes to
b64 albeit the size of both the formats
will be the same the hex has a longer
Cipher text since B 64 takes four
characters for every three bytes while
hex will take two characters for each B
hence B 64 turns out to be more
ficient now to decut the cipher text we
go by the same format choose base
64 we copy the cipher text onto a
decryption tool and we have to make sure
that the key we are using is exactly the
same we choose similar mode of
operation and we choose the correct
encoding format as well which is BAS 64
in this
case as you can see the encryption is
complete and we get a plain text back
even if you keep everything the same but
we just change the encoding format it
will not be able to decrypt
anything unfortunately DS has become
rather easy to crack even without the
help of a key the advanced encryption
standard is still on top when it comes
to symmetric encryption security and
will likely stay there for a
while eventually with so much computing
power growth the need for a stronger
algorithm was necessary to safeguard a
personal data as solid as Dees was the
computers of today could easily break
the encryption with repeated attempts
thereby rendering the data security
helpless to counter this dilemma a new
standard was introduced which was termed
as the advanced encryption standard or
the AES
algorithm let's learn what is Advanced
encryption
standard the AES algorithm also known as
the reile algorithm is a symmetric block
Cipher with a block size of 128 bits it
is converted into Cipher text using keys
of 128 192 or 256 bits it is implemented
in software and Hardware throughout the
world to encrypt sensitive data the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as n started
development on AES in 1997 when it was
announced the need for an alternative to
the data encryption standard the new
internet needed a replacement for Dees
because of its small key size with
increasing computing power it was
considered unsafe against entire key
search attacks the triple Ds was
designed to overcome this problem
however it was deemed to be too slow to
be deployed in machines
worldwide strong cases were present by
the Mars rc6 Serpent and the two fish
algorithms but it was the rindal
encryption algorithm also known as AES
which was eventually chosen as the
standard symmetric key encryption
algorithm to be used
its section was formalized with the
release of federal information
processing standards publication 197 in
the November of 2001 it was approved by
the US Secretary of
Commerce now that we understand the
origin of AES let us have a look at the
features that make AES encryption
algorithm
unique the AES algorithm us as a
substitution permutation or SP Network
it consists of multiple rounds to
produce a cipher test text it has a
series of linked operations including
replacing inputs with specific outputs
that is substitutions and others that
involve bit shuffling which is
permutations at the beginning of the
encryption process we only start out
with a single key which can be either A8
bit key a 192bit key or a 256bit key
eventually this one key is expanded to
be used in multiple rounds throughout
the encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly AES performs all its
calculations on by data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the dees
algorithm therefore AES treats 128 bits
of a clear text block as 16
bytes the number of rounds during the
encryption process depends on the key
size that is being used the 128bit key
size fixes 10 Rounds the 192bit key size
fixes 12 rounds and the 256bit key holds
14 rounds a round key is required for
each of these rounds but since only one
key is input put into the algorithm the
single key needs to be expanded to get
the key for each round including the
round
zero with so many mathematical
calculations going on in the background
there are bound to be a lot of steps
throughout the procedure let's have a
look at the steps followed in
AES before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of AES
encryption everything in the process is
stored in a 4 into 4 Matrix
format this Matrix is also known as a
state array and we'll be using these
State arrays to transmit data from one
step to another and from one round to
the next
round each round takes straight array as
input and gives a straight array as
output to be transferred into the next
round it is a 16 byte Matrix with each
cell representing one byte with each
four byes representing a word so every
state array will have a total of four
four words representing
it as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in let's say the number of rounds
are n then the key has to be expanded to
be used with n+1 rounds because the
first round is the key zero
round let's say n is the number of
rounds the key is expanded to n + 1
rounds it is also a state array having
four words in its vicinity every key is
used for a single round and the first
key is used as a round key before any
round
begins in the very beginning the plane
text is captured and passed through an
exor function with the round key as a
supplement this key can be considered
the first key from the n+1 expanded set
moving on the state array resulting from
the above step is passed on to a bite
substitution ution
process beyond that there is a provision
to shift rows in the state arrays later
on the state array is mixed with a
constant Matrix to shuffle its column in
the mixed column segment after which we
add the round key for that particular
round the last four steps mentioned are
part of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through the
state arrays are then passed from one
round to the next as an input in the
last round however we skipped the mixed
columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining
unchanged but what are these bite
substitution and row shifting processes
let's find out regarding each step in
more
detail in the first step the plain text
is stored in a state array and is exor
with the k0 which is the first key in
the expanded key set this step is
performed only once on a block while
being repeated at the end of each round
as per iteration
demands the state array is exor with the
key to get a new state array which is
then passed office input to the subbytes
process in the second stage we have byte
substitution we leverage an Xbox called
as a substitution box to randomly switch
data among each element every single
bite is converted into a hexadecimal
value having two parts the first part
denotes the row value and the second
part denotes the column value the entire
State array is passed through the sbox
to create a brand new state array which
is then passed off as an input to the
row shifting process the 16 input bytes
are replaced by looking at a fixed table
given in the design we finally get a
matrix with four rows and four
columns when it comes to row shifting
each bit in the four rows of the Matrix
is shifted to the left an entry that is
a fall off is reinserted to the right of
the line the ch change is done as
follows the first line is not moved in
any way the second line is shifted to a
single position to the left the third
line is shifted two positions to the
left and the fourth line is shifted
three positions to the left the result
is a new Matrix that contains the same
16 bytes but has been moved in relation
to each other to boost the complexity of
the
program in mixed columns each column of
four bytes is now replaced using a
special mathematic function the function
takes four bytes of a column as input
and outputs four completely new
bytes we will get a new Matrix with the
same size of 16 bytes and it should be
noted that this phase has not been done
in the last round of the
iteration when it comes to adding a
round key the 16 bytes of the Matrix are
treated as 128 bits and the 128 bits of
the round key are exort if it is the
last last round the output is the cipher
text if you still have a few rounds
remaining the resulting 128 bits are
interpreted as 16 bytes and we start
another similar
round let's take an example to
understand how all these processes work
if our plain text is the string
2192 we first convert it into a heximal
format as follows we use an encryption
key which is that's my K Fu and it is
converted into to a hexadecimal format
as
well as per the guidelines we use a
single key which is then later expanded
into n +1 number of keys in which case
it's supposed to be 11 keys for 10
different
rounds in round zero we add the round
key the plane test is exort with the k0
and we get a state array that is passed
off as an input to the substitution by
its
process when it comes to the
substitution bytes process we leverage
an SBX to substitute the elements of
each bite with a completely new bite
this way the state array that we receive
is passed off as an input to the row
shifting process on the next
step when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first row being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three
the state array that we received from
the row shifting is passed off as an
input to mix columns in mix columns we
multiply the straight array with a
constant Matrix after which I receive a
new Straight array to be passed on onto
the next
step we add the name State array as an
exor with the round key of the
particular iteration whatever state
array we receive here it becomes an
output put for this particular
round now since this is the first round
of the entire encryption process the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the new
Round We repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a cipher
text once the final State array can be
denoted in the hexad decimal format this
becomes our final Cipher text that we
can use for transferring information
from the sender and
receiver let's take a look at the
applications of AES in this
world AES finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients highly secure
mechanisms like WPA and WPA2 psk are
extensively used in securing Wi-Fi
endpoints with the help of Riles
algorithm it also helps in SSL TLS
encryption that is instrumental in
encrypting our internet browser sessions
AES Works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for
communication AES is also prevalent in
general file encryption of various
formats ranging from critical documents
to the media files having a large key
allows people to encrypt media and
decrypt data with maximum security
possible AES is also used for processor
Security in Hardware Appliances to
prevent machine hijacking among other
things as a direct successor to the dees
algorithm there are some aspects that
AES provides an immediate advantage in
let us take a
look when it comes to key length the
biggest flaw in DS algorithm was that
small length was easily vulnerable by
today's standards eses has managed to
NAB up 128 192 and 256bit key lens to
bolster the security further the block
size is also larger in AES owing to more
complexity of the algorithm the number
of rounds in Dees is fixed irrespective
of the plane text being used in AES the
number of round depends on the key
length that is being used for the
particular iteration thereby providing
more Randomness and complexity in the
algorithm
the dees algorithm is considered to be
simpler than AES even though AES beats
Dees when it comes to relative speed of
encryption and decryption this makes
Advanced encryption standard much more
streamlined to be deployed in Frameworks
and systems worldwide when it compares
to the data encryption standard hello in
our last video on cryptography we took a
look at symmetry key cryptography we
used a single private key for both the
encryption and decryption of data and it
works very well in theory let's take a
look at a more realistic scenario now
let's meet Joe Joe is a journalist who
needs to communicate with Ryan via
longdistance messaging due to the
critical nature of the information
people are waiting for any message to
leave Joe's house so that they can
intercept it now Joe can easily use
symmetric cryptography to send the
encrypted data so that even if someone
intercepts the message they cannot
understand what it says but here's the
tricky part how will Joe send the
required decryption key to Ryan the
sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise Ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decod all the
information easily key sharing is a risk
that will always exist when symmetric
key cryptography is being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem this is B
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on asymmetry key cryptography
let's take a look at what we are going
to learn today We Begin by explaining
what asymmetry key cryptography is and
how it works we take a look at its
application and uses we understand why
it's called publicly cryptography and
then learn a little bit about RS
encryption and then we learn about the
advantages of asymmetric key
cryptography over symmetric key
cryptography let's understand what
asymmetry key cryptography
is asymmetry encryption uses a double
layer of protection there are two
different keys at play here a private
key and a public key a public key is
used to encrypt the information
pre-transit and a private key is used to
decrypt the data post Transit these pair
of keys must belong to the receiver of
the message the public keys can be
shared via messaging blog posts or key
servers and there are no restrictions
as you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the cipher text the cipher text
is then transmitted to the receiver
without any other key on getting the
cipher text the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt it and get the
plane text back there has been no
requirement of any key exchange
throughout this process therefore
solving the most glaring flaw faced in
symmetry key
cryptography the public key known to
everyone cannot be used to decp the
message and the private key which can
decp the message need not be shared with
anyone the sender and receiver can
exchange personal data using the same
set of keys as often as
possible to understand this better take
the analogy of your
mailbox anyone who wants to send you a
letter has access to the box and can
easily share information with you in a
way you can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it this
is how the private key comes to play no
one can intercept the message and read
its contents since it's encrypted once
the receiver gets its contents he can
use his private key to decrypt the
information both the public key and the
private key are generated so they are
interl and you cannot substitute other
private keys to decrypt the data in
another example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob let's say tre's call me
today she must use Bob's public key
while encrypting the message upon
receiving the cipher message Bob can
proceed to use his private key in order
to decp the message and hence complete
Securities attained during transmission
without any need for sharing the
key since this type of encryption is
highly secure it has many uses in areas
that require High
confidentiality it is used to manage
digital signatures so there is valid
proof of a documents authentic
authenticity with so many aspects of
business transitioning to the digital
sphere critical documents need to be
verified before being considered
authentic and acted upon thanks to
asymmetric cryptography senders can now
sign documents with their private Keys
anyone who needs to verify the
authenticity of such signatures can use
the sender's public key to decrypt the
signature since the public and the
private keys are linked to each other
mathematically it's impossible to repeat
this verification with with duplicate
Keys document encryption has been made
very simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
similar
approach in blockchain architecture
asymmetry key cryptography is used to
authorize transactions and maintain the
system thanks to its two key structures
changes are reflected across the
blockchain's peer-to-peer Network only
if it is approved from both ends along
with asymmetric key cryptography stamp
approve architecture its non-
repudiation characteristic also helps in
keeping the network
stable we can also use asymmetri key
cryptography combined with symmetri key
cryptography to monitor SSL or TLS
encrypted browsering sessions to make
sure nobody can steal up personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general it
plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption Keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure HTTP website
format security parameters differ on a
session by session basis so the
verification process is consistent and
utterly essential to Modern data
security another great use of the
asymmetri key cryptography structure is
transmitting keys for symmetri key
cryptography with the most significant
difficulty in symmetric encryption being
key exchange asymmetric keys can help
clear the shortcoming the original
message is first encrypted using a
symmetry key the key used for encrypting
the data is then converted into the
cipher text using the receiver public
key now we have two Cipher text to
transmit to the receiver on receiving
both of them the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt the Symmetry key
he can then use it to decrypt the
original information on getting the key
used to encrypt the data while this may
seem more complicated than just
asymmetric cryptography alone symmetric
encryption algorithms are much more
optimized for vast amounts of data on
some occas encrypting the key using
asymmetric algorithms will definitely be
more memory efficient and
secure you might remember us discussing
why symmetric encryption was called
private key cryptography let us
understand why asymmetric falls under
the public key
cryptography we have two keys at our
disposal the encryption key is available
to everyone the decryption key is
supposed to be
private unlike symmetri key cryptography
there is no need to share anything
privately to have an encrypted messaging
system to put that into perspective we
share our email address with anyone
looking to communicate with us it is
supposed to be public by Design so that
our email login credentials are private
and they help in preventing any data
mishandling since there is nothing
hidden from the world if they want to
send us any encrypted information this
category is called the public key
cryptography there are quite a few
algorithms being used today that follow
the architecture of asymmetri
cryptography none more famous than the
RS encryption RSA encryption is the most
widely used encryption or public
encryption standard using asymmetry ke
approach named after its Founders reest
Shamir and Adelman it uses block ciphers
to obscure the information if you are
unfamiliar with how block ciphers work
they are encryption algorithms that
divide the original data into blocks of
equal size the block size depends on the
exact Cipher being used once they are
broken down these blocks are encrypted
individually and later chained together
to form the final Cipher
text widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption orbit
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat
applications with so many variables in
play there must be some advantages that
give asymmetrically cryptography and
Edge over the traditional symmetric
encryption methodologies let's go
through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recpt any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance we have much more extensive
key lens in RSA encryption and other
asymmetric algorithms like 248 bit key
and 49 96-bit Keys larger keys are much
harder to break into via brute force and
are much more
secure asymmetric key cryptography can
use as a proof of authenticity since
only the rightful owner of the keys can
generate the messages to be decrypted by
the private key the situation can also
be reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the
owner it also has a tamper protection
feature where the message cannot be
intercepted and changed without
invalidating the private key used to
encrypt the data consequently the public
key cannot decp the message and it is
easy to realize the information is not
100% legitimate when and where the case
requires now that we have a proper
revision let's understand what digital
signatures are before moving onto the
algorithm the objective of digital
signatures is to authenticate and verify
documents and data this is necessary to
avoid tampering and digital modification
or forgery of any kind during the
transmission of official
documents they work on the public key
cryptography architecture with one
exception typically an asymmetric key
system encrypts using a public key and
decrypts with the private key for
digital signatures however the reverse
is
true the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key because the keys are in
together decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document therefore by
verifying the signatures Provence let's
go through each step to understand the
procedure
thoroughly in step one we have M which
is the original plain text message and
it is passed onto a hash function
denoted by H hash to create a
digest next it bundles the the message
together with the hash digest and
encrypts it using the sender's private
key it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender's public
key once the message is decrypted it is
passed to the same hash function H has
to generate a similar
digest it compares the newly generated
hash with the bundled hash value
received along with the message if they
match it verifies data
Integrity in many instances they provide
a layer of validation and security to
messages through non-secure
Channel properly implemented a digital
signature gives the receiver reason to
believe that the message was sent by the
claimed sender digital signatures are
equivalent to traditional handwritten
signatures in many respects but properly
implemented digital signatures are more
difficult to forge than the handwritten
type digital signature schemes in the
sense used here are cryptographically
based and must be implemented properly
to be effective they can also provide
non-repudiation meaning that the signer
cannot successfully claim that they did
not sign a message while also claiming
their private key remains secret further
some non-repudiation schemes offer a Tim
stamp for the digital signature so that
even if the private key is exposed the
signature is
valid to implement the concept of
digital signature in real world we have
two primary algorithms to follow the RSA
algorithm and the DSA algorithm but the
latter is a topic of learning today so
let's go ahead and see what the digital
signature algorithm is supposed to
do digital signature algorithm is a fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signatures it was proposed in 1991 and
globally standardized in 1994 by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as as the nist it
functions on the framework of modular
exponation and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute
system unlike DSA most signature types
are generated by signing message digest
with the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data since just the message digest is
signed the signature is generally much
smaller compared to the data that was
signed as a result digital signatures
impose Less loow on processors at the
time of signing execution and they use
small volumes of bandwidth DSA on the
other hand does not encrypt message
digest using private key or decrypt
message digest using public key instead
it uses mathematical functions to create
a digital signature consisting of two
160 bit numbers which are originated
from the message digests and the private
key DCS make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with RSA DSA
also provides three benefits which is
the message authentication Integrity
verification and non-
repudiation in the image we can see the
entire process of DSF validation a PL
text message is passed onto a hash
function where the digest is generated
which is passed onto a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g a
random variable k and the private key of
the
sender the outputs are then bundled onto
a single pack with a plain text and sent
to the receiver the two outputs we
receive from the signing functions are
the two 160 bit numbers denoted by S and
R on the receiver end we pass the plane
text to the same hash function to
regenerate the message
digest it is passed onto verification
function which has other requirements
such as the public of the sender glob
Global variable G and SNR received from
the
sender the value generated by the
function is then compared to R if they
match then the verification process is
complete and data Integrity is verified
this was an overview of the way the DSA
algorithm works you already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next
section we have three phases here the
first of which is key generation to
generate the keys we need some
prerequisites we select a q which
becomes a prime divisor we select a
prime number P such that P minus 1 mod Q
equal to 0 we also select a random
integer G which must satisfy the two
formulas being mentioned on the screen
right now once these values are selected
we can go ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by X and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of zero and the
value of Q the public key can be
calculated as y = to G ^ x mod P where y
stands for the public key the private
key can then be packaged as a bundle
which comprises of values of p q G and X
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p q G and Y
once we're done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this
generation repeat once the keys are
generated we can start generating the
signature the message is passed through
a hash function to generate the digest
Edge first we can choose any random
integer K which falls under the bracket
of 0 and Q to calculate the first 160
bit number of ass signing function of r
we use the formula G to the power K mod
P into mod Q similarly to calculate the
value of the second output that is s we
use the following formula that is shown
on the
screen the signature can then be
packaged as a bundle having R and
S this bundle along with the plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver now with the third phase we
have to verify the signature we first
calculate the message digest received in
the bule by passing it to the same hash
function we calculate the value of w U1
and U2 using the formulas shown on the
screen we have to calculate a
verification component which is then to
be compared with the value of R being
sent by the sender this verification
component can be calculated using the
following formula once calculated this
can be compared with the value of R if
the values match then the signature
verification is successful and and our
entire process is complete starting from
Key generation to the signature
Generation all the way up to the
verification of the
signature with so many steps to follow
we are bound to have a few advantages to
boot this and we would be right to think
so DSA is highly robust in the security
and stability aspect when compared to
Alternative signature verification
algorithms we have a few other ciphers
that aim to achieve the simplicity and
the flexibility of DSA but it has been a
tough ask for all the other
suits the key generation is much faster
when compared to the RSA algorithm and
such while the actual encryption and
decryption process May falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of
Frameworks DSA requires Less storage
space to work its entire cycle in
contrast its direct correspondent that
is RSA algorithm needs a certain amount
of computational and storage space to
function efficiently this is not the
case with DSA which has been optimized
to work with weaker hardware and lesser
resources the DSA is patented but nist
has made this pattern available
worldwide royalty-free a draft version
of the speculation fips 1865 indicates
that DSA will no longer be approved for
digital signature generation but it may
be used to verify signatures generated
prior to the implementation date of that
standard the RSA algorithm is a publicly
signature algorithm developed by Ron
rivest ADI Shamir and Leonard Edelman
the paper was first published in
1977 and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough to withstand brute force and
streamlined enough to be fast post
deployment RSA can also encrypt and
decrypt general information to securely
exchange data along with handling
digital signature verification let us
understand how it achieve this we take
our plain text message M we pass it
through a hash function to generate the
digest H which is then encrypted using
the sender's private key this is
appended to the original plane text
message and sent over to the
receiver once the receiver receives the
bundle he can pass the Plaine text
message through the same hash function
to generate a digest and the cipher text
can be scripted using the public key of
the sender the remaining hashes are
compared if the values match then the
data Integrity is verified and the
sender is authenticated apart from
digital signatures the main case of RSA
is encryption and decryption of private
information before being transmitted
across communication challenge this is
where the data encryption comes into
play when using RSA for encryption and
decryption of General data it reverses
the key set usage unlike signature
verification it receives the receiver's
public key to encrypt the data and uses
the receiver's private key in decrypting
the data thus there is no need to
exchange any keys in this scenario there
are two broad components when it comes
to RSA cryptography one of them is key
generation key generation employs a step
of generating the private and the public
keys that are going to be used for
encrypting and decrypting the data the
second part is the encryption and
decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the cipher text you will
Now understand each of these steps in
our next
subtopic keeping the previous two
concepts in mind let us go ahead and see
how the entire process works starting
from creating the keeper to encrypting
and decrypting the
information you need to generate the
public and private Keys before running
the functions to generate Cipher text
and plain text to use certain variables
and parameters all of which are
explained before first use two large
prime numbers which can be denoted by P
and Q we can compute the value of n as
Nal to P into q and compute the value of
Z as P minus1 into Q - 1 a number e is
chosen at random satisfying the
following conditions and a number D is
also selected at random following the
formula Ed mod Z equal to 1 and it can
be calculated with the formula given
below the public ke is then packaged as
a bundle with n and E and the private
key is packaged as a bundle using n and
D this sums of the key generation
process for the encryption and
decryption function we use the formulas
C and M the cipher Tex can be calculated
as c = m ^ e mod n and the plain text
can be calculated from the cipher text
as c^ D mod n when it comes to a data
encryption example let's take p and Q as
7 and 13
the value of n can be calculated as
91 if we select the value of e to be
five it satisfy all the criteria that we
needed to the value of D can be
calculated using the following function
which gives it as 29 the public key can
then be packaged as 91a 5 and the
private key can then be packaged as 91a
29 the plain text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m Cipher text can be
calculated to the formula C equal to m
the^ e mod n which gives us 82 if
somebody receives this Cipher text they
can calculate the plain text using the
formula c the^ d mod n which gives us
the value of 10 as selected as our plain
text we can now look at the factors that
make the RSA algorithm Stand Out versus
its competitors in the advantageous
topics of this
lesson RSA encryption depends on using
the receiver's public key so that you
don't have to share any secret key to
receive the messages from others this
was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography
structure since the key pairs are
related to each other a receiver cannot
intercept the message since they didn't
have the correct private keys to deip
the information if a public key can decp
the information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with this private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private
anymore the encryption process is faster
than that of the DSA algorithm even if
the key generation is slower in RSA many
systems across the world tend to reuse
the same keys so that they can spend
less time in key generation and more
time on actual Cipher text
management data will be tamper proof in
transit since meddling with the data
will alter the usage of the keys the
private key won't be able to decp the
information hence alerting the receiver
of any kind of manipulation in between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
Transit the cases of which are rather
low imagine creating an account on a new
website you provide your email address
and set a password that you are
confident and you would not forget what
about the website owner how securely are
they going to store your
password for website administrators they
have three Alternatives they can either
store the passwords in a plain text
format they can encrypt the passwords
using an encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value let's have a look at each of
these when a password is stored in
cleant text format it is considered to
be the most unsafe option since anyone
in the company can read your passwords a
single hack and a data server breach
will expose all the accounts credentials
without needing any extra
effort to counter this owners can
encrypt the passwords and keep them in
the servers as a second alternative but
that would mean they also have to store
the decryption key somewhere on their
servers in the event of a data breach or
the server hack both the decryption key
and encrypted passwords will be leaked
thus making it a single point of
failure what if there was an option to
store the passwords after scrambling
them completely but with no way to
decrypt them this is where hashing comes
to play since only the hashed values are
stored in the server no encryption is
needed with no C inex passwords to
protect your credentials are safe from
the website administrators considering
all the pros hashed passwords are the
industry standard when it comes to
storing credentials
nowadays before getting too deep into
the topic let's get a brief overview of
how hashing
Works hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of information or
data beyond recognition we can achieve
this by using hash functions which are
essentially algorithms that perform
mathematical operations on the main PL
text the value generated after passing
the plane text information through the
hash function is called the hash value
digest or in general just the hash of
the original data while this may sound
similar to encryption the major
difference is hashes are meant to be
irreversible no decryption key can
convert a digest back to its original
value however a few hashing algorithms
have been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity of today's new
generation computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in use among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification
Etc like we discussed earlier websites
use hashing to store the users passwords
so how do they make use of these hash
passwords when a user signs up to create
a new account the password is then run
through the hash function and the
resulting hash value is stored on the
servers so the next time a user comes to
log to the account the password he
enters is passed to the same hash
function and compared to the hash stored
on the main server if the newly
calculated hash is the same as the one
stored on the website server the
password must have been correct because
according to Hash functions terminology
same inputs will always provide the same
outputs if the hashes do not match then
the password entered during login is not
the same as the password entered during
the signup hence the login will be
denied this way no plain text passwords
get stored preventing both the owner
from snooping on user data and
protecting users privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack apart from password storage hashing
can also be used to perform Integrity
checks when a file is uploaded on the
internet the file's hash value is
generated and it is uploaded along with
the original information when a new user
downloads the file he can calculate the
digest of the downloaded file using the
same hash function when the hash values
are compared if they match then file
Integrity has been maintained and there
has been no data
corruption since so much important
information is being passed on the hash
function we need to understand how they
work a hash function is a set of
mathematical calculations operated on
two blocks of data the main input is
broken down into two blocks of similar
size the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being
used hash functions are designed to be
one way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by Design some algorithms like the
previously mentioned md5 have been
compromised but most secure algorithms
are being used today like the sh F of
algorithms the digest size is also
dependent on the respective algorithm
being used md5 has a digest of 128 bits
while s 256 has a digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not
reversible there are certain
requirements of a hash function that
need to be met before they are accepted
while some of them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
Security in the long run
the hash function must be quick enough
to encrypt large amounts of data at a
relatively Fast Pace but it also
shouldn't be very fast running the
algorithm on all cylinders makes the
functions easy to boot force and a
security liability there must be a
balance to allow the hash function to
handle large amounts of data and not
make it ridiculously easy to Brute Force
by running through all the possible
combinations the hash function must be
dependent on each bit of the input the
input can be text audio video or any
other file extension if a single
character is being changed it doesn't
matter how small that character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value this is essential
to create unique digest for every
password that is being store but what if
two different users are using the same
password since the hash function is the
same for all users both the digests will
be the same this is called a hash
Collision you may think this must be a
rare occasion where two users have
exactly the same password but that is
not the case we have techniques like
salting that can be used to reduce these
hash collisions as we will discuss later
in this
video you would be shocked to see the
most used passwords of 2020 all of these
passwords are laughably insecure and
since many people use the same passwords
repeatedly on different websites hash
collisions risk are more common than
than one would
expect let's say the hash functions find
two users having the same password how
can they store both the hashes without
messing up the original data this is
where salting and peppering come to
play salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function this random keyword is unique
for each user on the system and it is
called the salt value or just the salt
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the salt value will differ and so
will the digest there is a small problem
with this process though since the salt
is unique for each user they need to be
stored in the database along with the
passwords and sometimes even in plain
text to speed up the process of
continuous verification if the server is
hacked then the hashes will need to be
brute forced which takes a lot of time
but if they receive the salts as well
the entire process becomes very fast
this is something that peppering aims to
solve
peppering is the process of adding a
random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case the pepper isn't
stored on the servers it is mostly
hardcoded onto the website source code
since it's going to be the same for all
credentials this way even if the servers
get hacked they will not have the right
pepper needed to crack into all the
passwords many websites use a
combination of salting and peppering to
solve the problem of hash collision and
bolster security since Brute Force takes
such a long time many hackers avoid
taking the effort the returns are mostly
not worth it and the possible
combinations of using both salting and
peppering is
humongous with the consensus aiming
towards an educated public on digital
privacy it's no surprise to see an
increasing interest in encryption
algorithms we have already covered the
major names like the dees and the AES
algorithm md5 algorithm was one of the
first hashing algorithms to take the
global stage as a successor to the md4
despite the security vulnerabilities
encountered in the future md5 Still
Remains a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments the md5 hashing Al
algorithm is a one-way cryptographic
functions that accepts a message of any
length as input and it returns as output
a fixed length digest value to be used
for authenticating the original messages
the digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input the md5 hash
function was originally designed for use
as a secure cryptographic hash algorithm
to authenticate digital signatures md5
has also been depreciated for users
other than as a non-cryptographic check
sum to verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data
corruption Ronald dest founder of RSA
data security and Institute professor at
MIT designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the
md4 as already iterated before the
process is straightforward we pass up PL
text message to the md5 hash functions
which in turn perform certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 120 bit
digest receive from this is going to be
radically different from the pl text the
goal of any message digest function is
to produce digest that appear to be
random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
functions should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value even a slight change in
the plane text should trigger a drastic
difference in the two digest this goes a
long way in preventing hash collisions
which take place when two different PL
Texs have the same
digest to achieve this level of
intricacy there are number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compar able with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when we receive the
input string we have to make sure the
size is 64 bits short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters this
prepares a string to have a length of
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512 here and out we can proceed onto the
next Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bits short of any
multiple of 512 now we add the length
bits in such a way that the total number
of bits in the message is perfectly a
multiple of
512 that means 64 bit lens to be precise
are added to the message our final
string to be hashed is now a definite
multiple of 512
The Next Step would be to initialize the
message digest buffer the entire hashing
plane text is now broken down into
512-bit
blocks there are four buffers or
registers that are of 32 bits each named
a b c and
d these are the four words that are
going to store the values of each of
these
subblocks the first iteration to follow
these registers will have fixed
hexadecimal values as shown on the
screen
below once these values are
initial of these 512 blocks we can
divide each of them into 16 further
subblocks of 32 bits each for each of
these subblocks we draun four rounds of
operations having the four buffer
variables a b c and d these rounds
require the other constant variables as
well which defer with each round of
operation the constant values are stored
in a random array of 64 elements since
each 32-bit subblock is run four times
16 such subblocks equal 64 constant
values needed for a single block
iteration the subblocks can be denoted
by the alphabet M and the constant
values are denoted by the alphabet
T coming to the actual round of
operation we see our four buffers which
already have pre-initialized values for
the first iteration at the very
beginning the values of buffers b c and
D are passed on to a nonlinear
logarithmic function the formula behind
this function changes by the particular
round being worked on as we shall see
later in this video Once the output is
calculated it is added to the raw value
stored in buffer a the output of this
addition is added to the particular
32-bit subblock using which we are
running the four
operations the output of this requisite
function then needs to be added to a
constant value derived from the constant
AR k since we have 64 different elements
in the array repeat since we have 64
different elements in the array we can
use a distinct element for each
iteration of a particular block The Next
Step involves a circular shift that
increases the complexity of the hash
algorithm and is necessary to create a
unique digest for each individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer B the
final output is now stored in the second
buffer of B of the output register
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in C value of C
gets stored in D and the value of D in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this subblock the values of a b c d
are moved on as input to the next
subblock Once all 16 subblocks are
completed the final register value is
saved and the next 512-bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5
algorithm regarding the nonlinear
process mentioned in the first step the
formula changes for each round it's
being run on this is done to maintain
the computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure the formula for each of
the four rounds uses the same parameters
that is b c and d to generate a single
output output the formulas being used
are shown on the screen right
now algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digests they don't consume
a noticeable amount of disc storage and
are comparatively easier to remember and
reiterate passwords need not be stored
in plain text format making them
accessible for hackers and malicious
actors when using Digest the database
security also gets a boost since the
sizes of all the hash values will be the
same in the event of a hack or a breach
the malicious actor will only receive
the hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plane text which would be
the user passwords in this case since
the functions are irreversible by Design
hashing has become a compulsion when
storing user credentials on the server
nowadays a relatively low memory
footprint is necessary when it comes to
integrating multiple Services into the
same framework without a CPU overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string this helps in creating a low
requirement for computational power and
is much easier to run on older Hardware
which is pretty common in server farms
around the
world we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
ons it once the hash is match file
Integrity checks are valid and we can
avoid data
corruption hash functions will always
give the same output for the similar
input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the
message we use our Wi-Fi everyday for
work and we use the internet for
entertainment and communication the
dependent tendy on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades a big portion of this
belongs to ensuring secure channels of
communication and data
transmission the secure hash algorithm
are a family of cryptographic hash
functions that are published by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology along with the NSA it was
passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as FS it
has four different families of hash
functions ssj 0 is a 160 bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flaw sha1 is also a 160 bit
hash function which resembles the
earlier md5 algorithm this was designed
by the NSA to be a part of the digital
signature
algorithm S2 is a family of two similar
hash functions with different block
sizes known as the Sha 256 and the Sha
512 they differ in the word size sha 256
uses 32bit words while sha 512 uses
64bit words sh3 is a hash function
properly known as kak it was chosen in
2012 after a public competition among
non- NSA designers it supports the same
hash lens as H2 and its internal
structure differs significantly from the
rest of the S family
as we have already iterated the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the Sha hash function which
in turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data the 160 bit digest received
from this is going to be radically
different from the plain text the goal
of any hash function is to produce
digests that appear to be random to be
considered cryptographically secure the
hash function should meet two
requirements first that it is impossible
for an attacker to generate a message
that matches a specific hash value and
second it should be impossible for an
attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plane text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which takes
place when two different plane text have
the same
digest the S family functions have some
characteristics that they need to follow
while generating the Dig yes let's go
through a few of
them the length of the clear text should
be less than 2^ 64 bits in the case of
sha1 and
s256 this is essential to keep the plane
text compatible with the hash function
and the size needs to be in comparison
area to keep the digest as random as
possible the length of the hash digest
should be 256 bits in the sh 256
algorithm 512 bits in the Sha 512
algorithm and so on bigger digest
usually suggests significantly more
calculations at the cost of speed and
space we typically go for the longest
diges to bolster security but there must
be a definite balance between the speed
and security of a hash
function by Design all hash function of
the Sha 512 sh 256 are
irreversible you should neither get a
plain text when you have the digest
beforehand nor should the digest provide
the original value when you pass it
through the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the Sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance this is done to reduce
the chance of Brute Force
attacks to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the Sha algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when you receive the
input string you have to make sure the
size is 64bit short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the mids
you must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
characters
this prepares our string to have a
length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of
512 here on out we can proceed to The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message was 64 bits short from becoming
a multiple of
512 now we add the length of bits in
such a way that the total number of bits
in the message is a perfect multiple of
512 that means 64 bits plus the length
of the original message becomes a
multiple of 512 this becomes a final
string that needs to be
hashed in the next step we have to
initialize this chaining
variables the entire plain text message
can now be broken down into blocks of
512 bits each unlike other hash
algorithms like md5 which use four
registers or buffers sha family use five
buffers of 3 two bits each they are
named a b c d and e these registers go
through multiple rounds of operation
where the first iteration has fixed H
aimal values as can be seen in the
screen moving on we have to process each
of the 52 bit blocks by breaking each of
them into 16 subblocks of 32 bits each
each of them goes through four rounds of
operation that use the entire register
and have the 512-bit block along with
the constant array out of those four
rounds each round has 20 iterations so
in general we have 80 rounds some
total the constant value of K is an
array of 80
elements of those 80 16 elements are
being used each round so that comes out
to 80 rounds for each of those
elements the value of T differs by the
number of rounds as can be seen in the
table
below a single formula is necessary to
to calculate the output of each round
and iteration the formula can be AB CDE
e registor is equal to e plus a
nonlinear process P along with a
circular shift of a + WT + KT in this
formula ABCD is the register value of
the chaining variables as we discussed
before p is The Logical process which
has a different formula for each round
S5 is a circular shift by five bits and
T is a 32bit string derived from the
existing subblock this can be calculated
depending on the iteration at hand KT
signifies a single element of the 80
character element array which changes
depending on the particular round at
hand for the values of WT the first 16
values are the same as that of the
subblocks so there is no extra
calculation needed for the next 64
elements the value of WT can be
calculated as shown in the formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the
output next we use a nonlinear process P
that changes depending on the round and
uses the values of b c and d as
input whatever output is generated from
the nonlinear process it is added with
the value of the E
register next the value of a is circular
shifted by 5 bits and is added with the
output generated in the previous
step the next step is adding the value
of WT and the constant element of KT the
current output is then stored in the
registor a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
subblock in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the
subblocks are joined together to form
the single Cipher text message we will
have our hash output regarding the
nonlinear process P that uses the values
of b c and d as input the formula
changes every round to maintain a
complexity of the program that can
withstand Brute Force attacks depending
on the round the values are passed
through a logical operation which is
then added with the values of WT KT and
so on now that we understand how to get
our hash Digest from the plain text let
us learn about the advantages we obtain
when using the Sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text
format digital signatures follow
asymmetric encryption methodology to
verify the authenticity of a document or
a file hash algorithms like sh 256 and
the industry standard s 512 go a long
way in ensuring the verification of
signatures passwords need not be stored
in a plain text format which makes them
accessible to hackers and other
malicious actors when using digest the
database security also gets a boost
since the size of all hash values will
be the same in the event of a hack or a
breach the malicious actor will only
receive the hash values with no way to
regenerate the plane text in this case
the plane text would be user credentials
since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers the SSL handshake is a crucial
segment of the web browsing sessions and
it's done using sha functions it
consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection it relies on a
combination of symmetric and asymmetric
algorithms which ensure the
confidentiality of the data transmitted
between a web server and a web client
like the
browsers you can monitor to file
corruption by comparing hash values
before and after Transit once the hash
is match file Integrity checks are valid
and data corruption is avoided hash
functions will always give the same
output for the same input irrespective
of the iteration parameters it also
helps in ensuring that the data hasn't
been tampered with on route to the
receiver of the message passwords are by
far the most common type of user
authentication they are popular because
the theory makes perfect sense to
individuals and is reasonably simple to
implement for developers on the other
hand poorly constructed passwords can
pose security flaws a well-designed
password-based authentication process
does not save the user's actual password
this would make it far too simple for a
hacker or a malevolent Insider to access
all of the systems user accounts in this
video you will learn how to crack
passwords and simultaneously try to make
your passwords as Brute Force resistant
as possible let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today
we start by learning about what is
password cracking in
general next we take a look at the
different techniques of password
cracking that hackers use in order to
generate user credentials for
hacking moving on we take a look at the
multiple tools that hackers can use to
generate these hashes and the
passwords finally we take a look at the
steps and the guidelines that users can
follow to prevent their passwords from
being
cracked
let's start by giving a basic idea about
password
cracking password cracking is the
process of identifying an unknown
password to a computer or a network
resource using a program code it can
also assist a threat actor in gaining
illegal access to resources malicious
actors can engage in various criminal
activities with the information obtained
through password tracking the procedure
might entail comparing a set of words to
guess credentials or using an algorithm
to guess the password repeat L password
cracking can be done for several reasons
but the most malicious reason is in
order to gain unauthorized access to a
computer without the owner's awareness
this results in cyber crime such as
stealing passwords for the purpose of
accessing banking information other
non-malicious reasons for password
cracking occur when someone has
misplaced or forgotten a password
another example of nonm malicious
password cracking may take place if a
system administrator is conducting test
on password strength as a form of
security test this enables so that the
hacker ha ER cannot easily access
protected systems the best way that
users can protect their passwords from
cracking is to ensure that they choose
strong
passwords typically passwords must
contain a combination of mixed case
random letters digits and symbols strong
passwords should never be actual words
in addition strong passwords are at
least eight characters long in many
password protected applications users
are notified of the strength of the
password they've chosen upon entering it
the user can then modify it and
strengthen the password based on the
indications of its
strength now that we understand the
basics of password cracking let's go to
the basic techniques hackers use to
retrieve passwords from General
victims asking the customer for the
password is simple approach to hacking a
fishing email directs the unwary reader
to a counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset that page then
captures their password which the hacker
can subsequently exploit for their own
purpose social engineering influences
the victim to get personal information
such as bank account numbers or
passwords the strategy is popular among
hackers because they realize that humans
are the gateway to vital credentials and
information through social engineering
the employer tried and true tactics to
exploit and influence age-old human
Tendencies rather than devising novel
means to breach secure and Advanced
Technologies it has been demonstrated
that many firms either lack adequate
security or are overly friendly and
trustworthy when they should not be they
allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a so
story a hacker searches a password
dictionary for the correct password in
the case of a dictionary attack password
dictionaries cover many themes and of
mixture of topics such as politics
movies and music groups users failure to
create a strong password is why this
approach efficiently cracks passwords
till today simply said this assault
employs the same terms that many
individuals use as passwords a hacker
can compare the password hash obtained
to hashes of the password dictionaries
to find the correct plain text
password now that the passwords have
been hashed the hackers attempt to
achieve authentication by breaking the
password hash they accomplish this by
employing a rainbow table which is a set
of pre-computed hashes of portable
password
combinations hackers can use the rainbow
table to crack the hash resulting in
guessing your password as a result it
retrieves the password hash from the
system and eliminates any need to break
it furthermore it does not necessitate
the discovery of the password itself the
breach is accomplished if the hash
matches in a Brute Force assault the
attacker attempts multiple password
combinations until the correct one is
identified the attacker uses software to
automate this process and Run Exhaust
cost of password combination in a
substantially shorter length of time
with the growth of hardware and
technology in recent years such programs
have been invigorated it won't be quick
if your password is more than a few
characters lengthy but it will
eventually reveal your password boot
Force assaults can be sped up by
throwing more processing resources at
them with so many different techniques
coming together to correct passwords
none of them are useful without the
right tools there are a prra of scripts
and Snippets of code that can Reet
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash digest let's go through
some of these
tools cane anable is a password recovery
tool for Microsoft operating systems it
allows easy recovery of various kinds of
passwords by sniffing the network
cracking encrypted passwords using
dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks recording Vibe
conversations recording scrambled
passwords recovering wireless network
Keys Etc are some of the other features
of K enable the latest version is faster
and contains a lot of new features like
ARP poison routing which enables
sniffing on switch L and man in the-
Middle attacks the sniffer in this
version can also analyze encrypted
protocols such as ssh1 and https while
containing filters to capture
credentials from a wide range of
authentication
mechanisms it also ships routing
protocol authentication monitors and
Route
extractors dictionary and boot Force
crackers are also present along with
common hashing algorithms and several
specific authentications password hash
calculators and other
features John the Ripper is a password
cracking application that was first
released in 1996 for Unix based
computers it was created to evaluate
password strength brot Force encrypted
hash passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attacks it can use dictionary
attacks rainbow tables and other attacks
depending on the target
type Rainbow Crack is a password
cracking application that uses time
memory trade-off algorithm to crack
password hashes with rainbow tables
rainbow tables make password cracking
more easier and faster than traditional
Brute Force attacks it is like a
dictionary containing nearly every
possible password and the pre-calculated
hashes creating this kind of dictionary
takes much more time than cracking a
single hash but after that you can use
the same dictionary over and over again
this procedure might take a long time
however once the table is ready it can
break passwords far quicker than Brute
Force
methods with so many tools ready to NAA
passwords there are certain set of rules
users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised let's
cover some of these
guidelines longer passwords are required
making the Brute Force mechanism tougher
to implement longer passwords and
passphrases have been demonstrated to
boost security significantly however it
is still critical to avoid lenier
passwords that have previously been
hacked or that feature often in cracking
dictionaries this password policy
encourages users to establish passwords
that do not contain personal
information as previously said most
users create passwords utilizing
personal information such as Hobbies
nicknames pet or family member names Etc
if a hacker has access to personal
information about a specific user for
example via social media they will test
password combinations B based on that
knowledge password regulations should
compel users to distinguish between
security and convenience users should be
prohibited from using the same password
for all services password sharing
between users including those who work
in the same department or use the same
equipment should be avoided a single
breached password doesn't affect your
other accounts with this
policy some password regulations
necessitate the creation of a pass
phrase rather than a pass word while
pass phrases serve the same objective
the length make them more difficult to
break in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass phrases however the
latter is much more breach
resistant two Factor authentication or
2fa can help secure an online account or
even a smartphone TFA does this by
asking the user to provide two forms of
information a password or a personal
identification pin and a code texted to
the user smartphone or a fingerprint
before accessing whatever is secured
this helps discourage unauthorized
entries to an account without the
original owner's permission at this
point you may wonder why you need a
strong password in the first place even
if most websites are safe there is still
a danger that someone will try to access
or exploit your information a strong
password is among the most effective
ways to protect your accounts and
personal information from hackers you
should follow certain rules and
guidelines while creating a strong
password password managers are also
recommended to help remember the created
passwords for convenience of
usage with that being said let's take a
look at the topics we are covering
today we start by learning about the
state of password cracking in today's
world and why creating strong passwords
is an absolute must for every account
next we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faes have grown in popularity and
are being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal
information let's start by learning
about why strong passwords have become
an absolute
necessity one of the most common ways
that hackers break into computers is by
guessing passwords
simple and commonly used passwords
enable Intruders to easily gain access
and control a Computing device
conversely a password that is difficult
to guess makes it prohibitively
difficult for common hackers to break
into a machine and will force them to
look for another Target the more
difficult the password the lower the
likelihood that one's computer will fall
victim to an unwanted intrusion many
individuals opt to tie their websites to
something they can readily recall to
generally easy memorable combos however
this does not make the password unique
in fact it's the reverse passwords are
handled by 53% of individuals using
their Recollections and memory with
modern computational standards simple
passwords take seconds and a couple of
minutes at worst to be completely brute
forced according to Global surveys more
than 60% of people use the same
passwords for their personal and job
applications while this may allow the
user never to forget the password it
makes a single point of failure the only
pin to drop if one one of the accounts
gets breached all subsequent accounts
are as good as hacked to further
elaborate on how you can create strong
passwords let's go through some of the
guidelines let's go through some dos and
Dons to understand how to create new
passwords for our accounts it is
recommended to keep the password length
at least 12 characters to ensure brute
forcing to be
difficult a combination of upper and
lowercase alphabets is an absolute
necessity when creating strong
passwords it is also recommended to use
numerics along with those alphabets to
create a complicated
password finally special characters help
in making a password much more Brute
Force resistant than any number of
alphabets or letters can make moving
over to the Don
section it's absolutely not recommended
to keep Simple dictionary terms such as
computer or even even the word password
as your credential because those are
very easy to be brute forced and are
usually present in majority of the
dictionary attack word list similarly
changing a single alphabet or a single
character in a dictionary word does not
make it Brute Force Zant considering
there are already algorithms present
that can counter this
tactic using the same character multiple
times in a password also reduces the
strength and makes it easier to crack
for hackers
apart from using single characters
multiple times following patterns that
are present on this traditional English
keyboard such as e w t y or the line
below the main alphabet such as the ZX
cvbn M Etc make it easier to guess since
these are once again common combinations
that are present in word list
already finally the most important part
being not using personal information
such as birthdays addresses and other
important information in the passwords
more often than not if a hacker is
trying to break into your account there
has been some amount of research done be
it via social media or any other medium
if they have already this information
present with them breaking into your
account becomes all the more
easier now that you understand how to
create strong password look at how past
freezes have become prevalent as a
replacement for plain text
passwords a passphrase is a
sentence-like string of words used for
authentication that is longer than a
traditional password easy to remember
and difficult to crack typical passwords
range on an average from 8 to 16
characters while pass phrases can reach
up to 100 characters or more using a
long fast phrase instead of a short
password to create a digital signature
is one of the many ways that users can
strengthen the security of their data
devices and accounts the longer a
passphrase is the more likely a user is
is to incorporate bits of entropy of
factors that make it less predictable to
potential attackers as more websites
applications and services increase the
user security requirements aost phas is
a fast and easy way to meet these
criterias let's take a look at some of
the advantages that pass faes have over
common
passwords pass phases are simpler to
remember than just a random assortment
of symbols and characters it's easier to
comprehend a line from your favorite
song or a quotation than a short but
difficult password passwords are
reasonably easy for humans and robots to
guess or crack online thieves have also
Advanced and created Cutting Edge
hacking tools to crack even the most
complex
passwords passphrases are nearly hard to
crack since most efficient password
cracking programs fail at approximately
10 characters as a result even the most
sophisticated cracking tool will be
unable to guess brute force or
pre-compute compute these passwords
complies with password setting rules
with ease are passphrases the usage of
punctuation and upper and lower case
password satisfy the password complexity
criteria most operating systems and apps
support pass
phrases phrases of up to 127 characters
are permitted on all major operating
systems including Windows Linux and Mac
as a result for optimal protection you
can use lengthier pass
phrases but when creating a strong
password the major problem people come
across is remembering these passwords or
the pass phrases this is where you can
find a use for a password
manager when you establish accounts or
change passwords password managers
generate new strong passwords and they
keep all of them in one place protected
by a single strong master password if
you maintain your master password the
manager will retain everything else
including your username and passphrases
and fill them in for you whenever you
sign on to a website or app on your
computer or phone there is no good
memory needed for this this implies that
everyone may use the most recent
suggestions for strong passwords such as
extended phrases symbols grammar and
capitalization password managers enable
consumers to write a single master
password and automatically F each
website with their own unique set of
credentials and not just passwords
credit card information may be stored
securely with several password managers
some others make multiactor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input which is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login
inputs among the global players and
password managers services like bit
Warden keas and Ashlan have been running
for years now and are very worthy
recommendations if you want to get
started with password management now
that we understand what is hacking let's
take a look at some points to know where
whether our system is already hacked or
not the first point regarding how to
check whether a system is hacked or not
can be cases where the system security
is Switched Off by unknown means and it
is not visible to the user this is one
of the most primary checkpoint to know
if our system is hacked or
not next point to check whether a system
is hacked or not would be frequent
antivirus software failures which are
due to the interference from hacking
attempts performed by a professional
hacker or a cyber
criminal then we also face problems
regarding systems reaction speed which
is affected due to the execution of
unknown applications in the background
of the
system which also affects the hardware
resources in the device
next we also face problems regarding
passwords which are no longer working or
are changed without the user's
Intervention which might indicate that
there was some unknown hacking activity
that took place in our
account let's take a look at some more
points regarding the
topic there are often cases when the
systems cursor move on its own and
perform tasks indicating that the system
is being used by someone else using an
illegal hacking method there are also
cases when we often see files and
folders being created in the storage
disk on the
system which is unknown to us to better
understand the points regarding how to
identify whether our system is hacked or
not let's take a look then let's start
with the first
point if we want to check whether our
system is hacked or not the first point
would be to choose the settings
option and using privacy and security
and moving on to the Windows security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are
available on the
system if we see any problem regarding
any one of them for example appson
browser control in my system it says
there's a problem with it which might be
due to hacking attempts that was done on
my
system now let's take a look at the
other option how we can check whether
our system is hacked or not that would
be checking the anti virus software that
is installed in our
system if you face problems regarding
that this might be the issue according
to my antivirus software it says my
computer is at risk this might be due to
the interference from cyber criminal or
a hacker while using different illegal
softwares during its hacking
attempt then there are also
cases where we see there are unknown
programs being executed in the
background of our system which we can
take a look using the task manager
software using the task manager we can
take a look at each and every
application that is being executed in
the system and see the
origin if we find any unknown program or
application we can assume that it might
be due to a hacking
attempt moving on if we want to check
further whether our system is hacked or
not we can check for files or folders
that are being created unknown to us for
example this unknown
folder which contains some security
details that are unknown to
me this might be also due to a hacking
attempt by a hacker or a cyber
criminal then there are also cases when
the system's cursor move on its own and
perform tasks that are not initiated by
us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is due to a hacking attempt that
was done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of a system
system then there are also cases
regarding login issues or password
problem for
example if I want to access into my
account and there's a problem with the
password it might be due
to the attempt of hacking into my
account by a professional
hacker
seems like there's a problem with the
username which means there was a hacking
attempt by a professional
hacker we can further check hacking
attempts by accessing our web browser
and checking whether there's some extra
add-ons or unknown add-ons that wasn't
installed by us this might also indicate
a hacking attempt on the system now that
we are clear about how to check whether
a system is haed or not let's take a
look at some of the counter measure
against hacking let's
begin the first point regarding how to
avoid hacking is do regular manual
Security checks and keep the system
security updated using certified
antivirus softwares is a basic counter
measure against hacking
attempts and if possible visit only
secure websites for surfing on the
Internet or use VPN or other internet
security applications to mask your
systems Network to avoid any hacking
attempts for the
device then we have avoid clicking on
random web popups and ads to avoid
Hackers from getting into a system and
accessing a device
data and lastly use strong passwords or
complex passwords for your login
details applying these counter measures
we can avoid hacking to a certain extent
the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and like-minded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time since then instant messaging has
revolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app the
present instant messaging experience is
seamless and it intuitively integrates
features like video photos voice
e-commerce and gaming with plain old
messaging among among these apps
WhatsApp has comfortably found its place
among the most popular messaging
platforms like everyone associated with
the internet a matro security is never
far away considering the huge user base
of this messaging app hackers are always
on the lookout for compromised accounts
to grab today we are going to cover some
of the ways we can protect our WhatsApp
account from falling into malicious
hands we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
WhatsApp and instant messaging apps in
general next we cover some of the most
important steps that should be followed
in order to protect our WhatsApp
accounts from
hackers finally we learn what we should
do when a WhatsApp account gets
compromised let's start by learning why
we need to focus on the safety of
WhatsApp in the year of 2020 the big
news was about Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos and
his phone being haed by Saudi Arabia a
report coming from the guardian
suggested that bezos's phone was hacked
via a video file sent on WhatsApp the
report said that bezos's mobile phone
was hacked by Saudi Arabian prince in
the year 2018 and gigabytes worth of
data was stolen from the device while
there are some issues being raised about
the report which states with the medium
to high confidence that Jeff piz's phone
was hacked it does raise a security fear
for regular users after all if the phone
of one of the world's most powerful men
can be hacked the same can happen to any
one of us as
well when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with our loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics the
information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft basic information like
preferred Banks occasional dining places
can go a long way in Social Engineering
attacks further increasing the need for
secure messaging
habits WhatsApp uses endtoend encryption
to protect all communication on its
platform these encryption keys not only
make it impossible to decrypt messages
but they also prevent third parties and
even WhatsApp from accessing messages or
calls but not entirely although NN
encryption makes WhatsApp more secure
than other communication apps no app is
100% safe to use like any application or
digital device WhatsApp is often
targeted by Bad actors it also has
access to your contacts and tracks where
and how long you use it putting your
privacy and personal information at
risk we all have access to our cell
phones so it's no surprise that sms2
factor authentication is one of the most
widespread types of MFA available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tied to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multiactor authentication method the
nature of SMS itself opens up your
organization to a host of risk hackers
may have many ways to leverage SMS to
find a way into your accounts and
network be it via spoofed SIM cards or
message hijacking WhatsApp to using SMS
isn't a foolproof
solution now that we understand the
variety of reasons why WhatsApp needs
extra security let's go through some of
the ways we can achieve
this it is more than probable that one
fine day you might receive a WhatsApp
message or even an SMS that reads that
your order is delayed please check its
data here or your account is locked and
please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3G and
movie tickets here some of them may
sound intimidating and some of them may
be lucrative but they all have one
purpose to trick you into clicking that
link and once you do that it's already
over it will install malware on your
phone and you won't have a clue about it
only when you start noticing that your
phone builds are abnormally high or your
bank account has been used without your
permission the realization will Dawn
upon you that something is wrong with
your phone but by then it may be too
late WhatsApp in itself provides various
privacy options to users the messaging
platform provides users with option to
choose who they want to share their
profile photo status and other details
with it's a good idea to change the
settings to contacts only this means
only phone numbers that are saved on
your smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
autod delete status as
well make sure you enable the option to
log the screen every time WhatsApp is
closed
this will ensure no one else but you can
open your WhatsApp account just head to
the settings menu privacy and select the
screen lock option you will then need to
register your fingerprint after the
process is completed you will have to
scan your fingerprint every time you
open the WhatsApp app this adds an extra
layer of
security the two-step verification works
as an extra layer of security and helps
WhatsApp users to protect their otps and
documents shared through WhatsApp it
it's very easy to set up a PIN to
activate a twostep verification users
have to enter it periodically once it is
activated WhatsApp will sometimes keep
asking users to enter this six-digit
passcode users cannot disable this
without disabling the two-step
verification feature
altogether in case users do not provide
WhatsApp with an email ID and want to
disable two-step verification then the
number will be permitted to reverifying
Whatsapp without the passcode after 7
Days however the users will lose all
pending messages upon very
fine we often have the tendency to log
into WhatsApp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
this habit can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
PC can access all your chats without you
even realizing it it's a good practice
to log out from WhatsApp web before
leaving the office it just takes a few
seconds to log in again by just scanning
the code and you're
done all WhatsApp users should ensure
that the chats are are end to-end
encryptor to verify that a chat is end
to endend encrypted open the chat tap on
the name of the contact to open the
contact info screen and then tap
encryption to view the QR code and a 60
digigit number WhatsApp endtoend
encryption ensures that only you and
your contact can read the messages that
are being exchanged and nobody in
between not even
WhatsApp with the necessary guidelines
out of the way let us go to the
recommended course of action should our
WhatsApp accounts be compromised
the first and most important thing that
you need to do is report the issue to
the WhatsApp support team for assistance
make sure that you reach out to the
support team through its help desk and
Report the hacking attempt WhatsApp help
center will take the shortest time to
resolve your issue via email or within
the app itself this will help you to
take prompt legal action against the
hackers if you can't access your email
call the support team in some cases the
support will deactivate your WhatsApp
account and request you to deactivate
within 30 days if you don't want it to
be deleted
completely when someone compromises your
WhatsApp account they can now send
messages to your contact stating that
the company sent your verification code
and gain access to the account that's
why one of the first things you'll want
to do is send a message to your friends
and family letting them know that you've
lost access to your account this action
prevents further exploitation of your
account and others another reason you'll
want to let your contacts know you have
no access to your account is that they
may fish for personal information from
your banking number to your email
address hackers will cleverly attempt to
gain as much access to your personal
information as
possible WhatsApp web is an extension of
WhatsApp messenger over the web that
facilitates easy synchronization of our
smartphone and personal computer this is
the biggest security threat that hackers
can easily exploit to get into your
personal data over WhatsApp therefore it
is highly recommended that you use this
WhatsApp feature carefully once you
notice that your what messenger has been
hacked go to your WhatsApp web and tap
or click on the log out from all
computers option this will deactivate
all the web extensions of your
account under the unfortunate
circumstances where the account recovery
doesn't seem likely you can always ask
WhatsApp support to delete your account
permanently while far from the ideal
solution it can act as a fail safe
option if you want to protect your
personal data at any cost possible you
can always open a new account ler
with the security issues mitigated and
before we begin if you're someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security or to become an ethical hacker
by graduating from the best universities
or a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts and
try giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of computing the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find find a complete
overview of the program being offered
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet usage is at the risk of being
hacked be it via unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration testing has
become the norm when it comes to
vulnerability assessment K Linux is an
operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution that is
made specifically for penetration
testers K Linux has layers of features
that we will be covering in today's
lesson let's take a look at the topics
to be covered in this
video we start by learning about K Linux
and a basic explanation of its purpose
we take a look at the history of K Linux
from the story of its origin to its
current day
exploits next we learn a few distinct
features of Kali that make it an
attractive choice for pention testers
worldwide finally we take a look at the
multiple ways we can install K Linux to
start a journey in the world of
penetration testing let's start by
learning about K Linux in
general Kali Linux which is formerly
known as backtrack Linux is an open
source Linux distribution aimed at
Advanced penetration testing and
security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools that are targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering
color Linux is a multiple platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop while the operating system is
capable of practically modifying every
single part of our installation the
networking components of Kali become
disabled by default this is done to
prevent any external factors from
affecting the installation procedure
which may pose a risk in critical
environments apart from boosting
security it allows a deeper element of
control to the most enthusiastic of
users we did not get K Linux since the
first day how did it come into existance
let's take a look at some of its
history K Linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems during all these project
lifelines there have been only a few
different developers as the team has
always been small the first project was
called wopex which stands for white hat
noex as can be inferred from the name it
was based on the npix operating system
as its underlying OS poix had releases
ranging from version 2.0 to
2.7 this made way for the next project
which was known as vax or the long hand
being white hat slacks the name change
was because the base OS was changed from
KNIX to slacks wax started at version 3
as a nod it carrying on from warix there
was a similar OS being produced at the
same time auditor security collection
often being shorted to just auditor
which was once again using
npix its efforts were combined with wax
to produce backrack backtrack was based
on slackware from version one to version
three but switched to uban to lat later
on with version 4 to version 5 using the
experience gained from all of this K
Linux came after backtrack in 2013 Ki
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when khi Linux became a
rolling operating
system now that we understand the
history and the purpose of K Linux let
us learn a little more about its
distinct
features the latest version of Khali
comes with more than than 600
penetration tools pre-installed after
reviewing every tool that was included
in backtrack developers have eliminated
a great number of tools that either
simply did not work or which duplicated
other tools that provided the same or
similar
functionality the K Linux team is made
up of a small group of individuals who
are the only ones trusted to commit
packages and interact with the
repositories all of which is done using
multiple secure protocols restricting
Act ESS of critical code bases to
external asset greatly reduces the risk
of source contamination which can cause
K Linux users worldwide a great deal of
damage as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Khali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since Arm based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more and more prevalent and
inexpensive the development team knew
that ki's armm support would need to be
as robust as they could manage with
fully working
installations K Linux is available on a
wide range of armm devices and has armm
repositories integrated with the
mainline distributions so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution all this information is
necessary for users to determine if K
Linux is the correct choice for them if
it is what are the ways that they can go
forward with this installation and start
their penetration testing
Journey the first way to use scal Linux
is by launching the distribution in the
live USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the K Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with the
capacity of at least 8 GB some people
don't need to save their data
permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the cavar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USPS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations but what if the user wants to
store data permanently in the installed
OS the best and the most reliable way to
ensure this is the full-fledged hard
disk installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of
Linux the next alternative route for
installing K Linux would be to use
Virtual ization software such as VMware
or virtual box the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and K Linux can
be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window the hardware
requirements will be completely
customizable starting with the allotted
Ram to the virtual hard disk
capacity the usage of both a host and
guest operating system like K Linux
allows users a safe environment to learn
while not putting the systems at risk if
you want to learn more about how one can
go forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where K Linux is being
installed on VMware while running on a
Windows 10 operating system you can find
the link in the description box to get
started with your very own virtual
machine the final way to install K Linux
is by using a dual boot system to put it
in simple words the K Linux OS will not
be overwriting any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and K Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system now for the convenience
of explanation we're going to install K
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware VMware is a
able to run multiple operating systems
on a single host machine which in our
case is a Windows 10
system to get started with K Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image
file we go to get Cali and as you can
see there are multiple platforms on
which this operating system can be
inverted as per our requirement we're
going to go with the virtual machine
section as you can see it is already
recommended by the
developers this is the download button
which will download a 64-bit ISO file we
can download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet after clicking on the
download button we can see we have a
window archive which will have the ISO
files for now we have downloaded the ISO
file and it is already present with me
so we can start working on the VMware
side of things once the ISO file is
downloaded we open up VMware
Workstation go to file and we create a
new virtual
machine in these two options it is
highly recommended to go with the
typical setup rather than the custom one
the custom is much more advanced and
requires much more information from the
user which is beneficial for developers
and people who are well versed with
virtualization software
but for 90% of the cases typical setup
will be
enough here we can select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later in some operating
systems we can use the ISO file here
directly and VMware will install it for
us but right now in the case of K Linux
the third option is always the
safest K Linux is a Linux distribution
so we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels every distribution has a a
parent distribution for example K Linux
has Debian and there are other
distributions which are based or forked
from some parent distribution kinu is
based of Debian so we can go with the
highest version of Debian which is the
Debian 10. X
64bit go on next we can write any such
name we can write K Linux so that it'll
be easier to recognize the virtual
machine among this list of virtual
machine instances the location can be
any location you decide to put by
default this should be the documents
folder but anywhere you put it will hold
up all the information of the operating
system all the files you download all
the configurations you store everything
will be stored in this particular
location that you
provide when we go next we are asked
about the disc capacity this dis
capacity will be all the storage that
will be provided to your virtual machine
of Linux think of your Windows device
you if you have a 1 TB of hard drive you
have the entirety of the hard disk to
store data on how much data you give
here you can only store up to that
amount of data not to mention some
amount of capacity will be taken up by
the operating system itself to store its
programs and applications for now we can
give around let's say 15 GB of
information or if it recommended size
for D is 20 you can just go ahead at 20
it depends all on the user case if
you're going to use it extensively you
can even go as high as 50ft or 60 GB if
you have plans to download many more
applications and perform multiple
different tests another option we get
over here is storing virtual disc as a
single file or storing them into
multiple
files as we already know this virtual
machine run entirely on VMware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over
here instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible for all scenarios
except it is much easier if the split
the virtual dis into multiple files now
even if this makes porting virtual
machines easier from either
system to system or software to software
let's say if you want to switch from
VMware to Virtual box or vice versa the
performance takes a small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual L as a single file
if you have no purposes of ever moving
the virtual machine even if you do it's
not a complete stop that it cannot be
ported it's just easier when using
multiple files but in order to get the
best performance out of the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over
here this is a summary of all the
changes that we made and all the
configurations that have been settled
until now now at this point of time we
have not provided the ISO file yet which
is the installation file for the K Linux
that we downloaded from this
website as of right now we have only
configured the settings of the virtual
machine so we can press on
finish and we have K Linux in the list
now
to make the changes further we press on
edit virtual machine
settings the memory is supposed to give
the ram of the virtual machine so
devices with ram of 8 GB or below that
giving high amount of ram will cause
performance issues and the host system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my Windows machine takes about 2 GB so I
have 6 GB of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6gb it will be
much more difficult for the host system
to run everything properly so for this
instance we can keep it as 2 GB of
memory for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as
well hard disk is preset up as the SCSI
hard disk and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at
all CD ID DVD this is where the
installation file comes you can think of
the ISO file that we downloaded as a pen
drive or a USB thumb drive which is
necessary to install an operating system
to provide this you're going to select
use ISO image file we're going to click
on
browse going and go to downloads and
select the IMO file over
here select
open and we can see it is already loaded
up next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use natat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or land segments but those are
not necessary for
installation rest of them are pretty
standard which do not need any extra
configuration and can be left as it
is press okay and now we can power on
this virtual
machine in this screen we can choose how
we want to proceed with the
installation we have a start installer
option over here so we're going to press
enter on
that
we're going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO
file um the first step in the
installation is choosing the language of
the operating system for this we can go
with English as
standard this is a location this will be
used for setting up the time and some of
the internal settings which depend
entirely on the location of the user so
for this we're going to go with
India configuring the keyboard it's
always recommended to go with the
American English first many people make
a mistake of going with the Indian
keyboard if it is possible and it
provides a lot of issues later on so
it's always preferred to go with the
American English and if later we see
some necessity of another keyboard
dialect that is NE required we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with American English as a
basic at this point it's going to load
the installation components from the ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect
Hardware once the hardware and the
network configuration is done by the ISO
file we want to write a host name for
the system this host name can be
anything which is used to recognize this
device on a local network or a land
cable let's say if we use the name
Kali domain name you we can skip it for
now it's not necessary as such for the
installation this is the full name for
the
user let's say we can provide the name
as simply learn as a full
name next we're going to set up a
username this username is going to be
necessary to identify the user from its
root accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one to
three now we have to choose a password
for the user now remember since this is
the first user that is being added onto
this newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator we can use whichever
password we like over
here and use the same password below and
press on
continue at this point it's going to
detect on the components on which the
operating system can be
installed like here there are multiple
options like the use entire disk use
entire dis and set up lvm this entire
disc can set up encrypted lvm for
newcomers it is recommended to just use
the first one since lvm encryption is
something that you can learn afterwards
when you're much more handson with the
Linux operating system for now we're
going to use the use entire disg guided
installation and press on
continue when we set up the virtual
machine on vmw we had set up a dis
capacity that we gave a prose 20gb that
is the hard disk which is being
discovered here even though it is a
virtual disk on vmy it acts as a normal
hard disk on which an operating system
can be installed so we select this one
and press on
continue here there is a multiple
partition system
all the operating systems that are
installed have different components one
is used for the a keeping of the
applications one for the files other for
the RAM management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one
partition and we're going to select that
and press on
continue this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1 GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine we can press on
finish partitioning and write changes to
disk and
continue it's just a confirmation page
as you can see it's WR that scsi3 is our
virtual hard disk of 20gb disk
capacity write the changes to the disk
we press yes and click on
continue at this point the installation
has started now this installation will
take a while depending on the amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a
while since this is going to take some
time to install as it is being run on a
virtual machine with only 2 GB of RAM
we're going to speed up this part of the
video so we don't have to waste any more
time just watching the progress
bar now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating systems is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple
devices it's an interface to install
external applications which are not
installed by default let's say for
Google Chrome or any other browser which
can be used to browse the
internet at this point of time is ask us
to select a network mirror we're going
to select as yes and move forward with
this next it's going to ask us for an
http proess which we can leave it as
blank and press it as continue
forward at this point of time it's
looking for updates to the Kali Linux
installation this will fetch the new
builds from the Kali server so the
installation is always updated to the
latest
version now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it ask install the graub boot
loader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press
continue remember the installation was
conducted on dev
SDA so we're going to select
installation of the ground loader on the
same hard disk that we have
configured we press this one and press
continue so now the graub boot loader is
being installed
the grub is highly essential because it
it shows the motherboard where to start
the operating system from even if the
operating system is installed correctly
and all the files are in correct order
the absence of a bootloader will not be
able to launch the OS
properly as you can see the installation
is finally complete so now we can press
on
continue and it's going to finalize the
changes
now you can see K Linux being booted up
straight away it doesn't check for the
ISO file anymore since the operating
system is now installed onto the virtual
hard disk storage that we had configured
before here we're going to enter our
username and password that we had set up
before
and we have the coloro system booted
up and this is your homepage we can see
the installed applications over here
which are being used for penetration
testing by multiple security analysts
worldwide all of these can pre-install
with K Linux and others can be installed
using the AP package manager that we had
configured you can see a full name over
here and with this our installation of
the K Linux is complete hey everyone
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet usage is at the risk of getting
hacked be it via unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration testing has
has become the norm when it comes to
vulnerability assessment par security OS
is an operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a l distribution more cater
towards penetration testers specifically
parent security has layers of features
that we will be covering in today's
lesson let's take a look at the topics
for this
video we start by learning about what
parent security is and why it should be
considered as a viable alternative next
to K Linux of penetration
testers next we take a look at the
minimum system requirements necessary to
obtain Optimum performance from an
installation of parot security moving on
we learn about some unique features that
make parot Stand Out Among the multiple
ethical hacking operating systems
available on the market and finally we
look at the multiple ways that par
security OS can be installed be on a
single system or for portable
media so let's start out by learning
what parat security
is parat is a Dean based Linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom Harden Linux kernel while
being founded in
2013 parro security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards various
information security task such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbies it features a distinct forens
six mode that does not Mount any of the
system hard diss or partitions and has
no influence on the host system making
it more stealthy than regular mode this
mode is used on the host system when
there is a need for executing forensic
procedures in software development a
rolling release is a paradigm which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions this ensures that the software
is constantly up to date rolling release
distribution such as parro security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market with a basic introduction to the
operating system out of the way let us
have a look at the bare minimum system
requirements necessary to be able to run
this operating
system first up we got a CPU requirement
which states that a 1 GHz dual Coe CPU
is the absolute minimum in order to use
bar OS while multiple core systems will
provide more Optimum performance a small
beginner has been
included a very distinct thing to be
noted is that the operating system can
be installed on all variance of chipsets
be 32-bit 64bit and the newly popular
armm portfolio of
devices unlike K Linux which requires
some amount of graphical acceleration to
display the operating system correctly
paret OS has no such requirements and
can be used with the leanest of
machines taking into account the ram
issue a minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free
Ram provides the optimum usage
scenarios even when the OS is installed
on a hard drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB of
information which may extend up to 16GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box when it comes to booting
options we have the option option of
going with the Legacy BIOS settings or
with the more modern ufi settings these
are just some of the requirements for
the installation of parro security OS to
understand this process more vividly and
to learn how visualization can help
install an OS in our existing computer
please follow the link to a parate
security installation video linked right
above let's understand what some of the
things that make parot security unique
among all the other penetration testing
operating system
along with all the giant catalog of
scripts par security has its own custom
hardened Linux kernel which has been
modified explicitly to provide as much
security and resistance to hackers as
possible as a first line of defense the
configurations in the operating system
act as a second Gateway taking care of
malitia requests and dropping them off
this is particularly beneficial since
should there be a scenario where the
latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the par to his
development team will most likely add in
it out first before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardened kernel
wasn't reasoning enough parent security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users all the tools you found in Kali
are present in parto and then a few
extra ones for good measure this has
been achieved while keeping roughly the
same size of the installation file
between both operating systems
however it's not all productivity points
for parro OS they provide a choice
between two different desktop
environments the M desktop which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with Linux terminology
you can think of desktop environments as
the main UI for a Linux system being
highly modular in nature one can use Ki
Linux or parat Os while adding another
text of environment which they find
appealing while Kali has only a single
option par has managed to provide two
optimized bills with made desktop and KD
desktop ready made on the
website one of the primary advantages of
parat os over Kali is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes frequently less dis space and
computing power to function properly
with as little as 320 MB of ram required
in reality paratos is also designed to
operate successfully of a USB stick but
Kali leux does not work well from a USB
stick and is generally installed in a
virtual machine parat can be seen as
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than K
Linux there are multiple ways to go
about with this
installation many people prefer to
install it directly onto a hard disk
where the parro security OS will
override whichever data the hard disk
already has now this is beneficial if
you want to preserve your data for the
long term but this might pose some
trouble to people who do not have a
spare hard disk or do not want to lose
their current installation of Windows
operating system another way to use par
security is by using the live boot but
whatever changes you make to the live
boot operating system those changes are
removed the moment we restart or shut
down the
system a very good Common Ground between
both these installations is
virtualization using virtualization
software like VMware or virtual box we
can install parad security on our
systems while simultaneously saving our
data and having the convenience of a
host machine such as a Windows operating
system in case things go
wrong to start the installation we first
need to get a ISO file for the par
security operating system this can be
found on the current
website parats sec.org
once we enter the website move into the
download
section and select the get security
Edition over
here par security OS has multiple
desktop environments to you to choose
from these desktop environments serves
as a different user interface for the
user for example right now we have the M
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to
them for our example let's go with a M
desktop we have two options either we
can go with the direct download or we
can get the torrent file for this
example if you press on the download
button
and our download will start I have
already downloaded this file but the ISO
file provided over here will serve as an
installation it will have around 4 and2
GB of space it will be used to install
this operating system in
VMware once the file is downloaded we
can close this and open VMware
Workstation VMware can also be used as a
player version or the Workstation
version if you have much more
familiarity with using virtual box of
virtualization application we can use
that as
well once the VMware is open we click on
file and select a new virtual
machine for the first time installation
we're going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine oses going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with the
typical option
moving on it will ask us for a source to
where to install the operating system
from since we're going to use a live ISO
first we're going to select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later and press
next as we already know parent security
is a deban derivative so When selecting
the guest operating system type we're
going to go with Linux and in the
selection we're going to choose
whichever the highest version of Debian
is along with the 64 forbit
OS we're going to click on next we're
going to name our virtual machine let's
say parent security
OS we're going to select the location
where we want to save the virtual
machine this will have all the hard disk
of the operating system
installation we're going to click on
next for the disk size we're going to
specify how much of the current memory
are we going to allocate this is the
hard disk memory of the operating system
installation whatever changes you make
in the operating system whatever
applications we install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage we
can go as high as possible and we're
going to select the recommended 20gb as
written when given the choice of storing
the virtual dis as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that it
helps them stay portable people change
systems and sometimes they want to swap
their instances between the work and
their personal computer if there is no
portability in mind storing the virtual
dis as a single file gives the best
performance and should be the
recommended goto when installing for the
first time we click on next here and
it's going to give us a summary of the
settings we have already settled till
now we're going to press on
finish and there we go we have our
installation First Step
completed here on out we're going to
click on edit virtual machine
settings here we're going to have a look
at some of the requirements that the
parro security OS will need it is known
to be a memory lightweight operating
system but just to have the most Optimum
performance we're going to provide
around 2 GB of RAM from our host system
which is a Windows 10 machine when it
comes to the processors I'm going to
increase it to two and the number of
codes to two as well so giving out a
total four processor Calles to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at
hand hard size has already been set at
20gb and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on one thing that
we need to make sure is selecting the CD
DVD IDE here we have to use a ISO image
file over here previously it should be
used physic drive and at Auto detect
we're going to use a use ISO image file
over here we're going to click on
browse we're going to go to where we
have downloaded the ISO file which is
over here and select
it press okay
here and we can now power on this
virtual
machine at this point of time there are
two options we can go with the try
install option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode to get a better user
experience we're going to go with the
try install mode specifically press
enter and it's going to start the live
boot ISO meanwhile vmw has an prompt
over here where it will try to install
some VMware tools on it while this is
not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools tools
so that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we're going to close this
prompt as you can see this is the live
boot ISO of the parot security operating
system currently it's running the mat
desktop as we have downloaded in the
website the live boot ISO is necessary
to get a good feel of the operating
system there are many good Linux dros
that have this live boot option so that
you can give a try of the operating
system before installing it
permanently once you're into the live
boot we can start up with the
installation using the shortcut as you
can see install parot going to double
click
it and this is a calamaras installer
choose your language as American
English and press
next you can select your time zone
according to a
location C and we can go
next at this point of time you have to
choose choose the correct keyboard now
what many people go get confused is
choosing their own language keyboard but
people must keep in mind is what
keyboard the laptop
provides most of the systems that come
pre-build provide the English US
keyboard so whatever keyboard you choose
make sure to type here and test that all
the buttons including the superscript
and the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this
step once you settled on the keyboard
that you need to install can go
ahead here it will ask you to select
storage device and the only option
you're going to get is the amount of
hard disk storage you have given in the
virtual machine settings we have already
provided 20 GB of storage we're going to
choose that and we're going to erase
this
disk manual partitioning can be useful
when you're going to install parad
security on an operating system or on a
hard disk where it is is already
including a Windows OS for now we're
going to select erase disk and press
next we're going to give our full name
Let It Be simply
learn you can give the name of the
computer and this is the username which
we will use to log
in this is your root password that we
going to give over here the root
password of this C Linux will act as the
administrative access and it will be
necessary for making changes to the
system or installing and updating
software enter the password and repeat
it over
here you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this
disabled click on next this is another
summary of the installation that we
going to move forward with have a look
that whatever changes we have made is
according to your requirements and once
everything is checked you can press on
install click on install
now and we're going to let it complete
the
work as you can see the installation of
parro security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart Now button over here
disabled I'm going to click on
done we're going to to shut down this
live boot
ISO going to click on
menu turn off the
device and shut
down we're not restarting straight away
because if you remember correctly in the
virtual machine instance settings we had
given it an ISO
file please remove the live medium and
press enter to continue we can just
press enter to
continue and it's going to shut down now
to move on we're going to click on edit
virtual machine
settings going to CD DVD and we're going
to use physical drive now we're going to
remove it from the iso image file
because the installation has already
been completed and we don't want to use
the same ISO file again and again by
using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20gb hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it going to
press
okay and we're going to power on this
virtual machine for
testing make sure this you click s over
here this is the grub menu at this we
get different choices for example which
NVIDIA drivers off or with some other
Advanced options
more often than not we're going to
choose the first option and press
enter if you remember clearly we did not
get the option of try install or a
terminal run just like we did in the
live boot ISO since this is running
straight from the 20gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the OS
directly now with the login screen you
can see our username over here as we
provided in the
installation we're going to enter our
root
password and press
enter and this is a currently working
desktop of the par security operating
system we can open the terminal over
here and we're going to try a root
password and
installation to install any software
we're going to use the keyword Pudo
AP install and Neo
fetch we're going to use the root
password that we used to log
in going to press y for
yes this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had
provided
now that we have installed neof fetch we
can write the command new
Fetch and this is going to give us some
information about our
installation you can see the OS name as
parro OS 4.11 is running on a VMware
host it's the kernel versions and some
of the other information like the number
of packages installed the current shell
version res resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once and some other things
you can see the memory is supposed to be
1951 mbes which is supposed to equal
around 2 GB of RAM usage that we had
provided K Linux and parat Os are two
popular penetration testing
distributions while these operating
systems each have unique offerings the
overall Choice can differ between
Personnel thanks to the various tools
and Hardware
specifications today we will look at
both these distributions and settle on
the perfect choice for each type of user
let's go through the agenda for this
video we will learn about K Linux and
pirot security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers next we know
about some features of these operating
systems that stand out of their
package finally we directly compare K
Linux and parro security OS thereby
making a clear-cut conclusion on which
OS is perfect on a per requirement
basis so let's start by learning about K
Linux from a ground
level K Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open-source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multiplatform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and a
stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the K Linux desktop
while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of K Linux come disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a more
profound element of security control to
the most enthusiastic of
users now let's take a look at parad
security operating
system paret security OS is a Debian
based Linux distribution with an
emphasis on security privacy and
development it is built on the demian's
testing branch and uses a custom
hardened Linux
kernel par security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards tasks
such as penetration testing computer for
n6 reverse engineering and security
research it is seen as a generally
lightweight distribution that can work
under rigorous hardware and software
specifications it features a distinct
forensics mode that does not Mount any
of the systems hard diss or partitions
and has no influence on the host system
making it much more stealy than its
regular occurrence this mode is used on
the host system to execute forensic
procedures a rolling release is a
paradigm in which software upgrades are
rolled out constantly rather than in
batches of versions and software
development this enses that the software
is constantly up to date a rolling
release distribution such as pirate
security OS follows the same concept it
provides the most recent Linux kernel
and software versions as soon as they
become
available with the basic introduction to
the operating systems out of the way let
us take a look at the unique features of
both K Linux and parad security
OS the latest version of K Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar
functionality the K Linux team comprises
a small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external assets dramatically
reduces the risk of source contamination
which can cause C Linux users worldwide
a great deal of damage as a direct
victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Kali includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more prevalent and inexpensive
the development team knew that Khali's
armm support would need to be as robust
as they could manage with fully working
installations Kali Linux is available on
a wide range of armm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with the
the mainline distribution so the tools
for armm are updated in conjunction with
the rest of the
distribution let's take a look at some
of the features of parat security
operating system
now along with the giant catalog of
scripts par security OS has its own
hardened Linux kernel modified
explicitly to provide as much security
and resistance to hackers as possible in
the first line of defense the the
configurations in the operating system
Act is the second gate view taking care
of malicious requests and dropping them
off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latex Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parat O development
team will most likely iron it out first
before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardal kernel
wasn't reason enough paret security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and Scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent to us and a few extra
ones for good measure and this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
operating system size between both of
them however it's not all productivity
points for pirate OS they provide a
choice between two different desktop
environments mate which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with Linux next
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a
distribution being highly modular in
nature one can use parad security OS
while adding another desktop environment
that they find appealing while K Linux
has only a single option parad security
has provided two optimized bills with M
desktop and KD
desktop one of the primary advantages of
parro os over K Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less disk space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality paratos is
designed to operate successfully off a
USB stick but K Linux does not work well
from a USB Thrive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine parat is
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than
K features are great but what about
performance real world metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and usability in the end
we can decide on what distribution is
fit for each type of
user for our first point of comparison
let's take a look at the ram required
for Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature RAM usage is a very
important facet while khux demands at
least 1 GB of RAM par security can
operate optimally with a minimum of 320
MB of
RAM for correctly displaying graphical
elements K Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parent security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user side
once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos they take up a minimum amount of
hard disk storage both of these
operating systems have a recommended
disk storage of minimum of 20 GB in K
Linux and a minimum of 15 GB in parro
security so they can install all the
tools necessary in the ISO
file when it comes to the category and
the selection of tools K Linux has
always been the first in securing every
single tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry par
Security on the other hand has manage to
take it up a
notch while specializing in Wireless pen
testing parage security makes it a point
that all the tools that K Linux provides
has been included in the iso while
simultaneously adding some extra tools
that many users will have to installed
from third party sources in K
Linux
being a decade old penetration testing
distribution K Linux has formed up a
very big Community with strong support
signature par Security on the other hand
is still growing and it is garnering
much more interest among veteran
penetration testers and ethical
hackers a primary drawback of K Linux is
the extensive Hardware requirement to
perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parro security it also needs
iCal acceleration while demanding more
virtual hardk Storage parro security on
the other hand was initially designed to
run off a USB drive directly thereby
requiring very minimal requirements from
a hardware perspective like just 320 MB
of RAM and no graphical acceleration
needed this means parro security is much
more feasible for people who are not
able to devot massive resources to
either their virtual machine or on their
laptop hard disk
directly with the comparison done
between both of these operating systems
let's take a look at the type of users
both of these are catered
to one can go with K Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years if they have a powerful system
which can run K Linux optimally without
having to bottleneck performance and if
they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners one can decide to go with par
security if they want to go with a very
lightweight and lean distribution that
can run pretty much on all
systems it also has a lot of tools
pre-installed and some of them are not
even present on G
Linux it is much more suitable for
underpowered DS where users do not have
a lot of Hardware resources to provide
to the operating system and thereby it
is much more feasible for people people
with underpowered laptops or no
graphical
acceleration compared to K Linux parot
Securities desktop environment is also
relatively easier to use for new
beginners for people who are just
getting into ethical hacking par
security does a relatively better job of
introducing them to the operating system
and to the various toools without having
to dump them into the entire intricacies
with ethical hacking and penetration
testing becoming Main stream and
corporate environments trained personnel
and relevant equipment are in high
demand the right software framework can
be the Tipping Point in a hacking
Campaign which deals with intricate
Hardware one such tool that has become a
main state for decades is nmap when it
comes to scanning machines for open
ports and services nmap has always been
the first choice for hackers being
lightweight and open source nmap has
strong Community backing and receives
regular
updates let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today
we start by learning about the different
phases in ethical hacking and where nmap
is most valuable to ethical hackers we
learn the basics of nmap and its purpose
during a penetration testing
campaign next we take a look at the top
level approach of nmap as a scanning
tool and how it conducts these scans on
host
machines moving
on we cover the multiple modes and types
of scans that can be performed using
nmap on unsuspecting
users we also look at some Alternatives
that users can prefer if nmap is not
something they are comfortable with
while a live demonstration of the powers
of nmap will help in shedding light on
the topics being taught
today let us first understand where and
why and map is
essential there are essentially five
phases in ethical hacking the
reconnaissance phase is the first phase
of the penetration test here the
security researcher collects information
about the target it can be done actively
or passively or both it helps security
firms gather information about the
target system Network components active
machines Etc this activity can be
performed by using the information
publicly available and by using
different
tools the scanning phase is more tool
oriented rather than being performed
manually the tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the Target by using various
scanners such as war dialers port
scanners Network mappers and
vulnerability scanners the penetration
test collects as many vulnerabilities
which help in turn to attack a Target in
a more sophisticated
manner in the gaining axis phase the
penetration tester tries to establish a
connection with the Target and exploit
the vulnerabilities found in the
previous phase the exploitation may be a
buffer overflow attack denial of service
attack session hijacking and many more
basically the penetration tester
extracts information and sensitive data
from the servers by gaining access with
different tools
in the maintaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to create a
back door for himself it helps him to
identify hidden vulnerabilities in the
system while allowing him to come back
to the system to retrieve more data
further
on in the clearing tax phase the tester
tries to remove all logs and Footprints
which might help the administrator
identify his presence this helps the
tester to think like a hacker and
perform corrective actions to mitigate
those
activities andap is most beneficial in
the early stages of ethical hacking
where a hacker must figure the possible
entry point to a system it is necessary
to know this before running the
necessary exploits thus allowing the
hackers to leverage any insecure
openings and breach the device so the
reconnaissance and the scanning phase
are the points where nmap finds the most
use let us now understand what nmap is
from a Layman's
perspective nmap which stands for
network mapper is a free and open source
utility for network discovery and
security auditing many systems and
network administrators also find it
useful for tasks such as Network
inventory managing service upgrade
schedules and monitoring host and
service uptime the program is most
commonly used via a command line
interface and is available for many
different operating systems such as
Linux free PSD and
gento it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploit
nmap was developed for Enterprise scale
networks and can scan through thousands
of connected devices however in recent
years nmap is being increasingly used by
smaller companies as well nmap uses raw
IP packets in novel ways to determine
what hosts are available on the network
what services these host are offering
what operating systems they are running
what type of packet filters and
firewalls are in use and dozens of other
characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fine against single hor as well the rise
of the iot in particular now means that
networks used by these companies have
become more complex and therefore harder
to secure since every application that
connects to a network needs to do so via
a port the wrong port or server
configuration can open a can of forms
that leads to a thorough breach of the
system the recent emergence of iot Bot
Nets like meai has also simulated
interest in N map not least because of
its ability to interrogate devices
connected via the UPnP protocol but also
to highlight any devices that may be
malicious now that we understand what
nmap is let us take a look at the
workflow of how an ethical hacker uses
this tool in penetration
testing at a practical level nmap is
used to provide detailed real-time
information on your networks and other
devices connected to them we have the
hacker running nmap on a system with a
victim machine running a standard
installation of the operating system be
it Windows Mac OS or
Linux the nmap interface will send
specially crafted packets to generate
some reply from the victim machine the
victim machine in return will send some
information back to the nmap host with
replying some of the services and hosts
that are being run on the computers nmap
allows the network admins to find which
devices are running discover some open
ports and other services this in turn
help discover the vulnerabilities and
the possible entry points for hackers to
breach
into we are now aware of how nmap works
on a basic level but there are many
varieties of cans that users can run on
local machines let's take a look at some
of
them the Ping sweep is a simple type of
nmap scan where it pings to all the
available IP addresses to check which
IPS respond to icmp protocol if the
users need to know only the number of IP
addresses and not many details the Ping
sweep is very useful it's fast and hence
the results to be known are fetched very
easily
the SN scan is the most useful type of
nmap scan which does work very quietly
it sends an SN packet via the TCP
protocol or the transfer control
protocol to all the intended ports if an
acknowledgement pack is received to the
system it is sure that a port is opened
there no response means that the port is
either closed or not available here the
acknowledgement pack is not sent back to
the system assuming that the connection
is not valid the scan is not shown in
most of the scan logs and hence it is
safe to use SN scan to identify the open
ports the TCP connect scan is similar to
SN scan in many aspects as it uses the
TCP layer to send packets and is passed
to all the ports here the difference is
that the full connection is done by
sending the acknowledgement back at back
the logs can easily find the TCP scan
and need more power from the machines to
do the work but it is more
accurate if all the accesses related to
the OS are available to the user it is
is better to do a TCP scan than an sinin
scan as all the low-level and high level
accesses are required for the scan the
network is also loaded more and hence
users must be careful about overloading
the system and the
networks the idle scan is really used to
check whether any malicious attacks are
planned on any particular
Network users need not control the
external host but an IP address and a
port should be given to the same all of
requirements are taken from the scanner
itself the RPC scans or remote procedure
calls are done by hackers to make the
system vulnerable to virus attacks it is
thus necessary to know whether our
systems answer such calls and make our
system open to
malware RPC scan is done to check this
by finding the ports open with certain
commands being run by
RPC the windows scan is a simple scan
where the application scans the
acknowledgement packets received from
the polls once the SN packets are sent
if there are any abnormalities in the AK
packets received the scan scan reports
the same and helps in recognizing which
ports are functioning in a different
manner the bound scan is used to check
the security in the file transfer
protocol layer FTP layers mostly do not
accept any packets and once it is
rejected from the FTP layers there are
chances that it might be sent to an
internal layer so that it can access the
internal machines bounce can check this
loophole by doing exactly the same
process and identifies whether our FTP
layer is open to vulnerability or
not the FI n scan is similar to SN scan
where the system that sends the packets
receives the response back and it will
be mostly be a TCP FN packet if the
system sends an RSD packet it is a false
alarm and users need not be worried
about the
same the null scan is useful for other
systems than Windows where the systems
can easily identify what kind of packets
they have received and respond back with
either TCP packets are null responses
null scans are not useful for Windows as
they may not always produce the desired
results
when it comes to looking at Alternatives
there's a wide range of free network
monitoring utilities as well as free
open source vulnerability scanners
available to network administrators and
security
Auditors what makes nmap stand out as a
tool it and network security managers
need to know is its flexibility and
power there are some alternatives to
nmap but most of them are focused on
providing specific Niche functionality
than the average system administrator
does need frequently M scan for instance
is much faster than nmap but provides
less detail in reality however nmap
provides all the functionality and speed
that the average user requires
especially when used along with other
similar tools like netcat which can be
used to manage and control Network
traffic and zenmap which provides a
graphical user interface for nmap but as
an allrounder solution to network
scanning nobody can go wrong with nmap
as their tool of
choice let's now take a tour of nmap
based on all the things we have covered
today in this live demonstration we
start by learning on how to install nmap
on a fresh operating system that doesn't
come pre-installed with the tool we also
cover the different types of scans that
can be run on local machines along with
checking multiple inferences on ethical
hacker can gather based on the scan
output of an nmap screen finally we run
scans on vulnerable machines to get an
idea of how to proceed with the outputs
We Gather using this tool if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more the
first step in our demonstration is
installing
nmap now it depends heavily on what
Linux distribution you're going to use
to perform ethical hacking right now I'm
using parot security operating system if
you're not aware of what parot security
is or even what call Linux is we highly
suggest that you check out the videos of
those two operating systems on my
YouTube channel so that you can get a
fair idea of what they serve now if you
are using any of these two operating
systems n map should come pre-installed
by default to check if nmap is
pre-installed or not you can just press
on applications over here go to the pen
testing
section go to this information gathering
Tab and you should be able to see nmap
right here now let's say you do not have
nmap pre-installed maybe you're using a
Linux distrib ution like Ubuntu or Linux
Min or something that is based on depan
operating systems one thing you have to
make sure that nmap should be in the
distribution repository once you check
that or even if you do not know if it is
present you can just this command should
be pseudo which is to give root
permissions for installation a AP is the
package manager of all Linux
distributions that are based on Debian
that goes for Debian St table Ubuntu
Linux Min K Linux par security and
anything of that
nature AP is the package manager which
handles the installation and removal of
applications in these specific operating
systems once you're here just write
install and end map press enter and it's
going to ask you for the root password
that you set when you install the
operating system in the first place
enter your root password and press enter
again
as you can see it's saying that nmap is
already installed the newest version
since I'm running parate security
operating system now should you be
running this operating system or even G
Linux you should receive a similar
message and the installation is already
done if you are using some other
distribution let's say even black o Arch
Linux or Manjaro anything like that the
installation steps will be slightly
different this pseudo AP install nmap
command is for distributions that are
derived from Debian and abantu if you
want to install in Arch Linux based
distributions you have to use their
package manager which is known as
pamac but that is for a different step
and if you want to get an ethical
hacking the best way to start is by
learning either K Linux or par security
now that the installation is done we're
going to learn how to use nmap one of
the most basic functions of nmap is to
identify active hosts on the network we
can do this by using a ping scan the
ping scan identifies all of the IP
addresses that are currently online
without sending any packets to these
hosts now to run the ping scan we're
going to write end map the flag we're
going to mention over here is sp now
these flags are the
different traits of the nmap scan
depending on what flag we use we can
send different kinds of requests to the
host that we are scanning now before
moving forward with this let me open
another terminal over here and check the
IP
address we're going to write the command
if config and find the Subnet in which
this system is present as you can see
the IP address is
192.168
72131 now this operating system is being
run on a virtual machine software known
as VMware the VMware in itself is
running on a Windows 10 operating system
considering they are now a part of the
local network this IP address is of par
security and the Windows operating
system which is the host system in my
scenario will fall in this particular
subnet so to run our
scan we're going to Target 19
192.168 and
72.1
-24 this command then returns a list of
hosts on your network and the total
number of assigned IP
addresses this is going to be capital P
yeah if you spot any host or IP
addresses on that list that you cannot
account for you can then run further
commands to investigate them further as
of right now you can see the machine
that is the parent security this IP
address can be detected in the subnet
the 19 192.168 72.1 is my local Windows
machine that is running VMware software
and ultimately this virtual machine the
72.2 is the DHCP server that hosts the
internet connection of the par security
this we can ignore for now now the
Windows machine that we have over here
let's run some tests on that going to
clear our
terminal and we can close this
actually
when scanning hosts and map commands can
use server names ipv4 addresses or IPv6
addresses a basic nmap
command will produce information about
the given host to run a basic port scan
we can just use nmap along with the IP
now as you remember the IP
192.168 72.1 this is the IP of my local
Windows 10
machine as you can see it shows the
ports that are open and the particular
servers that these ports are
running now you can also have a
detection of the operating system now
mind you this is not 100% correct and
the reliability depends on the
installation and what kind of
fingerprinting measures are available
now since this does TCP IP
fingerprinting it needs some extra
permissions the flag that we going to
use is n map minus o along with the same
IP
address like I said since this is TCP IP
fingerprinting it requires root
privileges now to provide root
privileges we're just going to add the N
map and pseudo
keyword going to repeat the same command
that we wrote
above as you can see it has successfully
detected that I am running Microsoft
Windows
10 with this Mac
address it has also shown the correct
build number of the Windows 10 system
that I am
using this is useful for troubleshooting
scanning for few vulnerabilities or even
locating some services that need to be
updated to get the necessary information
about these services for example what
versions they are using we have a
command known as SV which stand for
service version we use the same IP
address and press
center now as you can see the scan is
complete and if you can check the
results of the scan above here we don't
see any version number for the
services here we can actually check what
version they are running now this
becomes helpful when we are trying to
find specific versions to exploit for
example if VM workstation 16. 1.2 had
some particular vulnerability we can
exploit it by checking this
command apart from the host scanning
Port scanning is one of the most basic
utilities there are few ways that this
command can be customized as well for
example I have already checked that the
the 443 command is open but I have found
out after running this lengthy scan
let's say I only want to check if
command if the port 443 is open and map
I'm going to use
the flag of minus P which stands for
port and give 443 as an argument here
using the same IP
address and you can see it says it's
open
but we already knew it is open let's say
there was something else uh if let's say
we're going to scan if the Apache web
server port is open which usually runs
on
80 obviously since I'm not running an
Apache web server it says it's
closed now we can combine these two
commands by running both BS
simultaneously to do that we can just
put a
comma and complete the rest
similarly expected 80 is closed and 443
is open another feature of n map for
Port scanning is showing of ranges now
ranges can be beneficial when you're
trying to see up to a certain limit for
example n map minus P we're going to
check what ports are open between 100 to
let's say
2,000 this act is a
range everything else is the
same and it checks all ports in the
range of 100 to
2,000 whatever ports is open in between
that range it can be mentioned over
here we're going to clear the screen now
another flag that can be used with nmap
is the SS command this runs a steal scan
which is a little harder to detect if
you're the it admin of the system that
is being
scanned the results will more or less be
the same although this will need
elevated route
privileges
2.1 as you can see this is more or less
similar to a port scan just adds an
extra mac RIS as well for good measure
but like I said it's more about the
stealth the normal scans usually are
easier to detect when the logs are being
checked style scans are relatively
tougher to check on much more intricate
systems this takes longer as
well now that we're done with Port
scanning let's look at a vulnerable
machine the system that is scanning
right now is the my own personal system
with everything is pretty locked down as
much as it can
be there is an attack box
running in the cloud the IP address of
which is over here now to be able to get
into this network we need to connect to
their personal network using a VPN so
what I'm going to do is switch to a
different workspace over here I'm going
to open our
terminal and if you can see over here
there is a hack test. ovpn file I'm
going to connect to their VPN network
using this ovpn
file
and once we get the initialization
sequence completed message we know that
the connection has been
established like we discussed this is
the vulnerable device IP we're going to
copy
this and we're going to try to Ping this
let's open a new terminal we're going to
try to Ping this and check if we are
able to reach this
machine and as you can see we're getting
a reply back which means we are now part
of the local network where the
vulnerable machine is
present let's run a service scan map
with the respective
versions We ran the similar scan on my
local machine where we were able to
detect what version each service was
running what we're going to do over here
is by checking what kind of services are
open on the machine running on the cloud
we're going to decide what we are going
to do next and we're going to see if in
map alone can point us to a Direction
Where We can gain access to the
machine as you can see the scan is now
completed and we have some of the ports
that are being opened over here and what
kind of service they are
running now like we discussed this is
the first stage or sometimes even the
second stage of ethical
hacking what we can infer from here is
what are the services that are being run
now these two ports 139 and 445 are
actually Windows SMP server ports which
are above the windows Samba server now
every service has a particular put
attached to it that will be consistent
whichever machine you may use Apache
server will always run on Port 80 SM SMB
servers will function on these two
ports now SMB servers have had a
vulnerability known as the Eternal blue
exploit which was pretty well known as
of right now from the scan results we
are not able to detect if this machine
has the similar vulnerability or not but
since it has the SMB server open it's
worth a shot that we try that exploit on
this
machine now to start the exploit on this
we're going to open another terminal
over
here and we're going to use met sploit
for trying the exploit there we're going
to write sud sudo msf
console msf console is the keyword for
launching the Metasploit
console enter the root password and wait
for metas plit to Launch
other than the ports we can also see
that it has checked the host name of the
system and the operating system as
well now that the metas spit is
open we're going to launch the
exploit now before launching we're going
to have to check what exploits are there
for the Eternal blue
vulnerability you're going to write use
exploit blue and we're going to check
what kind of results we are getting over
here as you can
see serial number nine exploit Windows
SMB Ms 17010 Eternal blue it was first
disclosed in 2017 and SMB remote kernel
buol
corruption let's say we're going to use
this particular exploit now all of this
may be confusing if you're not aware of
Metasploit but remember this is the next
stage of ethical hacking which comes
into the gaining access part we're going
to use exploit number nine as we found
above to use exploit number
nine we're going to set a p
load which is our malicious code that
will run on the the victim
machine now we're going to
check some options as you can see it has
by default pointed it to the 445 Port
since that is the port where SM SMB
server can be accessed
from the parameter that's missing over
here is our host the r host is the IP
address of the vulnerable machine
basically the machine in which we want
to attack now I'm going to use
the set
command to set the IP
address now if we
check we now
have a victam IP address
set another parameter that we can change
is the lhost this is basically the IP
address of our own system where we are
going to gain access now if you have
remember we had connected using a VPN so
so we're going to be assigned a new IP
according to the VPN so if you write if
config and check this one T10 is the VPN
adapter this is our IP address that we
have been assigned in the server in the
network where the vulnerable machine is
present so we're going to copy this IP
address we going to move over this
workspace and we're going to set
lhost with that IP address
with that our options are set now we're
going to run
exploit and it's going to check if
sambar server vulnerability is
present as you can see it has written
that the target is vulnerable to this
particular exploit it's going to send
the malicious code and the malicious
code is set in the payload that you sent
above
and we now have the shell command of the
Windows
machine as you can see see Windows
system
32 to be sure that this is in fact this
Windows machine that is being used we're
going to write ip config which is a
Windows only shell
command as you can see this is the IP
address that was assigned to the victim
victim machine
now while the major part of this process
was done on
Metasploit we would not have reached the
stage had we not found out that the 139
and 445 ports are open which basically
pointed us that we can try the Eternal
blue exploit of the windows Samba
servers similarly all the scans that we
run serve as a preface to the actual
stages or the actual hacking stages of
the campaigns
this SV command was necessary because we
could check what are the exact services
that are being running in some cases if
if it Apache server is being run there
are particular versions which have
particular exploits those exploits will
not work on other versions so we're
going to have to check what particular
version is being run and accordingly
apply the exploit that can be done in
the metlo or you can run some other tool
but what exact exploit you have to run
and which vulnerability we have to
Target that is where nmap comes to help
with the world moving towards the next
generation of computer hardware the
software side of things still has a lot
left to be discovered with the majority
of laptops coming with Windows
pre-installed many users are devoid of
the Linux operating system experience
which is more resource friendly than the
mainstream operating systems it can be
attributed to the difficulty people used
to face when installing a new operating
system like Linux in the old days
however a lot of these issues are fixed
nowadays thanks to the big names like
Debian and ubu who have been
instrumental in making Linux based
operating systems as user friendly as
possible but which one of them is better
for you let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today as we answer this
question for
you we start by learning about the
operating systems from a Layman's
perspective and uncovering the basic
offerings of both
entities next we cover the unique
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
how they stack up against each other and
other industry
counterparts moving on we take a look at
some pointers before installing each of
these operating systems and the
respective download
links finally We compare the contrasting
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
infer the kind of users each OS skaters
to so let's start by learning about
Ubuntu and Debian in
general
Ubuntu is an open- Source free Linux
distribution it is an operating system
for cloud computing in accordance with
support with open stack Ubunto is
developed by the canonical community and
it is freely available also canonica
limited is sponsible for the funding of
Ubuntu basically Ubuntu is released
every 6 months free support is available
for 9 months after every release and
long-term support which are the LTS is
released every 2 years the first release
of Ubuntu was in October
2004 you must have heard about uban 2 no
matter what it is the most popular Linux
distribution overall not just limited to
servers but also the most popular choice
for Linux desktops it's easy to use
offers a good experience and comes
pre-installed with essential tools to
get a head start of course Ubuntu
managed to simplify the Linux experience
years back and that is the reason why it
is still so popular even with several
impressive Linux distributions available
right now every new release is more
polished and comes loaded with new
features and
improvements thanks to its huge user
base a number of software vendors have
made the applications compatible with
onew while the catalog may not be as
extensive as Windows the options are
still well curated more importantly the
advantage of Linux based operating
systems is the ability to use free and
open-source alternatives to Major
proprietary software by lacking some
Polish and overall feature set most
alternatives are enough to get the job
done for majority of the users the
never-ending Community Support also
helps in troubleshooting should things
go wrong at any point in
time the default desktop environment in
ubo is gnome or a Unity the unity is a
modern desktop environment with a
powerful Search tool for finding all
your applications and documents with its
base setup as noome it integrates well
with common applications such as audio
players video players and social media
media there are a few other desktop
environments for2 as well with unity as
its Flagship
environment Debian on the other hand is
a free operating system for your
computer which started in 1996 and is
maintained by global
contributors if the operating system a
set of basic programs and utilities that
make your computer run its core is the
kernel the kernel is the most
fundamental program on the computer
Debian uses the Linux kernel a
completely piece of software which was
started by Linus trowal and supported by
thousands of programmers worldwide a
large part of the basic tools that fill
out the operating system come from the
gnu project and those rules are free as
well Debian is the mother of Linux
distributions beginners always wonder
why this not so good-looking drro is so
popular inside the Linux developers
Community especially when there are a
lot of modern distributions that are
easy to use and have beautiful UI later
on they found out the power of Debian
after using a bunch of distributions
from other developers you'll be
surprised to know that almost all other
popular consumer level disos are based
on Dean even U it is so stable and
feature Rich that the developers find it
easy to build their D based on Debian
rather than building it from
scratch Debian is run and maintained on
its GitHub repository thanks to
contributions from developers worldwide
the major decisions are taken up on the
repository issues tab leading to
CommunityWide feedback and holis
approach to open source development of
the Debian operating system thanks to
this variety of personnel the source
code of Debian comprises around 70
different programming and scripting
languages Debian supports all kinds of
graphical environments ranging from full
feature desktop environments to lighter
Alternatives and EM minimalist window
managers ubo ships with unity desktop by
default but the package manager can
install The Gnome environment if needed
while also including cinnamon l XD xfc
KDE and M on the other hand Debian gives
you the choice of choosing which desktop
environment you want from the getco by
providing ISO files for each desktop
environment
individually now that we understand
where both these operating systems stand
let us take a look at some of the best
features offered by each of these
distributions U is the closest thing to
a household name among desktop Linux
distributions it is a great distribution
to start with and it's even a great
distribution to keep using after you
more experienced if you're happy with it
it is user friendly in a lot of ways it
provides a simple desktop has an easy
installer and provides a checkbox during
the installation process that will
automatically install Flash plugins and
various codecs that you will need for
multimedia support there's an additional
drivers tool that will detect closed
Source or proprietary drivers that might
be necessary to get all your Hardware
working and easily install them for
you uban 2 is produced by canonical and
their friends it is run as an open
project to enable others with diverse
ideas to benefit from all the work the
developers do to deliver the world's
best open platform still canonical is
responsible for delivering six monthly
Milestone releases and regular LTS
releases for Enterprise production use
Enterprises can count on canonical to
support secure and manage uban to
infrastructure and devices with more
than 500 employees in over 39 countries
the company underpins the critical
infrastructure for thousands of
businesses and millions of Ubunto users
around the
world Unity desktop was originally
developed by canonical and introduced
earlier for Netbook computers with uban
2 10.10 then it went on to be the
default desktop environment for uban 2
eventually it has been dropped by
canonical and replaced by gnome however
it has made a comeback after UB to
18.04 while being completely stable the
HUD and Global menu hold up just fine
with major applications such as lib
office Thunderbird and other web
browsers that means that the unity
desktop works as it is supposed to while
making you more productive when some
desktop environments have a steep
learning curve Unity is very intuitive
for new users in spite of deviating from
the traditional start menu format that
the windows users are generally
accustomed
to
the calamaras installer is a framework
by design it is very customizable in
order to satisfy a wide variety of needs
and use cases calamaras aims to be easy
usable beautiful pragmatic and more
importantly distribution agnostic
calamaras includes an advanced
partitioning feature as well which
supports for both manual and automated
partitioning operations it is the first
installer with an automated replace
partition option which makes it easy to
reuse a partition over and over for
distribution
testing coming to Debian it is a
community distribution through and
through it's governed by a board of
elected developers it has its own
internal structure and laws and just
about everyone working on it is a
volunteer making it completely Community
Driven it is maintained and developed by
programmers and developers all around
the world this form of development
ensures continuity if one of the
developers decides to stop working on
the project another developer might come
in and take place and keep the project
going on it is completely free of
centralized control and this is also one
of the reasons for an undecided stable
release cycle Debian Sid is the
permanently unstable development version
of Debian it where the latest versions
of programs are being considered for
inclusion in the Debian release cycle
are uploaded and tested because it has
no official installed media and the few
net boot images that are built often
don't work even people who are willing
to risk using a development version May
may have trouble installing it however
it Still Remains the best place to test
new features that have not yet made
their way onto the stable
Branch Debian has only free and
open-source software in its repositories
this is mostly ample for users except
for users who use Hardware that only has
proprietary drivers these repositories
work well in most cases it is possible
to add other repos as well that have pro
priy software if that is the
requirement Dean Standard Version is
very stable as software and libraries in
it go through rigorous testing the
stability makes Debian a perfect server
OS and it's also the same reason why
average user shy away from using Debian
as a primary OS on
desktop this is also one of the reasons
why many developers use Dean as a base
for their derivative one of which is
also
Ubuntu now that we are aware of each
distribution's unique features let's
take a look at how we can go ahead and
install inst all these operating systems
and where we can get the downloadable
images when it comes to Ubuntu Ubuntu
has dropped the support for 32-bit
systems currently it supports only 64bit
devices and armm devices installation is
easy with the calamis framework coming
into ISO pre default and the latest ISO
can be downloaded from the link being
shown on the screen right now in the
case of dbn the support for multiple
range of devices is still present that
can also include 32-bit systems and
other smaller devices which are not
modern even though it does not use the
calaris installer even downloading the
ISO file can be a bit hectic for newer
users considering this is a distribution
aimed at developers and intermediate
users finding the right link can be
difficult because of which if we have
mention the link on the screen below
where you can get the latest ISO
depending on which desktop environment
you choose to go go
with with the installation out of the
way let's take a direct comparison of
the features between both ubu and
Debian Debian is a community-driven
open- source Linux distribution and is
primarily aimed to be robust capable and
most importantly free on the other hand
Ubuntu is also and free on open source
like Debian but it's backed up and
developed by a Canon which is a
corporate company
Debian and uban 2 are both fundamentally
fast regarding performance as Debian
comes bare minimum and is not bundled or
prepack with additional software and
features it makes it super fast and
lightweight at least when compared with
uban 2
directly both Ubuntu and Debian use the
same AP software packaging management
system but provide a different software
repository Debian is more like promoting
freedom of choosing free software thus
it does not include any proprietary
software by default you can always
install the paid versions but you have
to enable it manually UB to focuses on
usability including all the software
including free paid open source closed
Source Etc Ubunto also introduced a
universal package management system
called Snap it will be used across dros
and thus prevent more drro based
software
fragmentations as the dean drro does not
contain any proprietary blobs there
might be some problems with drivers and
firmware that means Debian lack some of
the essential proprietary firmware by
default but the users can enable the
repository and install it manually like
other page software on the other hand UB
2 does not care how much whether it's
paid free open source or clone source so
it includes as many drivers and firmware
as possible ubun to also let you install
and configure the necessary drivers in
firmware automatically during
installation or
afterward if you are a gamer then you
will probably be concerned with the
latest software drivers and Hardware
support while Debian can potentially
provide that it is likely that you might
end up breaking your installation as
mentioned before UB to supports certain
proprietary packages as well which often
consist of graphic drivers which are
essential to gaming Debian focuses on
the open- source aspect of the software
hence it can be a well-known fact that
with Gamers Ubunto and some other
distributions like popos have been
working much better regarding both
software and Hardware
support regarding the audience they
cater to both Ubuntu and Dean have their
pros and cons Ubuntu is a very good
distribution for amateur users with
little to no experience and if they want
to have the latest versions of packages
and applications at all times on their
systems it is also for users who do not
want a lot of customizability in spite
of unity being very customized a desktop
environment it is also perfect for users
with newer Hardware since it comes
updated with all the latest graphical
devic devices and their respective
drivers Debian on the other hand is
cater towards a little bit of
experienced users who can fix some minor
bugs on their own or with minimal
Community Support it also is for users
who want to support an open source
approach rather than an operating system
which is devoid of any contribution from
other end and is primarily backed by a
corporation it also doesn't favor gaming
since it does not guarantee
compatibility with all the newest
graphic cards or even Wi-Fi cards in
some
cases however due to the low memory
overhead Debian is very useful for
people who are looking to run home
servers or even corporate environments
where running servers on Debian will
provide much more use data protection is
of Paramount importance in today's world
the vast amount of data flow between
corporations and consumer needs to be
secured considering that they entrusted
with a lot of belief a company can spend
millions of dollars on the most secure
servers but it takes a single hacker to
ruin all the Goodwill between between
the organizations to prevent these
malicious attacks many automated
security systems have been developed but
none of them have been as used as ideas
platforms which are also known as
intrusion detection systems welcome to
this introductory lesson on intrusion
detection systems so let's go through
the topics that we are going to cover
today we start with a basic definition
of ideas from a Layman's perspective
then moving on we cover the multiple
types of intruders that seek to access
confidential information without any
authorization next we cover the basic
ways to detect intrusion signatures from
the perspective of a network
administrator then take a look at the
different types of ID systems that can
be used in corporate environments today
a small explanation of the two types of
protection is Then followed by an
introduction to some of the most
well-known IDs tools on the market so
let's get started with what is an
IDs an intrusion detection system is an
app or device that monitors inbound and
outward Network traffic continuously
analyzing for activity changes in
patterns and alerts an administrator
when it detects unusual behavior an
administrator then reviews alarms and
take action to remove the threat for
example an IDs might inspect the data
carried by Network traffic to see if it
contains node malware or other malicious
content if it detects this type of
threat it sends an alert to your
security team so they can investigate
and remediated once your team receives
the alert they must act quickly to
prevent an attack from taking over the
system to ensure that the ideas doesn't
slow down Network performance the
solutions often use a switched Port
analyzer or a text access port to
analyze a copy of the inline data
traffic so that they do not meddle with
the actual
traffic however they do not block threat
once they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do regardless of
whether you set up a physical device or
an IDs program the system can recognize
attack patterns with network packets
monitor user Behavior identify abnormal
network activity or ensure user and
system activity do not go against
security
policies the main goal of an IDs is to
detect the anomalies before the hackers
complete the objective once the system
detects a threat the IT team is informed
and the information is passed on given
the requirement for understanding
context an Enterprise has to be ready to
make any ideas fit its own unique needs
expert advised what this means is that
an IDs cannot be a one siiz fits-all
configuration to operate accurately and
effectively and this requires a Savvy
ideas analyst to tailor the ideas for
the interest and needs of a given site
and knowledgeable train system analyst
ask SC the trick with ideas is that you
have to know what the attack is to be
able to identify it the ideas has always
had the patient zero problem you have to
have found someone who got sick and died
before you can identify it it can
usually go for two types of protection
active protection and passive in a
passive system the idas detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals an alert in a
reactive system or an active system the
idas responds to the suspicious activity
by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
Network traffic from the suspected
malicious
source so now that we understand what an
ideas is let us go through the different
type of intruders IDs platforms must be
aware of to understand the type of
intruders let us go through a scenario
we have the servers which are protected
by the ideas Platforms in place so let's
say a hacker tries to breach the system
from outside the organization this can
be done using multiple attacks like dos
attacks injection attacks Etc the
category of individuals that are not
authorized to use the system but still
exploit users privacy and confidential
information using different techniques
are known know as
masqueraders a masquerader is an
intruder that is an outsider who does
not have direct access to the system and
aims to attack unethically by stealing
data or
information however there is another
Intruder who is theoretically harder to
detect and approve than a masquerad
these are the people within the
organization who want to weaken the
security defenses be it for corporate
Espionage or to Aid other
masqueraders the category of individuals
that are authorized to use a system but
misuse the ground access and privilege
these are individuals that take undue
advantage of the permissions and give
access to them and this category of
intruders are known as
Misa misers are people that are insiders
and have direct access to the system
which they aim to attack unethically by
stealing data or
information let us now go through some
of the ways the idas platforms can
detect intrusion before it is too late
intrusion detection systems primarily
use two key methods one is signature Bas
intrusion and the anomaly based
intrusion signature based intrusion
detection is designed to detect possible
threats by comparing the given Network
traffic and log data to existing attack
patterns these patterns are called
sequences and could include bite
sequence which is also known as
malicious instruction sequences
signature based detection enables you to
accurately detect and identify possible
Lo attacks anomaly based intrusion
detection is the opposite it's designed
to pinpoint unknown attack such as new
malware and adapt to them on the Fly
using machine learning machine learning
techniques enable an intrusion detection
system to create baselines of
trustworthy activity which is known as a
trust model then compare new behaviors
to verified trust models false alarms
can occur when using an anomaly based
ideas since previously unknown yet
legitimate Network traffic could be
falsely identified as malicious activity
now if you combine both of those you
have the hybrid intrusion detection they
use signature based and an normally
based intrusion detection to increase
the scope of your ideas this enables you
to identify as many threats as possible
a comprehensive intrusion detection
system can understand the evasion
technique cyber criminals use to trick
and ideas to thinking there isn't an
attack taking place these techniques
could include fragmentation low
bandwidth attack pattern change evasion
and many
more we can now take a look at the type
of protection offered by IDs
platforms there are a couple of phase
that can be set up so let's go through
each
method the first is a network based
ideas the sensors are deployed at
strategic points within the network such
as within the DMZ or at the Network's
parameter the sensor can monitor
individual packets of inbound and
outbound traffic to and from all devices
on the network it analyzes them for
malicious activity and depending on the
network architecture and amount of
traffic involved multiple instances of
network based ideas may be necessary the
second category is host based intrusion
detection systems or
HIDs an agent runs on all servers
endpoints and devices in the network
that have access to both the internet
and the internal Network intrusions
identified by analyzing operating
specific activities like the
modification of the file system registry
or Access Control lists and the
monitoring system application logs as
well they augment network based idea
systems by detecting animalist traffic
which originate within the organization
or from the host that is being monitored
for example a host infected with malware
that is attempting to spread it to other
internal host is an issue that a network
based idas could potentially fail to
detect the third variant is a cloudbased
intrusion detection
system because of the internet facing
nature of the cloud on premises IDE
Solutions are not necessarily optimized
for
monitoring for example network-based
sensors need to be deployed within the
cloud at an environment's Network
perameter and yet a cloud service
provider may or may not have a way to
facilitate this cloud-based servers use
purpose build Cloud sensors that use
cloud service provider application
programming interface or cloud service
provider apis to get as much visibility
as possible into your Cloud
environment now that we understand the
different types of idas deployment
tactics let us go through some tools
that excel in this field offering
top-of-the-line implementations in a
corporate and consumer environment
the first tool being covered is the
solar wind security event
manager the solar wind security event
manager is designed to integrate
real-time log data from across your
infrastructure enabling it to act both
as a network based idea system and a
host based idea system the solution can
let you discover all kinds of malicious
attacks and help you protect your
network from harm it is also designed to
enact both signature based and anamaly
based intrusion detection by comparing
sequences of network traffic against a
set of customizable
rules next we have the McAfee life Safe
macafee Life safe is an inion detection
system designed to bring a real-time
threat awareness to your physical and
virtual networks it uses signature-based
intution prevention and anomaly based
intrusion detection along with emultion
techniques to spot and identify
malicious activity maafe is also built
to correlate threat activity with
application usage which can further
prevent network issues stemming from
cyber attacks
next we have bluma bluma is a security
information and event management
platform built to enact a detection and
responses across your cloud and on
premises environments it is designed to
continuously monitor your it
infrastructure for suspicious activity
and misconfigurations both of which
could result in data leaks and
compliance breaches it enables you to
respond to an attack in progress and
stop malicious actors in their tracks
monitoring usage of corporate data and
access to privilege information had been
a daunting task before the Advent of IM
am encompassing numerous apis single
signon Frameworks and data handling
policies imem has established itself as
a key component of every it department
but how does it enforce these rules and
who are the key benefactors of these
policies what about the advantages of
these Frameworks and the workflow of
these systems we are here today to
answer these questions let's take a look
at some of the topics to be covered
today
we start by learning about IM am that is
identity and access management from a
surface level so as to put a clear idea
of what it is next we cover the general
workflow and process of how I am Works
moving on we cover some of the tools
that find the place in an IM am
framework and are crucial
components finally we go through some of
the advantages of the I am learning what
makes them a lucrative deal for
organizations
so let's get started by learning about
IM am from a surface level
perspective identity and access
management or am is a set of processes
policies and tools for defining and
managing the roles and access privileges
of individual Network entities to a
variety of cloud and on premise
applications the users can include
customers Partners employees devices
like computers smartphones routers Etc
the core objective of IM systems is one
digital identity per individual or item
once the digital identity has been
established it must be maintained
modified and monitored throughout each
users or devices access life cycle
access and user are two vital IM
Concepts access refers to the actions
permitted to be done by a user like view
create or change a file users could be
employees Partners suppliers contractors
or even customers furthermore employees
can be further segmented based on their
roles IM systems are designed to perform
three key tasks identify authenticate
and authorized meaning that only the
right person should have access to
computers Hardware software apps any it
resources
etc for the entry of new users or the
changing of the roles of existing users
the list of access privileges must be up
to date all the time IM functions
usually fall under it departments or
section that handle cyber security and
management now that we understand the
importance of IM am in today's cyber
security sphere let us understand the
process of this framework we have
multiple components that Aid this
process let's start by going through
each of them
individually principal is an entity that
can perform actions on an awsc Source or
any Cloud management system a user a
role or an application can be a
principle it's always the principal who
raises a concern to access or modify
data on servers serving as the first
point of contact in the IM am
workflow authentication is the process
of confirming the identity of the
principal trying to access the product
the principal must provide s credentials
or required keys for authentication this
step can be further enhanced by multiple
authentication factors and Googs among
other things once the identity is
confirmed the principal has the ability
to view the data behind the wall of
security and take the necessary
steps when it comes to requests a
principal then sends a request to the
cloud management system specifying the
action and which resource should perform
it in this step the user can ask to
modify delete edit or affect other users
in this particular bucket of
organization by changing the data or the
information when it comes to
authorization it carries out the rest of
an organization identity and access
management processes once the user has
been authenticated users are granted
authorizations according to to the role
at an organization the practice is
referred to as role based access control
or
rbac authorizations determine a roles
resources and level of access in the
network these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more for example an accounting
department employee who regularly works
with payroll software must be authorized
to do such if authentication resembles a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it well
authentication is fully straightforward
authorizations and their management are
far more challenging authorizations
consist of complex set of rules and
policies and groups which are permitted
explicitly configured per user
account with the working of IM
Frameworks out of the way let's cover
some of the tools that these systems
work
on SSO is an IM tool that enables a user
to log into one an organization's
properties and automatically be logged
into a design set of other
properties for example when you log into
Google you're automatically logged into
your Gmail and your YouTube accounts
similarly for users single sign on
reduces fiction since they don't have to
keep track of different credentials for
every application for organizations SSO
helps in collecting valuable insights
about user behavior and preferences
since it taxs them as they move from one
application to another connected by one
single
login next is multiactor authentication
or
MFA implementing multiactor
authentication is crucial to protect the
organization's data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every IM
platform offers some form of
MFA however it's equally crucial to
customize MFA with the appropriate level
of security for example in business to
Consumer scenarios you need to consider
ux and try not to create unnecessary
fiction for users who don't want to be
subjected to heightened scrutiny every
time they log in for Workforce you may
want a more stringent MFA since the
consequences of an unauthorized party
gaining access to your private Network
can be so devastating a modern IM
solution will allow you to implement MFA
only when it's needed this can be
accomplished to set up authentication or
adaptive authentication in which users
only trigger MFA if they're trying to
access sensitive data or their behavior
is flagged as
risky in the past few years identity has
become the preferred Gateway for hackers
to break into systems Brute Force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted fishing campaigns
are all attempts by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box there are multiple ways IM
systems can help detect and mitigate
these malicious attacks IM Solutions
detect attacks with monitoring signals
such as the velocity of traffic
detection of login patterns that differ
from a user's routine use of a breached
password use of devices and IP addresses
with a poor reputation among other
things these are some of the most widely
used tools when it comes to IM
Frameworks but why do we go through
setting up so many tools and
firewalls let's go through some of the
advantages of using IM systems in both
corporate and consumer
environments IM solution helps identify
and mitigate security risks you can use
IM to identify policy violations or
remove inappropriate access privileges
without having to search through
multiple distributed systems you can
also leverage IM IM to ensure that
security measures are in place to meet
Regulatory and auditing
requirements IM provides a common
platform for Access and identity
management information you can apply the
same security policies across all the
operating systems and devices used by
the organization the IM framework can
help you enforce policies related to
user authentication Privileges and
validation and attend to the privilege
creep
problems IM simplifies signup and user
management processes for application
owners end users and syst system
administrators it makes it simple to
provide and manage access and promotes
user
satisfaction IM Services can also lower
operating costs using Federated identity
Services means you no longer need local
identities for external users this makes
application Administration easier
cloud-based IM Services can reduce the
need to buy and maintain on premise
infrastructure so importance of a cyber
security certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
the first is the training itself which
allows me to gain the knowledge which
allows me to understand the aspects of
security or whatever the certification
is there for the second aspect is the
exam itself how do I need to prepare
myself for the exam and how do I need to
approach the exam how do I need to
ensure that I pass in my first attempt
and the third aspect is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job rule so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that pre prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific role uh for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course with teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
Advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in the
job profiles so cyber security cred uh
certifications can be classified in
three different aspect aspects the first
one being the foundational level then
the managerial level and the advanced
level uh in the previous video we just
had a small overview here we are going
to discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
uh the price points for each and every
exam so let's start with the
foundational certifications we start off
with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish the routing uh the pathing of
how data packets will travel across the
network this certification covers all
the basic concepts that you require to
understand networking the basic
requirements for this certification are
that the candidate must have a
bachelor's degree but apart from that
there are no other prerequisites so it's
just that you need a bachelor's degree
and then you can apply uh you can study
for this you can undergo a training and
then you can attempt the exam uh the
certification provider obviously is
Cisco so the knowledge that is limited
to this training and certification is
for Cisco devices only the exam fees for
this certification is approximately
$325 the exam when it is conducted uh it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 90 minutes the
type of questions that you going to get
is multiple choice questions where you
have a question and four answers and you
have to choose the correct answers among
those drag and drop where you have to
click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate Place probably architectural
diagram and you have to let's say pick
on a router and place it into a
particular uh position if you place it
correctly you answer the answer the
question correctly otherwise it's wrong
and a simulator where you where there
could be a configuration you need to
configure it in a particular Manner and
then check whether the configuration is
correct or not the pass Mark is around
800 to 850 out of a possible th000 marks
so each question will have a different
weightage depending on the depth of the
question depending on the difficult
level of the question or the difficulty
level of the question which uh would
then count towards your marks and if you
score 800 to 850 that's when you clear
the exam the job roles as we have
discussed over here would be more more
on the network administrator side or a
network engineer side depending on the
level of experience that you have the
salaries uh that are expected from this
job roles in the US are around $55,000
to $90,000 annually the next one is the
comcha certification called Security
Plus comcha is also a global certific
ation Authority for uh infos courses so
this certification teaches candidates on
how to secure applications networks and
devices it focuses on Hands-On practical
skills in the field of network security
I have trained people on this
certification myself so uh I know this
certification it's quite Hands-On it
deals with the concepts to the core it
helps you understand the concepts and
then in the Practical Hands-On demo uh
you need to execute the Practical
yourself so that uh you can gain that
knowledge the recommended level for a
candidate to attempt this training would
be at least around 2 years of experience
in the it sector in addition if you have
already been certified for Network plus
certification from comia which is the
Baseline networking certification this
is also a preferred way to go for this
certification as said comcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is
$339 the exam is quite simple 90
questions in 90 minutes that's 1 minute
per question it sounds like a lot of
time but believe me the questions can be
a little little bit confusing can be a
little bit lengthy so you will require
all those 90 minutes to answer those
questions especially when they're tricky
and they're technically in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance- based the pass Mark for
this exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900 the job profiles for this
kind of a certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security engineer's position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization uh the
average annual salary of this uh person
would be around
$772,000 then comes the c or the
certified ethical hacker training from
EC Council now this is a very well-known
course and also uh EC council is a
global certifying Authority very well
accepted across a lot of countries uh
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from from an
ethical hackers perspective so the job
profiles that you'll be looking here are
of a pentester where you go into an
organization you test their security
controls or you'll test their devices
find out flaw flaws within them and then
provide recommendations of how to plug
those flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have 2 years of experience at least in
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of networking
maybe a little bit of applications
operating systems would be necessary uh
before attempting this certification the
certification provider is EC Council and
the exam fees for this certification is
$500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
4 hours and you will only get multiple
choice questions in here now for CH
there are two exams one is the multiple
choice questions and the second is a
practical exam where uh you need to
solve some given problem s to you in a
IAB scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified for CH practical the cut off
varies from 65 to 85% depending on the
questions that you have answered and the
weightage associated with each and every
question as said the job roles would be
as a penetration tester a security
engineer and your salaries would start
from around $90,000 annually then comes
the CND or the certified Network
Defender also from EC Council now this
is more on the network defense side so
here again the job rues would be where
you where there's a network that you
have and you're going to try to secure
the network and the communications that
are going to travel over the network so
you need to be a network administrator
network security engineer or uh in a
similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate provider again is EC Council
and the certification is placed a little
bit below C so it becomes Network
defense then C where you're going to
become a penetration Tester the exam
fees for this ification is
$350 the exam the exam is of 100
questions to be answered in 4 hours
again it's just a multiple choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question the
pass percentage again varies from 60 to
85% depending on the questions answered
and the weightage of that question job
rules to be applied Network defense
technician CN analyst or a security
analyst from a network perspective
salaries would range from 65,000 to
75,000 ,000 per anom then comes the
forensic investigator course which is
exactly what it is digital forensic
investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve that
data to investigate a crime that has uh
taken place so the candidate must have
at least 2 years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is s after mainly in the
law enforcement areas but there are a
few corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when a corporate gets compromised and
they want to uh conduct their own
investigations the certification
provider for this is also AC Council and
the exam fees are $500 this is an
advanced level certification so uh
understanding of applications networks
and operating systems is a must before
you attemp this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in 4 hours again
it's just a multiple choice question
exam the cut off again is from 60% to
85% depending on the questions and the
weightage of each and every question job
rules it security specialist network
security pro the job roles forensic
investigators law enforcement agencies
security Specialists homeland security
jobs and your salaries would be around
$888,000 and above all right now let's
talk about the manager level
certification ations Coit stands for
control objectives for information and
related Technologies it's a
certification that will give a candidate
an in-depth knowledge of the framework
which kobit is all about and the
framework helps you manage and govern
Enterprise it environments now this is
Advanced certification so around 8 years
of manager experience is suggested
before you attempt the Coit 5
certification to understand all the
aspects and to help you implement the
framework properly the certification
certificate provider is isaka the exam
fees around
$175 now this is a small exam 50
questions but in 40 minutes so you
really have to be on your toes you have
to know the knowledge there's a very
limited time to think and you have to be
fast in your answers the past percentage
is 50% the job roles associated with
this certification would be to uh when
you apply for uh information security
manager or as a security consultant or a
cyber security manager and your roles
and responsibilities would be to govern
and uh it space that the organization
owns so all the servers desktops the
network the data flows the data basis
everything and how it needs to be
managed and how it needs to be governed
in a secure manner annual salaries would
be around $100,000 plus then the cism
also called as sism it stands for
certified information security manager
and as the name suggests it's a security
manager certification it helps the
candidate in understanding the
relationship between business goals and
and information security so now you're
going into the space where you're not
only technical in nature but you also
have to understand the business needs
the goals of the business and you have
to align the information security of
your infrastructure along with the
business needs and the business goals so
it is your inputs that are going to go
to the management to see if the
infrastructure is aligned to the
business goals or if the infrastructure
or the business goals need any
fine-tuning around 5 years of work
experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the 5 years
the candidate must have a background as
an information security manager for 3
years so you have some experience as a
manager uh you have implemented those
things yourselves which will give you a
better understanding and then you
attempt the certification again
providing by isaka and the exam fees for
isaka members is
$575 for nonmembers it is
$760 the exam is where you have to
answer 150 questions in 4 hours uh quite
a bit of time but questions are going to
be uh scenario based questions where
they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the pass Mark is 450 out of 800
your job profiles would be either a risk
manager or a risk consultant analyzing
the business requirements to the
infrastructure security that uh that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around $888,000 and above then the cesa
or the cisa the certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
5 years of work work experience in the
field of Information Systems auditing
control or security is necessary now
here the question would be what's the
difference security is where you're
technical in nature you have done let's
say a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even uh UTM
and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
uh ISO 2701 guidelines or the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members are
$575 whereas non isaka members will have
to pay $760 for the certification 150
questions again in 4 hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand the real world
scenarios of where what controls and
what audit mechanism should be in place
pass Mark is 450 out of 800 your job
rules would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or a Information
Technology consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103,000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as crisk uh
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this is is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in Europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of a role you should
have a minimum of three years of
experience in the field of is controls
that means information security controls
you should have knowledge about
Fireballs you should know about how to
mediate risks how to identify risks in
the first place risk analysis risk
management and after which you're going
to implement security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it to
acceptable levels at this point in time
you will also be responsible to create
policies revolving those risks and how
you want to calculate those risks and
treat those risks in their lifetime
certificate provider again is isaka $575
for isaka members $760 for non isaka
members for the exam fees a similar
question 150 questions to be answered in
4 hours multiple choice based on
performances so they may give you a
scenario where you have to perform a
risk analysis and provide a report and a
solution based on your findings again
the pass Mark is 450 out of 800 the job
profiles Associated as discussed earlier
are the it risk management professionals
where they're going to identify risks
treat those risks calculate analyze
maybe do a business impact analysis to a
certain how uh the organization is going
to be affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job roles are concerned average annual
salary would be 119,000 and above moving
on to advanced level certification now
this is where we come across a cissp or
the cisp certification certified
information system security professional
this is the gold standard of all
certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the IT world now
just to qualify you'll have to have 5
years of experience in the information
uh security field there are eight
domains that are specific ified by cissp
and you have to prove that you have
knowledge and you have work experience
of around 5 years in at least two of
those domains if you do not have those
kind of experiences you can still
attempt the exam but you become an
associate of ISC Square which means that
you get six years to accomplish the 5
years of uh experience requirement for
this certification before taking up the
cisp certification it is suggested that
the candidate clears all the
intermediate level certifications not
all but some of them in fact I've seen
people do the other way around they
qualify for cissp they give the exam
once your cissp the cisa or cesm CIS or
cism exams are way easier to crack but
you need to have that kind of experience
I have seen people with 15 years of
experience and more fail at this
certification in the first attempt the
certificate provided is IC Square the
exam fees is
$699 like I said this certification is
where most sought after the gold
standard in fact there is hardly any
other certifications after this that you
might want to do the questions now the
exam has changed if it is the English
version that you're giving it's 150
questions to be answered in 3 hours if
it is a non-english exam that you're
attempting then it is 250 questions in 6
hours it's a marathon and if you're
opting for the 6- hour exam you need to
plan it really well it sounds really
easy but the questions are quite tough
they're scenario based and the answers
are quite confusing as well you would
get multiple choice questions you would
get drag and drop and you might get
simulators as well uh the pass Mark is
700 out of 1,000 but each question has a
different weightage so uh it depends on
which questions are asked of you and
which questions you've answered
correctly the job rules associated with
this certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the ceso role the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is
$18,000 for this certification and if
you're someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security that
is by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who sits
to switch careers with cyber security by
learning from the experts and try giving
a short to Simply learns postgraduate
program in cyber security with modules
from the MIT schwarzman College of
Engineering and the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered and before
we begin if you're someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security or to become an ethical hacker
by graduating from the best universities
or a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts and
try giving a short to Simply lar
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of computing the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered in
today's interconnected world the
significance of cyber security has
reached Paramount levels as technology
continues to advance at an unprecedent
pace so do the risk and threats lurking
in the digital landscape recently in
April 2023 the shields Healthcare Group
a medical service provider located in
Massachusetts experiened the most
significant data breach towards the end
of the month report surface revealing
that an individual involved in cyber
crime had illicitly accessed the
organization systems and successfully
obtained the personal information of
approximately 2.3 million individuals
organizations and individuals alike are
realizing the critical need for
qualified professionals who possesses
the skills to defend against cyber
attacks one such certification that has
gained widespread recognition is the
certified ethical hacker or C
certification so in this video on step
by-step guide to crack C CH exam we will
be covering various topics like why C
what is C exam eligibility criteria for
C and how to prepare for C exam also
make sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and press the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn now
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question so which of the following
terms describes an individual who gains
unauthorized access to computer systems
with malicious intent option A is white
hat hacker option b is blackhe hacker
option C is gray hat hacker and option D
is script Kitty now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below now let's start with the first
topic which is YC or certified ethical
hacker so there is a high demand for
cyber security experts in various
businesses to hire these experts
organizations have certain requirements
these profession need to have a good
understanding of security Concepts and
be familiar with the latest tools
processes and Frameworks to stay ahead
of cyber criminals and prevent data
breaches certifications like C or
certified ethical hacker offered by EC
Council play a significant role in this
scenario the CH programming is designed
to train ethical hackers comprehensively
covering the latest hacking Trends and
introducing professionals to
technologies that help prevent data
breaches this certification is
recognized globally meaning your skills
and knowledge will be valued by
organizations around the world
regardless of your location the course
instructs participants on practical
strategies that can be used in real life
situations and future careers the CH
exam focuses on understanding how
malicious individuals exploit weaknesses
in addition to offering promising job
prospects the C certification training
provides a wealth of knowledge that is
not easily obtained through other
information security courses so if you
are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities
then try giving a shot at simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schatzman College
of Engineering the link is in the
description box that will navigate to
the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered also have a look at what our
Learners has to say about the course hi
I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old and last
year I upskill with simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the it sector
and various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccs P certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course course I must say was packed
with practical examples it was led by
highly skilled certified instructors
with many companies before as a security
analyst and architect on a contract
basis but I needed some stability which
I got with the job I just started with
infosis as a cyber security consultant
happened on the first now let us
understand about this certified ethical
hacker or C exam so the C exam focuses
on theoretical understanding and does
not involve hacking actual systems it
emphasizes comprehension of hacking
Concepts tools and methodologies however
to obtain the C Master's designation you
must also pass a six hour practical exam
with 20 challenges this exams evaluates
your practical application of Knowledge
and Skills in real life scenarios but
that's a choice if you want to apply for
Masters so the CH exam is 4 hours long
the exam consists of 125 multiple choice
questions the passing score required for
certification where is depending on the
specific exam some exams state in
passing score as a percentage While
others Bas it on the difficulty of
questions and the knowledge or skills
needed to demonstrate competence in the
subject the actual cut score determined
by subject matter experts depends on the
difficulty of the questions and ensures
fairness in evaluation skills if you
encounter more challenging questions few
correct answers are needed to pass while
an easier set of questions requires
higher percentage of correct answers
thus performance relative to the passing
standard can be higher even with fewer
correct answers in a difficult question
set so now let's have a look at the
sections so the sections covered in the
program includes section number one that
is background then there is section
number two which is analysis or
assessment then there is section number
three security then comes section number
four tools systems and programs section
five is procedures and methodology
section six is regulation and policy IC
section seven is ethics so this was
about the C exam now let's have a look
at its eligibility criteria so the
eligibility criteria for CH exam before
you start preparing for CH exam it's
important to meet certain requirements
firstly you must show this EC Council
that you have at least two years of
experience in information security and a
specialization in that field through
your educational background additionally
keep in mind that the CH exam has a cost
of $100
and make sure you fulfill these criteria
before moving forward to avoid wasting
your time so this was about the
eligibility criteria for CH exam now
let's understand how to prepare for CH
exam so the first step in preparing for
CH exam is joining a forum so there are
many online forums and blogs dedicated
to C where people with similar interest
and goals gather these forums are filled
with individuals who are either
preparing for CH exam or have already
taken it they share value able tipss
strategies and general advice based on
their experiences by participating in
these forums you can interact with other
C students and professionals this allows
you to exchange knowledge and discover
each other's strengths and weaknesses
it's a great way to identify areas where
you may need to improve your
understanding remember what one person
is good at another person may struggle
with through discussions on the Forum
you can learn from others and reinforce
your own knowledge through repetition
which helps with better retention the
second thing you can do is create
important topics checklist so once you
have identified the areas where you lack
knowledge as a hacker it's important to
make a checklist of study topics
prioritize the topics that need more
attention don't forget to allocate some
study time to the topics you already
know it's always beneficial to reinforce
and refresh your existing knowledge
however the main focus should be on
addressing the knowledge gaps First Once
you have addressed those gaps you can
revisit the other topics later along
with this you can also take up EC
council certification assessment EC
council certification assessments refers
to the international evaluation process
conducted by the international Council
of electronic Commerce Consultants the
certification assessment typically
involves an examination that accesses
the candidates understanding of the
relevant Concepts tools and best
practices in their chosen certification
track the exam is educational and the
questions are beneficial for studying
purposes using the training platform the
candidate can access the levels of
Readiness and analyze their preparedness
for the exam along with taking self
assessment you can also take help from
study guides while we emphasize the
importance of not relying solely on
books it cannot be denied that books
hold a wealth of knowledge when
preparing for the C exam it is essential
to thoroughly read the recommended books
this approach will addresses all your
what and why questions regarding cyber
security and ethical hacking the content
provided in these books is of top
quality offering precise definitions
descriptions and diagrams for almost
every topic we suggest dedicating at
least 1 hour daily to study in order to
grasp all the concepts covered in the
training so by understanding the exam
objectives setting up study plan
utilizing quality resources and
reviewing your weak areas you are well
equipped for Success remember to stay
focused manage your time effectively and
maintain a positive mindset throughout
your preparation with dedication and
perseverance you can confidently
approach the CH exam and achieve your
CER ification goals hello and welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel in today's
video we will be discussing the
Intriguing world of ethical hacking with
the rise of cyber threats and the
increasing need for robust cyber
security ethical hackers have become an
integral part of the modern digital
landscape in this video we will explore
what ethical hacking is why ethical
hacking are in high demand salary Trends
in the field of ethical hacking skills
required for a career in ethical hacking
and tips for starting a successful
career as an ethical hacker at the end
of this video we will be sharing some
useful tips so keep watching till the
end of this video so let's dive in
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question so what is the main goal
of an ethical hacker option A is to hack
into systems and steal sensitive
informations option b is to test and
identify vulnerabilities in systems and
networks option C is to create new
security threats and exploits option D
is to cause harm and damage to the
Target organization now you can pause
the video and answer in the comment
section below so let's start with the
first topic IC that is what is ethical
hacking ethical hacking also known as
whad hacking is the practice of
intentionally probbing computer systems
networks or applications to identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses the main
difference between ethical hackers and
malicious hackers is the intent and
legality of their actions ethical
hackers operate with the permission of
the system honor and their goal is to
identify vulnerabilities before they can
be exploited by malicious hackers they
use their skills and knowledge to help
organization strengthen their cyber
security defenses and protect sensitive
data from unauthorized access as
Reliance on technology and the internet
continues to grow so does the risk of
cyber threats organizations both large
and small are constantly seeking ways to
secure their digital assets and
Safeguard their business operations the
demand has led to a significant need for
skilled ethical hackers who can
proactively identify and fix
vulnerabilities in systems ethical
hackers play a crucial role in helping
organization prevent data breaches
protect customer information maintain
compliance with industry regulations and
Safeguard their reputation with the
increasing awareness of cyber security
threats ethical hackers are in high
demand across various Industries
including Finance Healthcare technology
and government sectors now let's discuss
some salary trends for ethical hackers
the rising demand for cyber security
expertise has led to a significant need
for ethical hackers consequently skilled
Professionals in the field have
experienced favorable salary Trends in
recent years several factors impact the
salaries of ethical hackers including
their experience certifications industry
and region the roles that fall under the
umbrella of an ethical hacker may
include penetration tester penetration
tester also known as pentester if you're
interested in pursuing a career as a
penetration tester you will need to
develop a strong skill set in various
technical areas including programming
operating system networking and cyber
security principles pent testers are
responsible for conducting authorized
test on computer systems networks and
applications to identify vulnerabilities
and and weaknesses and provide
recommendation for improving security
with an average salary of 5 lakhs per
year in India and
$12,000 in the United States becoming a
penetration tester can be productive
career choice simply learns professional
certificate program in ethical hacking
and penetration testing is designed to
equip you with the necessary skills to
analyze the threat landscape and develop
strategies to ensure the stability and
security of systems through Hands-On
training in real world cases you will
master essential cyber security skills
in just 6 months you will learn the
advanced cyber security strategies that
will enable you to protect networks and
data from breaches next is vulnerability
accessor this role involves identifying
and accessing potential vulnerabilities
in computer systems networks and
applications using various tools and
techniques to determine the level of
risk associated with those
vulnerabilities the average salary of a
vulnerability accessor is 950,000 in
India and $61,000 in the the United
States next up we have information
security analyst an information security
analyst is a professional responsible
for protecting and organization
information assets including Data
Systems Network and applications from
potential security breaches and cyber
threats information security analysts
play a critical role in safeguarding
sensitive information and ensuring the
confidentiality integrity and
availability of data the average salary
of an information security analyst is 6
lakhs per year in India and 9 $9,000 per
year in the United States the Caltech
cyber security boot camp is designed to
help you develop the skills needed for
this Ru this comprehensive course
curriculum covers defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensics penetration testing
infrastructure design and much more
you'll have the access to labs and
assisted practices that expose you to
several in demand cyber security tools
allowing you to gain practical hands-on
experience in a supportive learning
environment security analyst this this
role involves monitoring and analyzing
computer systems networks and
applications for security incidents and
breaches and taking appropriate actions
to respond to and mitigate these
incidents the average salary of an
information security analyst is 6 lakhs
per year in India and 999,000 per year
in the United States now let's discuss
skills required for a career in ethical
hacking a successful career in ethical
hacking requires strong foundation in
cyber security and a diverse skill set
some of the key skills that aspiring
ethical hackers should possess include
Proficiency in programming language such
as python C++ and Java understanding of
networking Concepts like protocols
knowledge of operating systems and
databases expertise in tools and
Technologies used in ethical hacking
such as Metasploit wi shark and nmap and
familiarity with cyber security
Frameworks and best practices
additionally ethical hackers should have
excellent problem solving skills
critical thinking abilities attention to
detail and the ability to work
independent or as a part of the team
continuous learning and staying updated
with the latest developments in cyber
security is also a crucial for
successful career in ethical hacking now
let's have a look at some tips starting
a career as an ethical hacker can be
exciting and rewarding here are some
tips to help you Kickstart your journey
first is demonstrate an ethical hacker
mindset develop curiosity problem
solving and continuous learning mindset
to excel in the field of ethical hacking
second is obtain relevant certifications
certifications like C calch cyber
security boot camp oscp and advanced
executive programming cyber security
these certifications add credibility and
demonstrate expertise these
certifications will help you in securing
a nice job in the market third is build
practical experience practice ethical
hacking in a controlled environment such
as setting up your own lab or practicing
in CTF competitions to gain hands-on
experience Real World experience will
help you develop practical skills and
insights into different types of systems
networks and applications next is stay
updated with the latest threats and
Technology cyber security landscape is a
constantly evolving and it's a crucial
to stay updated with the latest threats
vulnerabilities and Technologies follow
industry blogs forums and new sources
practice in online communities and
attend conferences and workshops to stay
informed and continuously improve your
skills and that's a rep congratulations
on completing the ethical hacker full
course you are now armed with the
insights and skills to navigate the
complex world of cyber security
responsibility and ethically if you like
this session then like share and
subscribe if you have any questions then
you can drop them in the comment section
below thanks for watching and stay tuned
for more from Simply loar staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge do domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here